I a joke to you? >> Wait, so you're telling me that that
the current president is more authoritative of what the constitution
is than uh than a document the constitution itself that was written
this many years ago? >> Communist manifesto the communist
manifesto that is not authoritative on socialism but Hassan is
not authoritative. Hassan >> pull the Lauren Southern card
Pisco pull it now I for me personally I wouldn't do it. You think
we're asking you personally or you think we're this whole purpose
is what you're prescribing your
Holy Connor, everyone knows your your standard was I don't really
have a problem using the socialist label if you're a politician,
but I do have a problem with it with your media figure. So, I'm
testing your logic. I'm testing. >> We're not here to test
my entire internal internal
preposterous. I asked you guys to think you can name a single
other socialist figure in media that supports an immigrant party
and can name one person. You can't even name one person here
so
to the left. You can't even name one
>> guys. specifically just going to have more nitpicking
on the sides. Well, he encourages and frankly I think smears
us as as tankies, anti-liberal,
terms and to notice actually what is the room of substantive
disagreement here or is all this a fugazi to cover up spite and
personal conflict between him and other streamers? Um, and is
there really evidence that we're moving to the tanky left or
the illiberal left? >> Okay. Well, thank you for being
here and I'm I'm sure we will get into all of that. Let's give
it first to counterpoints. Go ahead. >> Yeah. So the my
my issue with this whole thing is that there are socialists which
I define I think in a good faith way for the decommodification
of basic human need and workers owning the means of production.
There are also communists who believe that the end result of
our material analysis should be a moneyless stateless classless
society. I think these people exist. I think they have clout.
I think they have influence. And uh I would use in our sphere
of influence like Aaron or straight raid who says that she's
a communist. I would use the examples like Hassan who I just
watched earlier today is effectively >> okay we do have
counterpoints here guys I don't do a blast off tweet today okay
we're not doing a blast off tweet I'm going to put this Democrats
and the Democratic social can get clout and influence and then
radicalize them down a funnel so for me what I'm trying to point
out is that if you pretend that this person is normal and nice
and fine and a part of the coalition then you're going to lose
the moderates you're going to lose the center right
to speak to them uh specifically about their politics, but if
MLS are a part of the coalition, you're losing people. You're
being uh politically ineffective. That's my argument. >> Okay,
thank you for being here. And last, but certainly not least,
Destiny. Go ahead. >> Yeah. So I think that when I was
making the rounds debating Nazis in 2018, one of the most common
things that I heard from kind of like the centrists that basically
gave more credence to all of the farright ideas was point to
where I support this. Show me where I said that I'm racist. Show
me where I say that I hate people or I
white supremacist. And there was always this like annoying fight
that I would have to do where in order to start debating the
I'd have to chew through all of these epic centrists first who
would say, "Well, I'm just a classical liberal. I'm Sargon of
AOD. I'm not actually a white supremacist. I just happen to give
cover for all >> Oh, guys, I don't have to I don't have
to prove anything against Pisco because that would be, you know,
that would take a lot of time. >> Think they're becoming
tankies or anything like that. I just think there's >> It
would take a long time for me to do anything to say anything
direct about what Pisco said. >> We we can 100% discern
and decipher every single intention that Donald Trump has. No
problem calling him a fascist outright. But then when you have
people that hate the Democrats, that [__] on our
candidates, that attack everybody on our side constantly, we're
like, well, I don't know what they, you know, what they really
think or how they really feel or when it comes to people like
Assan, um, you know, like even earlier today on my subreddit,
you know, a boy when asked about supporting Assan will say things
like, well, I don't think I necessarily agree. >> So that's
basically comparing Pisco to Sargon and other people who eventually
became that's implying that there's some truly hell belief there
that he will continue on with, right? So, so that's the problem
with Saron is he actually went and became like a borderline,
right? So, Destiny just made another baseless accusation, another
bas baseless tie to a different person, right? That's that's
insane with him um on everything. I like he says uh I had a I
don't have a generally positive view of Hassan and I think I
would flatly agree with many of the criticisms Lebi at Hassan.
That's just in my mind even though it seems like there's some
kind of separation there. That's just a wild statement to make
from somebody who
>> another fantastic point in Zane. How does Destiny make
that point when he then went and hung out with Nick Fentes and
went, "Oh, where do you think my beliefs intersect with Nick
Fuentes is? Wait, where do you believe think my beliefs intersect
with Lauren Southerns?" Right? So, he literally did these things.
He used these defenses after he had that 2016 2018 arc. So, it's
insane that he's sitting here now and going, "Well, actually,
like you know, you don't have to prove what I think. He supports
terrorist groups." >> Sorry, you I don't have to prove
what you think, Pisco. I don't have to prove what you've said.
I just I'm just going to say that this is a problem. ians or
openly supports enemies of the United States or openly supports
the subversive propagandizing of our entire political party to
hijack the entire movement to destroy um if not the Democratic
Party, maybe even all of the entire United States of America.
So, um I'm sure we'll get into it. Uh I don't think that it's
I don't think it it behooves us to just say all this is a semantic
disagreement. And I think it's actually really important to define
what a leftist is because I think that it's important for the
people to know where everybody stands. And it's important to
get rid of people that are intentionally trying to obscure their
beliefs and come in under the guise of being a leftist without
actually stating, you know, what their position is and then having
this like uh this this role that they get to play propagandize
people
without actually ever stating what it >> So so Destiny
can't say this because Destiny was a close personal friend of
Pisco. Destiny's had close personal conversations with Pisco,
right? So he's he's implying this. It's like, Destiny, how what
does this say about your judgment of people that this was like
one of your best friends who you're thinking about moving to
New York City to do content with? Are you serious? What changed
here about your judgment of Pisco? What changed? Are you out
of your mind? Like 3 months ago, you wanted to Sorry. Like 6
months ago, you wanted to move to New York with this guy. You
wanted to go start a studio there and do Democratic politics
with him. And now he's suddenly a socialist. Are you >> They're
trying to do um Yeah. like are are you for the complete and total
abolition of our democracy or are you just somebody who wants
the government to do more stuff? >> And just to get clarity
so we know what we're talking about destiny, are you saying that
Econboy and Pisco are running cover for those leftists that you
think are um infecting the Democratic party or however you want
to put it, right? >> Yes. But I don't think it's like I
don't think it's like a I don't think it's like a um like they're
secretly tanky and so they want to provide cover for their tanky
friends. I think it's more just like this um there's something
that happens in the Democrat brain and I've been guilty of it
too where you're so obsessively trying to seem like even-handed
that you get rooted out in this world where you're like I you
know I'm trying to be fair and I don't want to have like Hassan
derangement syndrome so I'm just going to say you know they're
not that bad I don't know that much about any of this I'm not
sure whatever but what it happens what it causes is this reality
where you know the conversation for this podcast what was talked
about earlier was should we appeal to leftists when it comes
to gaining political power when do leftists talk about appealing
to liberals to try to gain political power or when do leftists
say hey maybe we should chill on the party, you know, forever
and ever when it comes to getting political power. Like, why
is the conversation only ever on the Democratic side of things?
That's just very wild to me. >> The Big 10 strategy, obviously,
>> the floor is open. Go ahead. >> Should some I
have a question.
I I have a question. Yeah. So, this is both to Connor and to
Stephen. Should some socialists, at least some be catered to,
be appealed to, and be part of the
>> So, you would agree therefore that Bernie Sanders, AOC,
and Mammdi should not be catered to and part of the coalition?
Correct. Depends what you mean when you say catered to. >> Should
they
support ahead of a ticket being a socialist like AOC mom Donnie
if they are the nominees should we support them? >> Yes.
But that doesn't mean you're catering to socialism. >> Okay.
But but you understand wait you recognize that supporting somebody
at the top of a ticket. Well you play the answer yes or no question.
I can play the same game. You understand that supporting somebody
being at the top. >> Uh that's him trying to prevent Pisco
from actually walking him down lines of argumentation. Right.
He's going to do the Trump. This is the Trump play, right? I'm
I'm going to say oh well if you want to do this really annoying
thing you do. I guess you could just do
doesn't mean that you are centrally supporting their ideology.
For instance, it's possible to cater to a roundabout way people
are further to the left of you without catering to far leftist
beliefs. Right. >> Correct. But you would agree like if
a socialist is at the top of the ticket, socialist like Bernie
Sanders, the Democratic party should support the socialist at
top of the ticket. Correct. >> But generally, yeah, I think
you should >> you're okay with socialist in part of the
coalition. Correct. >> I don't really know if I consider
Bernie Sanders or AOC to be like socialists. >> And why
is that exactly? >> Um because I don't because I don't
think that they like fit under conventional
the basic human needs. >> Yeah. So that's your definition
of socialist
socialist socialist definition.
Do you disagree with my >> Yeah. Okay. So just to just
to hop in here. So I I I disagree that that is okay. Do you want
me to answer the >> Give econ boy space to answer. Go ahead.
>> Let let answer. Go ahead. >> I probably should
have done an edible instead of a before entering this debate.
Um but the to answer your question um similar to capitalism,
socialism is a diverse universe of people. There's a lot of people
who call themselves socialists. Some of them are Marxist Linist.
Some of them are like what you might call like moderate like
right-wing socialists I guess like me who say that we should
just collectivize the ownership of production. People have different
ways of deming these things. For instance, capitalism includes
people all the way from Fabian Liberty to people like Destiny
who basically >> Why are we acting like like any definition
here is going to be like >> versus the Nordic model, right?
And they they're both capitalists, right? And so I think that
of the 10% of people who call themselves socialists and are part
of the Democratic party base, obviously that's a >> I'll
say right off the hop, I'm already very surprised that Destiny
is going to basically tie Pisco to Sargon of AOD. I did not think
he'd get this aggressive because I feel like he has to understand
he doesn't have the facts on him on his side, but he is like
going very aggressive right from the start. Oh, Pisco, you're
basically Sargon. I'm worried you're >> very diverse group
of people ranging from the exact essentially people that I just
mentioned as well. And I think that's a very sensible way to
look at who calls themselves socialist and why to Destiny's point
of >> Donnie is not a socialist or that Bernie's not a
socialist. That's crazy. >> Just just one more sentence
to Destiny's point about when do like the leftwingers ever cater
to the moderates. Well, I mean I seem to remember people like
Bernie Sanders and AOC taking very collaborative positions with
people like Biden when he was in office. And I seem to recall
like Manny, he took a very collaborative position with people
like Brad Lander. And Mani's campaign to the extent that it appealed
to people broader than just the left wing, he made that conscious
decision to do that. He didn't run on a campaign of seizing the
means of production. He ran on a campaign of like freezing the
rent and providing child care to people, right? I mean, I take
that to be in some sense a a means to cater to a broader base
of people than just leftwingers
>> So, I think that if we want to talk about catering >> so
that so then that's an example of leftists catering to liberals.
That's exactly what Destiny said doesn't happen. Are you saying
that happens exactly a boy? Like that precise thing he said never
happens. You're saying that happens exactly with Bernie, with
AOC, with Mamani. Okay, cool.
I think that the issue that we have is there exists a
bunch of like Bernie Sanders maybe.
And I think that if we lived in a world where there was a rich
media environment with a lot of people who were socialists who
you know some supported the liberals, some kind of didn't, some
were like really against it, then we could have that conversation.
But right now, it seems basically ubiquitous across the entirety
of the leftwing media landscape to aggressively and violently
on and attack Democratic candidates as harshly as possible. I
just saw, and I'm sure you guys saw that Vanguard tweet saying
that Pete Buddha just looked like and smelled like a rat. Um
Pete is one of the most like popular Democratic figures making
the rounds on shows. I just watched um Crystal Ball roast the
out of a senator from Michigan u because she wouldn't give like
the singular one answer on the Gazin issue. uh if this is the
world we're going to live in where you want to say oh well socialism
encompasses a broad range of people but when I looked at the
media environment almost every single person that
socialist relentlessly on the Democratic party I don't know if
I can really say yeah sure we should also appeal to these people
it's just not the right medial issue here which is you're saying
that Bernie Sanders and Zoran Mdani are not socialist explain
that >> that's not really responsive to anything I just
said >> no no because you weren't you you were so you were
not responsive to the to the yeah so the question is if you're
defining socialism to only include the people that Steven doesn't
like, then maybe there's not actually a disagreement here in
terms of who like should be leading the party or >> I wasn't
people I don't like. I was defining social. So, we can talk about
definition socialism. What I'm looking at right now is the socialist
media environment. My earlier argument was that I don't know
if I would even consider like Bernie. >> When does Hassan
argue to seize the mean of the sees the means of production as
a political uh position for the Democrats or anybody who runs
in America? When has he ever argued for that as a position? Right.
Hassan is the same as mom Donnie or AOC or whoever the we're
talking about in that when he's talking about American politics
he advocates for things that are actually somewhat possible under
the American political system. He's never argued for oh yeah
Bernie should run on ceasing the means of production. That'd
be insane. >> Bernie Sanders AOC to be hardcore socialist.
If I wanted to socialist at all well right now who are the socialists
all almost more than anybody else and Bernie Sanders. So I mean
>> whether they're on them or not even whether they're
or not isn't the question. That's a separate question. Are they
or not? The question is should socialists be part of the coalition.
You just said that Bernie isn't a socialist. Socialist. He identifies
as such. AOC is not a socialist. She identifies as such. Money
is a socialist. She identifies as such. What's your evidence
they're not >> So identifying that's a tautology that would
be nonsense. Number one. And number two, the question wasn't
should they be part of the coalition. The question is should
we appeal to them? Those are two fundamentally completely different
questions. >> That's to be clear though you and you're
narrowing your position. It was just last night when you said
explicitly anyone that uses the socialist label should be treated
like an R. >> In the media environment, in the media environment
is what we're talking about. I'm comfied then Destiny. Okay.
Well, that's what you said last night. We're clarifying just
people within the media environment. Then I'm just saying that
that's a that's a useful narrowing of the discussion then because
>> you can call it a narrowing if you want but anybody
that's watched any like I don't on AOC I don't on Bernie Sanders
>> I think useful is one way to put about it. I think useful
is one way to put it. I think I think weasly is another way to
put it and I think it is weasly. I think you're backing off of
the strong position. The strong position is socialist shouldn't
be a part of our coalition. And now when you're getting
the media environment yeah but you didn't say socialist shouldn't
be part of the coalition. I said we shouldn't be trying to actively
appeal to socialists. Do you understand that those are two separate
things? >> Hold on. Actually, no. No, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, dude. Everybody around you I So, I haven't watched
enough Destiny to know for sure, but Destiny said, "These people
are cancer. They need to be cut out. They need to be totally
cut out. We shouldn't talk to them at all." Right. So, now I
do believe he's narrowing his position because Hassan specifically
was somebody that's a cancer. We need to cut him out. We shouldn't
talk to him at all. Right. What the [__] are you
statements? They're correct. Two different statements, but you
>> know what I mean? Fundamentally, two >> They're
two different statements that mean different things. They're
two different statements that mean two different things. But
your position, is it your position therefore that the Democrats
should as part of their coalition in terms of who to vote for,
what kind of policy to support to humor people like Mandani Mandani,
humor people like AOC and humor people like Bernie Sanders? And
if that's the truth, then I I think that >> I don't know
what that mean. Should they humor them? Like what does that mean?
Like put them >> Oh. Oh, yeah. Yeah. So Pisco is basically
going to say, "Oh, we don't have a disagreement then. You actually
are totally fine with these people. Then we don't have a disagreement.
Thank you for uh thank you for coming to my position. Thank you
very much, Destiny. Uh I I'll enjoy your next debate." >> I
don't know what that question means. >> So should they
just have a seat at the table? Whatever you take that seat at
the table asking you. So, so for example, you're the one you're
the one who says that we need to excise these people from the
from the part. I actually don't know what you mean by that. So,
whatever your vision of be having a seat at the table not being
excised, whatever you're using when you say these people need
to be gone under that do you think? Sure. >> Let's let
Destiny those are good questions. Pico and I'd like to know the
answers too. Right. What do you mean destiny when you say we
need to excise these people? What like how do you see >> My
fixation is almost universally on the >> What do what do
you mean by excise? Oh, well I mean like probably don't cater
to. That's not what exise means at all. You ever when I'm having
these conversations, I think um when I was watching you guys
talk, it was also generally on the although sometimes you guys
would try to go back to AOC, but like politicians operate kind
of in a different world than the media environment operates.
And most of my criticisms on the media environment, the media
environment that all calls themselves like leftist or socialist
seem to relentlessly on Democrats and I just think it's a really
unhealthy and bad world again where you see a Michigan senator
wants to go into the podcasting world. And one of the jokes I
made about comma is one of the reason why she probably didn't
do any shows is because she would get by the right, the centrist,
and the left. and she goes on a lefty show and she gets on because
they only want to talk about Palestine. This is a senator from
a from a blue state from Michigan. Jesus, that's insane to me.
And I just I it would be nice if we actually had like a strong
center-le position and a strong center left media apparatus and
not just a bunch of leftists who hate the party. >> Wait,
wait, do do you understand our position to be that we disagree
with your assessment that leftists constantly on the on the Democrats?
Do you think that we disagree on that? >> Um, I'm not sure
all the time. I can't >> You're not sure. So, so we actually
we're here to discuss something where you're not sure if we agree
with you on the position that the the lefties constantly Democrats
in ways we don't like. We agree that lefties constantly on Democrats
that in ways that we don't like. We agree with Hutch, for example,
when they constantly on people like Biden in certain ways, even
though I Biden's on some respects. We agreed on the AOC tweets
that they shouldn't have [__] on her that way. And
so there's no disagreement there. So that obviously isn't what
we're here to discuss on a point that you're unsure that we disagree
on. >> Well, I wasn't saying that we had I was very strong
that we massively disagree.
I got something I massively disagree with. So, okay. I think
that every single leftist that I've talked to online, anybody
who has any kind of political knowledge whatsoever, defines socialist
as decommodification of basic human needs and workers zoning
the means of production. And they use that definition repeatedly.
I think that my frustration is that there are a bunch of quote
unquote social democrats who talk. >> The idea that this
is twoon two with economy and Connor here is so stupid. It's
so it's like actually so anti-content I'm going to lose my mind.
I dude why >> universal healthare they talk about uh you
know making rent cheaper or some like that which are social democratic
Scandinavian policies and I think they're using the term socialism
backdoor in order to rehabilitate uh rehabilitate the image of
this and not just that Hassan and plenty of far lefties plenty
of MLS probably the Vanguard as well they're ecstatic that this
is happening they're ecstatic that Mandami has social democrat
policies they're ecstatic that AOC have social democrat policies
they're ecstatic that Bernie Sanders have social democrat policies
because it rehabilitates the word in my mind that shift of the
Overton window to the left is an insidious plot by plots to manipulate
the Democratic party. >> I'll ask you pluralism. >> So,
so we're going to get some actual clarity here. So, to be clear,
Stephen, you don't disagree that people like Miy AOC and Bernie,
they're fine to be in the party and we're fine to appeal to the
kind of issues that they care about in their positions. Correct.
You don't have a problem with that? >> Well, I would hold
on real quick. Let me ask I'm asking Stephen I'm asking Stephen
a question. I'm going to get to you and see if you disagree.
I want to say something before you and Destiny talk for the next
40 minutes. What I would say is that if the socialists are proposing
social democrat policy, but >> I just want to talk. Okay,
I just want to talk before you guys talk for 45 minutes. Now,
when I was an insurance broker at Liberty Mutual, >> they
get what they want and then they try to yank the political window
further left. That is something 100% that I oppose. Destiny,
you and Peace, go ahead and fight for the next >> No, I
I just want to ask and I'll ask I'm going to go to you, Conor,
and see if you agree with Destiny because I think we might all
have a more disagreement with you, Connor, than we have within
each other in terms of the substant opinion. So, I'm going to
ask Stephen, do you have a problem with these people, the people
identified, Mom, Donnie, Sanders, AOC, uh, being part of the
Democratic coalition in however you way define uh, Democratic
coalition and having their positions cater to or or people having
their positions in general as part of the Democratic coalition?
Do you have a problem with that? >> Okay, so there's two
separate questions. So, one, like generally, I'm probably almost
always going to support a blue candidate over a red candidate
in this current media environment or in this current um, political
environment. number one. But number two, when you say you have
a problem appealing to them, that I mean, >> so except
in the hypothetical of Donald Trump versus Hassan, I guess. I
guess outside of that hypothetical, we'll always vote for the
lefty over the uh the righty. Sure. Sure. >> That means
different things. >> He's just to totally trying to weasel
out of the positions he took on Twitter. He's going to try to
entirely weasel out. So I really hope Pisco keeps extracting
concessions. So you're going to entirely on everything you said
on Twitter, you're going to admit you're wrong. You're going
to go in a totally different direction because you are in fact
a Okay, good. >> If you say like, would I have a problem?
>> As long as you just admit my superiority, this is Pisco
by the way. As long as you admit my superiority. Go ahead. Go
ahead. >> If we were to appeal to Bernie Sanders coming
out and saying I want to socialize all of the music productions
in the United States, I would have a problem with that. But if
you're saying you have a problem appealing to Bernie and AOC
and Ramadan saying we need to >> again, just show me where
where Hassan has legitimately advocated for socializing all the
means of productions in the United States as a political position
in the US. Where has he ever said this >> ways to make
uh you know rent cheaper in cities and that might mean a policy
like rent control that I personally don't >> Guys, I think
it would be really good if AOC ran on a position that she wanted
to socialize all of the means of production in the United States.
I think that would be a good Assan said that >> but you
know they want to try it. I mean I wouldn't be like fundamentally
opposed to having as part of my party's platform then no I mean
like it would depend on what things we're talking about appealing
to >> like agreed. You're okay with the socialist being
at the top of the Democratic ticket in the sense that
>> but this is part of the issue. You call >> is
that right or no? Am I wrong? This is not like a a simple thing.
You're like doing like the what is a woman at me? What is a socialist
like
you have a problem with Bernie Sanders being the top of the ticket?
>> You got to let Destiny answer. >> That's a specific
question. >> Top of the ticket. No. Like of him being a
senator from Vermont. No. If he was president, probably not.
>> When you say a socialist, if you're talking about somebody
who wants to abolish by law all of private enterprise and maybe
even attack the >> Bernie does want to do that ideologically.
Bernie wants to do that. Everything every single argument you've
made about Hassan, Bernie is the exact same. Bernie is an avowed
socialist for his entire life. Are you serious? Every single
argument you made about Hassan applies to Bernie one to one.
Democratic underpinnings of our uh political party. >> So
now Pisco can ask very easily. So now all you have to do is give
me the ideological position where Hassan and Bernie Sanders differ.
Go ahead. Right. And have a single party rule. I would be opposed
to that. >> You would but that doesn't describe Bernie.
It doesn't describe Mani. It doesn't describe AOC. Correct. >> No.
But Manny, Bernie, and AOC are on the outer perimeter of what
is considered socialist. and they're attacked by the center part
of what is socialist. That's my issue. You could probably find
you could probably find an outer perimeter fascist that I might
be okay with. If he's some fascist who's >> "Does Hassan
attack Bernie Sanders or AOC significantly?" >> Like, "Yeah,
I think we should protect America as an ethnost state and I'm
defining ethnostate as like the current ethnic composition of
America and I think that we should have like stronger rules in
immigration." I was like, "Yeah, I probably the problem is that
like and you understand any kind of boy laid this out that Bernie
AOC these types, they come from a long tradition of democratic
socialists from like UK, Australia." He he brought up Clement
Atley and this is not some fringe movement. These are democratic
socialists that exist in countries all over the world. So, we're
not talking about this idiosyncratic belief of of socialism.
It's a version of socialism that exists and you're okay with
it being part of the party. So the question isn't one of categorical.
You're okay with some socialist. You would vote for some socialist.
I'll ask Connor the same question. Connor, are you okay with
someone like Bernie Sanders being on the top of the ticket AOC
being on the top of the ticket Democratic party? No. I I would
either abstain from voting or I would vote against them. Like
for instance, if there's a moderate Republican compared to AOC
or Bernie, not that moderate Republicans exist anymore, but if
they existed, I would pick a moderate Republican over AOC or
>> I think the bigger disagreement is between you and Destiny.
there. I think Destiny's okay with some social democratic election.
>> Conor Connor is a Republican so I would
>> I really I really want Pisco to continue to point out
that this is Destiny walking his position back. He is on all
of his positions, right? And that Piscoll was correct from the
very beginning that Pisco like you are you are walking to my
position. Thank you Destiny for conceding to me and walking to
my position. Thank you. >> Say that. Yeah. No, but voting
for somebody is a lot different than appealing to somebody. These
are two different things and we keep playing like this like clever
game of trying.
Let Destiny finish his thought. Please >> Well, that's
it. No, I'm saying like appealing to somebody voting for somebody.
I'm guessing if I was in New York and there was a plethora. >> He
literally did finish his thought. Wick, what do you probably
wouldn't be my first choice, but I probably vote for him in the
in the primary or I'm sorry, in the general, but that doesn't
mean I would like folded. Yeah, by by saying Bernie Sanders is
okay. He is completely folded. Bernie Sanders has almost certainly
unequivocally
more died in the wool socialist beliefs than hissump. And he
operates as a US politician, but he his his ideological positions
are all from socialism >> to a socialist or whatever. >> But
I like we have I I think I think there's a useful thing to look
at what this actually looks like in in actually existing politics,
right? Um so in 2016 when Bernie Sanders got I don't know 45%
of the vote in the primary, something like that. Um he was involved
in the platform committee for the DNC. He was like a main speaker
at the DNC in 2016. he was able to extract a lot of concessions
to the party. Like I think that because of him the party added
in marijuana legalization, a $15 hour minimum wage. Um I think
carbon pricing. Um and I think maybe there was some stuff about
the death penalty. I want to say that that was something that
Bernie Sanders really pushed to add into the Democratic party
platform. You know, and and again that that's like a very direct
appeal to Bernie Sanders and like an appeal to the unity between
the centrists and the socialists and the Democratic Socialist.
>> No, nothing. What part what policy there was socialist?
>> Okay. So the problem because nothing that you just said
there was socialist and there's this game that's played
>> you're wrong about that. You're completely wrong. Okay.
So >> our is socialist. >> Okay. Do you think do
you think a progressive income tax is socialist? >> Not
necessarily. No. >> Right. So the communist manifesto.
>> Why don't you why don't you answer anything? Dude, does
the Zip Zip guy apparently argues like Destiny argues now. He
just doesn't take positions. Not necessarily. No. Just say no.
Say whatever your position is. >> Progressive income tax.
Right. So obviously socialist policy >> I would say generally
speaking that the communist manifesto you know the manifesto
of the communist party like it probably is something of an authority
on what it means to be a communist >> communist manifesto
is a conflict made so that farmers could look against the
aspect of communism is also democracy this is this is so bad
faith so so economy brings up a point he says is this policy
socialist is and as sort of embodied in the communist manifesto
and you go a broader point say well the communist manifesto has
this other purpose that's question
So no, that's not the point. So the point is that it's not about
whether or not we would semantically define something like a
progressive income tax as communist or not communist. It's about
these broader movements and what their general ideological disposition
is on all of the different set of possible positions within the
policy debate. So, I would agree to your point that like yeah,
like in terms of socialism being the decommodification of labor
and also like the collective ownership of the means of production,
if that's the way that you define socialism, then obviously these
aren't like socialist policies, quote unquote, but that doesn't
mean that you're not appealing to like the broader socialist
movement and the broader like socialist apparatus of advocacy.
When you propose things like a $15 an hour >> w econom
boy just for clarity so I understand you're saying in when you
say I want to appeal to socialists you're saying things like
oh pick policies that socialists would also like >> I'm
saying that I'm saying that in so far as socialists and very
progressive democrats are a part of the actually existing base
of Democratic voters they should have some proportional say in
things like party leadership positions committee assignments
the platform of the Democratic party fundraising distribution
activistbased organizing strategic discussions. They should have
some kind of proportional say in all of those discussions. >> But
the problem is those people, if they truly identify as socialist
and not just like liberal light or socialist light or whatever
we're calling these people, they're not going to be pushing for
these outer perimeter things that socialists might agree with
when it comes to liberals. So when you say like a 15 hour $50
an hour minimum wage or like a progressive taxation system, these
are quote unquote socialist policies because they're mentioned
in the communist manifesto. You don't need communism or socialism
to talk about either of those issues. And what I don't like is
this weird game that's played. Yeah, you don't need communism
or socialism to enact a lot of things that like socialist or
communists would like. That's that's the whole point. Yes, Destiny,
you are literally arguing their point that you don't need communism
to do positions that communists would like and would support
and would vote for. That's the entire point of them saying we
don't need to exercise these people. Play where somehow socialists
are allowed to know true Scotsman every single good thing that
our capitalist liberal society has produced and say, "Oh, well,
you like vacation days that actually came from socialism. You
like um you like a minimum wage that came from socialism. You
like labor unions that came from socialism. And every bad and
thing is ascribed to the capitalist part despite the fact that
that's what's even creating the necessary prerequisite wealth
to even have these other me. What what does that have to do with
Wait, I don't know what that has to do like at all with what
I just said. What I'm saying fundamentally is that I think it's
sensible to make policy concessions to the broader socialist
apparatus in so far as >> we don't have to make that's
not a policy concession to a socialist.
>> It's literally if you if you if No, absolutely not.
If you got it absolutely if you got rid of all the socialists,
could you still get my minimum wage?
>> Then it's not a politicession to socialism. No
under really quick basin, even under even quote unquote liberal
economic frameworks. People in my replies are calling countries
like the Nordic societies liberal capitalist societies even though
they do quote unquote socialist things as you would just define
like social ownership of the means of production. like there's
a lot of quote unquote socialist policies that those countries
have engaged in that people are labeling as liberalism and doing
these kind of things and it's like whatever if we want to have
narrow definitions of things that's totally fine with me but
I think that in so far as like the socialist movement and when
we went the topic of the debate courting the left right you know
conceding things to the left the broader left I include very
progressive Democrats on that who might identify as capitalists
or might be misaligned in some way that includes things like
broader progressive policies like I mentioned healthy minimum
wage things like that as well >> when I say court the left
and when I was designing this topic maybe I could have more clear.
I'm not talking about um issues that both liberals and leftists
share. Like both of them agree that we should treat kids nicely.
Both of them agree that we should be kind to our neighbors, things
like that. I'm not talking about those things. I'm talking about
things that are specifically and >> So name them. So name
them. So
modification of basic human needs and workers only the means
production.
Hassan is a good example, right? The >> Hassan isn't a
policy. Hassan isn't a policy. If you're talking about appealing
to people, economy gave you a response. He's talking about things
that these people care about. Socialists care about you talking
about No, no, no. Okay, so I'm gonna say something that me off
about this conversation. Oh, somebody else started talking. I'm
going to roll my eyes. Shut the up, East go. Shut take your eyeballs
and shut the shut them the up. Okay, so saying everything good
is socialism is dumb as
what I'm doing. >> Yeah. Yeah, we did.
Hey, shut the
forid.
No. Hey, my turn. I have the talking stick. Shut the [__]
up. Okay. So saying like, oh,
a minimum wage is socialist, progressive taxes is socialist,
firefighters is socialist, police are socialist, teachers are
socialist. This is the kind of that is the obfuscation that I'm
talking about where you're basically talking about normie lib
governmental policies that are perfectly conducive to a free
market state and you're like, oh, it's just a gradation of the
economics. Why don't I'm going to kill myself. I'm going to kill
myself. I'm going to kill myself.
I'm going to kill myself.
Everybody's a [__] Hold on. Hold on. Give it Give
it to Peace Go and Econ boy to respond. Go. >> Yeah. So
economy specific. >> All of that was in a video game on
>> Yeah. So just to be clear again, I'm grounding everything
that I'm saying in the actually existing people that call themselves
socialists and call themselves very very
>> about interrupting. So no, I heard it. >> Well,
well, you interrupted. So just give me a second here. I'm grounding
this in the existing people that call it socialism, that call
it whatever, very progressive capitalism or very progressive
like policies in general, right? So, in so far as you're saying,
oh, my narrow definition of socialist policies is decommodification
of labor and the socialization of the means of production. Then
to be fair, according to me and you know, according to some other
policies that have been proposed, that is like almost exactly
what we would give an example just an example of a watch. I didn't
come here to play the not wait not the palms again. I'm scared
doing the exact opposite. Okay, wait economy keeps bringing up
like a Bernie Sanders. Can you name somebody in the media environment
that identifies as a socialist that is friendly towards the Democratic
party? Like
anybody in the media
want another
>> honestly what Destiny is doing right now is just pointing
out that like there is a lot of money to be made being like a
Democrat friendly socialist right now. Unironically, he's just
pointing it out. >> Politicians have to operate within
the very trying to get elected. So necessarily their positions
are going to be probably a bit more constrained. And also these
are people that I mean maybe Conor has but I don't AOC or Bernie
Sanders. That was never what this conversation was ever about
like ever. Like I'm curious in the media environment. Are there
any people that identify as socialist that are friendly towards
the Democratic party in the United States of America? >> Why
is that relevant to whether or not the Democrats >> because
my main criticism I'm telling you because my main criticism is
that you're saying Democrats should appeal to socialists and
you're picking the outer perimeter socialists that are the least
>> No, no, no, no, no. He's saying that they shouldn't
be exised. Destiny's doing the flip. Destiny's flipping right
now. I hope Pisco sees it. You're saying they should be excised.
Those outer perimeter people should be excised. Pisco is saying
that, hey, if it aligns with our interest, if we can highlight
a policy where we overlap, that's what we can do, right? We could
go, oh, hey, look, look, this is the policy where we overlap.
But Destiny's totally flipping. He's totally trying to take a
different position. One that he didn't have, one that didn't
start this argument, one that he is now totally like he's moved
towards Pisco. He's just going to basically argue, Pisco, I totally
agree with you. Did you think I like disagreed with you at some
point? He's just gaslighting. This is gaslighting like blatantly
people who have won elections by being the least socialist people,
saying that the outer perimeter beliefs that we're appealing
to are things like a 15 and our minimum wage, which aren't aren't
even necessarily socialist policies. When the issue we have is
that the central tenants of socialism, like the abolition of
all free enterprise, the abolition of all private property, the
destruction of the political parties in the United States of
America, those are the people that are dominating the media environment.
And you're asking us to appeal to those people to capture people
like AOC and Bernie Sanders. I'm not worried about the AOC's
and Bernie Sanders. I'm worried about the people that worked
for Bernie Sanders like your Brianna Joy Graves or the people
that are running the entire left media online apparatus, which
is why I'm asking for a single person who identifies as a socialist
that supports the Democratic party. So, if you're asking for
if you're asking for a single person who identifies as a socialist
that supports the Democratic party, there's obviously a lot of
those people. I just said those are 10% of the people that vote
for >> I want to make this point because it's relevant
to the conversation we're having. Okay.
Every time you open your mouth, it's impossible for you guys
to line your eyes because your your whole job here is to muddy
the waters.
>> I think you're muddying the water. That's exactly what
I'm going to accuse you about momentarily. So, shut up.
>> This is so transparently like incredibly bad faith.
It's so [__] funny. These people will lose. You cannot
do this. You cannot run this like dog and pony show like this.
It's so obvious what's going on. And so many people can see it
now. These people are all going down. >> Hold on. Counter
stop. I'm going to offer clarity. >> Counter stop. Counter.
Stop. Please go first and then you can respond. >> So clearly
with respect to policies that socialists support um if what we
mean by appeal to socialists is to literally propose policies
that these types of socialists would support. You guys are okay
with them. Certain these policies, right? And and we're just
now defining what the scope of that agreement is, what the scope
of that overlap is. But you don't have a problem in principle
with appealing to socialists if by appealing to socialists we
mean promoting policies that they like. >> Yeah. But that's
a meaningless >> Policies are good. >> Okay. So,
so now wait wait cuz >> it's not a meaningless statement.
Hold on. It's not a meaningless statement. And Pisco and Connor
Boy need to continually focus on the idea that Destiny, Aerodite,
and Connor have been pushing excising.
What does excising these people mean? That means cutting them
off. not talking to them, not listening to them, not doing anything
with them at all, excising. We're cutting them off entirely.
Now they're going, "Well, if it means that we like if we do $15
minimum wage cuz we like that policy, then like we could talk
to them about it." Yeah. You have out. You have lost. You've
given up. You've done your mutton and Bailey. You've given it
up entirely, right? You you've totally abandoned your original
M. You've you've gone back and you're your Bailey is Pisco's
position. Yeah. You can't you can't call Pisco a disingenuous
socialist and then go, "But we agreed totally. We actually agreed
totally the whole time. No, that can't >> Are you okay
with appealing to members of the Klux Clan? >> They like
clean drinking water.
>> This is This is Oh my god. This is exactly why we argued
against excising. It's like actually just insane that they foot
this entirely. Yeah. >> Let's say you do like Yeah. Like
city >> So now let's actually talk about the policies and
whether they get >> No, you have to answer that question.
I'm okay with I'm I'm okay with a party I'm totally willing to
buy bullets. You know I buy bullets. I'm totally willing with
a party to appeal to members of the Kullex clan if that if what
is meant by that is appealing to common sense policies everyone.
Excuse me. Let me finish. Wait, wait, wait. It's not a pointless
question. >> Is Wick going to defend Pisgo's ability to
speak at all in the way that he's cut Piscow off multiple times
or >> because there are policies that you would consider
socialist I think under your definition no truth definition of
socialist that maybe the Democrats should appeal. So for example,
would you be against do you think first of all that a national
healthcare service is a socialist policy? >> Okay. Can
you give an example of a socialist policy? things that involve
taking away the means of production from private owners from
capital. >> Okay. So, so Destiny, can you admit that no
influencer has ever argued for a socialist policy with regards
including Hassan? Hassan has never advocated for a socialist
party uh policy in America as an actual political position. Right?
So he's he's indistinguishable from Bernie Sanders and that they
ideologically believe the means of production should belong to
the people, but they would never argue for that position in the
current American media envir current American political environment
>> owners and giving that so that the workers are exclusively
the ones that are in control of the means of >> A a a single
pair healthare system, let's say health insurance system. Let's
put put aside national healthare a single pair healthare system
that makes it illegal or outlaws private insurance. You would
not socialist. Uh if if you're talking about the government owning
everything from the top down then including hospitals then theoretically
you could call that socialist. >> Would you or would you
sorry would you call that socialist? Would would you would you
would would you call that socialist? Yes or no? >> I would
call it a state on enterprise or state enterprise a socialist.
I mean technically not really but
being a total just being a total weasel. Actually call out the
people with no spine on like this who literally can't take a
position. This is totally This is the most despicable spineless
behavior I've ever seen. I told you that he basically he's already
lost the conversation. Entering the conversation, he has lost.
So, he has to lie. He has to misrepresent. He has to be a total
weasel and bad ba on all of these things, right? That's the only
way he can participate in this conversation is by being totally
disingenuous and dishonest. The >> answer is your answer
that a singlepayer system is not socialist. Is that what your
answer is? >> I I don't I wouldn't call it socialist, but
if you wanted to for the purpose of this conversation, sure.
No, I want I want to know your opinion. So that's >> Yes.
Yes. Oh my god. He didn't do this to He didn't do this to loser
zip zip, but now he's doing it to Destiny. How about you give
me your position, you spineless your opinion. Your answer is
no. Singlepayer is not socialist. Okay. >> I don't know.
I don't think it's necessarily like a social if you want to >> I
don't know if Dude, be embarrassed. Shame anybody who supports
this overt. Okay, dude. Why does Destiny sit here? Can he move
his chair backwards? Right. Can he move his chair backwards so
we can get the full image here? He should be sitting back where
this gun rack is and and stream from there. Okay. So we can have
the image of him sitting in the corner of the room. >> You
could. But but >> No, I'm not asking if I wanted to. I
could. I'm asking your I'm asking your opinion. I'm not saying
if you wanted to, you could. You want me to give you a yes or
no answer to
your opinion? Do you think do you think you think single player?
Do you think you sing? Shut up. >> I'm not asking would
someone else could you? I'm asking you, Stephen Banell, do you
consider singlepayer to be >> Okay, now that you ask, shut
up the >> No. Okay, so this is who's the no true Scotsman
here? You guys were saying like the the policy that most people
who would absolutely consider to be socialist is not socialist.
And so our working framework of socialism is only tankyism, only
people who want to decommodify everything and have government
ownership of everything. And it's preposterous. You're just not
operating with the way people use those >> That's great.
That's literally not the argument though. But if you wanted to
argue that if we were to call >> That's literally not the
argument. It was the argument. Yes. You you you you're arguing
that people who don't advocate for socialist policies who don't
advocate for seizing the means of production now are are not
socialist. Okay, that's on Hassan. Hassan does not advocate for
seizing the means of production. He's never said Bernie Sanders,
you have to seize the means of production. If you win, you'll
seize the means of production. He's never said that. So what
the are we talking about there? There's nobody who exists and
is a popular political uh political commentator who actually
argues for this now, right? And then otherwise you have to explain
to me why the ideology Bernie Sanders have has and the ideology
Hassan has are different. That's what you have to do. Socialist
and you wanted to socialize the healthare system. The reason
why you would be doing that wouldn't be because you're trying
to appeal to social
finish. Holy there's a difference between doing something by
say so for instance I'm a free market capitalist but that doesn't
mean I oppose government intrusion into every single sector or
even a government monopoly on things like say utilities because
there are some things that the free market doesn't solve for
to say that I don't think the free market solves for this and
we no no 30-year-old user uh 30-year-old loser sorry I think
Hassan would say that but he is not advocating for current politicians
to do that that's the thing but Bernie Sanders also believes
the workers should have the means of production he is a politician
he is effective in the current political environment. There's
no reason to believe that Hassan is any different from Bernie
Sanders or any more socialist than Bernie Sanders. Right? There's
no reason to believe that. In fact, I believe Hassan's made it
clear that he is slightly less socialist than Bernie Sanders.
Right? So, so Destiny says he would support Bernie Sanders. If
you support Bernie Sanders, there's no reason you should argue
to exile Assan. He has clearly argued to exise Assan. He has
to resolve that ambiguity.
That's what he has to have utility companies ran by the state
is not the same as saying I'm appealing to socialists. I'm not
saying the book of life. When you ask me if a singlepayer system
would be socialist, I might say I guess you consider socialist
if you want. The reason why I'm asking this is news to me. Are
you unaware that Bernie Sanders has been an avowed socialist
his entire life? Evil Johnny Bravo. That he like did his honeymoon
in Moscow because he loves the USSR. Like are you unaware of
all that? >> No. For a singlepayer system isn't because
I'm trying to appeal to socialists. It's because I think free
market capitalism cannot problem.
Yes or no? Yes or no? What is a woman? What is a woman? We're
doing the obuscation is the question isn't >> there's no
obuscation to be clear. The option is not the obvious obuscation.
The occupation is a false and I'll identify it. The question
isn't whether or not the intention behind promoting singlepayer
system is one way or another. We're not talking about the intention
behind why you propose one policy or another. We're just asking
>> no evil Johnny Bravo. Bernie Sanders is like a diet
in the wool fullon socialist >> for semantic terms. Would
most people call socialized medicine socialized healthcare? Would
they call it a socialist policy? And your absurd deflection on
that and say no I would I would not call it socialist. I think
just you're not using the terms.
>> Here's a question. Wait. Do you think that Hassan would
call it socialism? >> I don't Wait, why is that relevant?
>> Why is the wing irrelevant to what mainstream thought
is amongst leftists in in on the online >> socialism? He
wouldn't call it socialism. He called it a socialist policy.
He would absolutely move in a socialist like policy direction.
Right. >> you just say communist manifesto? The communist
manifesto that is not authoritative on socialism. But Hassan
>> not authoritative. Hassan who you said is a
Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. I don't look at the communist manu manifesto
for what socialism or communism is but is my guiding star. Okay.
Yeah. You're you lost. You lost. Embarrassing >> on that.
But not the communist >> Hold on. I just want to be clear.
You're telling me that something that was written almost 100
years ago is more authoritative on what modern day
>> Okay. Well, I encourage you to do more >> Wait.
So, you're telling me that that the current president is more
authoritative of what the Constitution is than uh than a document
the Constitution itself that was written this many years ago?
Oh. Oh, we should listen to Donald Trump and what the Constitution
should be over James Madison. Is that what you're telling me?
Just because there's 100, Dude, what? I'm actually doing the
opposite hypothetical here. But you get what I'm saying. There's
no reason to believe that somebody who wrote something a 100
years ago is not an author an authority on the document they
wrote, right? Let me step in here. So, if if we're appealing
at that point though, Destiny, if we're appealing to what social
people who call themselves socialists actually think, hey, the
authoritative source of what socialism is is the actually existing
socialists today and what they believe in, right? Then in terms
of whether or not we're like acquiescing or appealing to the
socialist movement then yeah like the Bernie Sanders platform
concession. Hold on hold on hold on hold on. Wick mods. Wick
mods are in the chat scolding not soite. Sorry I have to I have
to pull this up. It's very relevant. Okay is very relevant. Notite
is in Wick's chat right now and we have missed not quit banning
people for nothing. Hey not soite quit banning people for nothing.
Hey stop trying to shape the argument. Not soite. Stop banning
people for literally
nothing. Stop. Stop. Hey, Ardite, how about you quit based? Thank
you. >> 2016 would count within that reasonable framework
that he was able to raise the minimum wage, you know, requirement
of the Democratic Party National Committee. He was able to add
in things like legalizing marijuana. And so, we're hopping back
and forth between, oh, well, some socialists say socialism is
decommodification of labor. >> I'm sorry. I keep playing
appealing to liberals. Liberals aren't trying to appeal to socialists.
Right. When Bernie Sanders recommends the legalization, what
are you talking about? You're molding about a YouTube timeout.
>> Marijuana. That's not someone, >> right? Bernie
Sanders trying to do something in a liberal capitalist framework.
You say the government used to grow weed. >> Okay. So,
do Okay. Number one, I take it that you take back the thing you
said in the beginning of this debate of when do socialists ever
appeal to liberals by just now saying that that was an appeal
to liberal. No, because I said at the beginning, I don't really
consider these people socialists. Cook follow the conversation.
Okay. >> Okay. So now Bernie Sanders isn't a >> I
don't consider these I did not say at the beginning of this conversation.
I don't really consider these people real socialist. No. >> No.
No. But Destiny, but Destiny, you but you but what you did say
was the actually existing contemporary socialists like Hassan
are authoritative on what socialism is. And so if people like
Bernie Sanders and Bernie Sanders point, if I could just finish
my point, if people like Bernie Sanders and people like Mom Donnie
and you know, people like AOC AOC say things like publicly owned
grocery stores and singlepayer healthare systems and public education
are socialist. >> Everyone's literally being scolded for
for shaping you just keep on doing it >> policies. Dude,
>> we have to agree.
I need your influence on what it means to be a socialist policy
under your own. >> Okay. No. And I would like an opportunity
to speak. >> No, I I want Jesse to really clarify that
really quick. Just like does that >> I really like balls
for the next 10 minutes. So I would like >> Hold on. Hold
on. Hold on. You guys honestly just kick Conor in the conversation.
He's incapable of having the conversation. He doesn't He's not
even a Democrat. Kick him the out. Why is he in the conversation?
This is about Democratic strategy. Kick him the out. Get him
out of here. >> Please. Destiny was asked a direct question.
I'm going to let him give you a direct answer. Conor should go.
Okay. Listen, I don't think that you look to the lawmakers in
a democratic system to see who your ideological thought leaders
are for certain movements in the United States necessarily. Okay?
They're running in certain districts and they're running under
the confines of trying to operate within some electoral system
so that they can get stuff done. I think that if you want to
have this argument right now of like does Bernie Sanders and
AOC dictate what socialism is in the United States. Honestly,
when you say it, um maybe when people say I'm not sure what plans
he's on right now, okay, but when you say, I think you genuinely
believe that and I don't think you're saying that like with stupidity
and I don't think you're saying that with malice and I don't
think you're a secret pinky or anything like that. Okay, I I
understand what you're saying there and I and I want to agree
with you, but the problem is but the problem is that when I go
outside, let me explain. The problem is that when we go outside
of where Econo Boy is, there is nobody in the United States media
environment, okay, that like calls themselves like really like
a socialist that would look to people like AOC and Bernie Sanders
and say, "Oh yeah, those are socialists." They would call those
people stepping stone. >> Uh Lawson Harrison donating 50
bucks over here. Lawson, you should come chat on stream. You
You're saying some really crazy donations. I would love for you
to come on stream and just, you know, lay out why you think apparently
the entire all the accusations against destiny are fabricated.
I would love to hear why you think that, how you've come to that
conclusion. Yeah, I would really love to in the radicalization
funnel and good like liberal capitalist at the end of day.
Hold on. >> I want to turn. Go ahead. I want to turn because
frankly you guys are talking past each other. Okay. The reason
why I've reiterated my definition of socialism as narrow and
tailored is because I'm not doing no true Scotsman. Okay? I'm
telling you what a Scotsman is. It's a Scottish person from Scotland.
Okay? It's a dude. He wears a kilt. He has his out all the time.
All right? So the point is I'm describing very specifically what
it is. And the reason why I would be about Universal >> more
not so aerodyite. It was a timeout for 24 hours and several bands
that had to be undone. Keep lying though. Oh, what the Hold on.
What? Dude, I'm sorry. This is actually funnier than the debate
right now. Okay. Oh my goodness, dude. Hold on. Can I scroll?
Can I scroll? Hello. Scrolling capabilities. Why can't I scroll?
I can't scroll this chat. What is happening? I can't I can't
scroll this chat. Here we go. Here we go. Nope. That's still
not working. Thank you. What is What is happening, dude? Thank
you, God. Okay, I banned someone. N didn't like that. That's
about it. At Wick TV, check DMs.
Uh, let's see. It was a timeout for 24 hours and several bans
that had to be undone. Keep lying though, Android. I forgive
you, but I have to stand on principle. Rh, she's over here. >> High
quality education being >> Why are you crashing out? >> Socialist
is number one, I think most committed socialists who have read
any books about socialism wouldn't agree with that definition.
And the only way that I would stretch it is if you considered
universal health care or universal access to health care as a
part of the decommodification of basic human needs, which by
the way, I'm pretty sure was just food, water, and shelter. But
what I'm saying is that the reason why I think that Econo Boy
and uh Pisco, whether they like it or not, are useful idiots
for committed socialists and tankies and communists is because
they they buddy the definitions. They blur it around. They're
just like, "Oh yeah, every public service." >> Connor Connor,
give us one example. Therefore, give us one example of a socialist
policy. Go
>> uh making food, water, and shelter available to human
beings at the point of service for free. >> So, you think
so, so why is that socialist but doing the same thing with health
insurance isn't? And it's because one is basic human needs. >> Uh
because I'm going based off Well, yeah, because I'm going off
of the definitions of Yeah, absolutely. >> Okay. So, so
healthare is not a basic human need, but food is. >> All
you're arguing is that healthcare is >> I'm asking a question.
I'm asking I'm actually asking you a question. Is food more of
a human need than healthcare is as you're seeing it? >> Yes,
absolutely. >> All right. So, I think that's cooked. I
think that's cooked and arbitrary. I don't think you can wait.
I got to ask I wish I wish Chris hadn't gone down this line cuz
I think you could probably argue like obviously in the hierarchy
of deeds. I think you get I think you get uh blown up on this
one. I don't like this one.
but this is just they're going to So, this is Destiny does the
exact same thing Asan does. Destiny's identified immediately.
Oh, I can actually fight on that all day. I can get way off of
our actual topic and I can fight on that all
>> Do you think that healthare is as important as food?
>> No, I think food is more important than >> Okay.
So, you agreed with Connor that I don't know why you just said
>> Wait, wait, no. You're you're cooked in that I would
consider I think most people consider in basic human necessity
need healthare as well as food. Not that food is more important.
>> You asked him which was more important, didn't you?
Did I miss that? Hold on. Wait. He asked which one was more important
or did he say was more important than healthare? >> Thank
you. Okay.
No, no, no. Is it is it is it more of in the sense of is it more
of a misspoke is it more of a basic human necessity in the sense
that it's a separate category of thing that there are separate
categories that you know food is a basic human necessity in a
way that >> you don't need to cope you can just say you'll
hold on wait just to be clear you're trying to bail yourself
out it doesn't make sense if something
>> of this in a category God damn it hold on why is she
uh when we're moderating your [__] you can moderate
chat Jenny Just relax. Uh, what the [__] am I witnessing
right now? Parallax, what's up? He's here, too. Uh, tags, your
DMs last night say otherwise. Wait, tags
last night.
>> Only socialist actually depending socialist actually
depending on whose definition. No one is crashing out. I am clicking
a name and undoing a ban or timeout that wasn't warranted. God
wants to explain something. >> So, when when you say when
you say the word a basic human necessity, right? A basic human
necessity. Um, in what respect is food a basic human? >> She's
responding to deeper.
Dude, I'll always power I'll always be power hungry. I can't
be stopped. Uh, where's the Kathy message, too? Hold on. Where's
the Did Kathy Cathy's message got moderated? Uh-oh. I thought
I saw Kathy message here. Did I not see a Cath? Oh, here it is.
Uh, not can you please stop banning people for disagreeing with
Destiny? Thanks. >> Respect that healthcare is not. And
I'm trying to see what are the metrics by which you assess healthare
to be Wait, wait, stop. Stop. >> Yeah, I know. I know it's
not synced with I'm clarifying. I'm clarifying.
is more important and I'm going to get destined to hear this.
Just because something is important, more important consideration
going to be more important doesn't mean it's more of a basic
human necessity. Yes or no? Stephen, >> what you just said
again? You said more of a basic human necessity category wait
Stephen. Is the category is the term basic human necessity and
important the
>> Okay. So saying something along the spectrum of basic
human necessity and importance. Those are different questions,
right? Stephen Stephen, are they different questions or not?
>> Those are different words. I don't know. >> So
are they? So is something on the spectrum of basic human necessity
the same spectrum of importance? Because importance can come
more than just something that's basic necessity, right? be more
important along the spectrum. >> So, do you do you So,
there's no contradiction, right? Can you identify >> No.
Lee and Gain, sir. I cannot
>> dude. Uh I have no idea how Pisco came back and and
turned that into like a concession. He looks kind of he looks
kind of unhinged for doing >> health and he said yes. He
said I don't I don't think it's interesting to debate whether
or not Pisco got dunked on just now. Okay. I want to go back
to what Destiny said previously, which I thought was pretty interesting.
So Destiny made a claim >> Pisco Pisco shouldn't be fighting
that but uh Pisco is and this is very rare for him. I think he's
actually kind of that Destiny is being this bad faith with him,
right? >> I think that's to determine who the
of socialists like people who label themselves as socialists
wouldn't be so that you have to be like so perfect Bernie Sanders
or Manny or AOC. Now I would say this is pretty absurd for a
number of reasons. Okay, if we look at hey when people go and
have public events, right? Like hey Hassan goes and has a public
event how many people show up? I'd say maybe a few hundred. Maybe
he gets into the the 1,00 plus club or something. When AOC and
Bernie Sanders go out and have an event, thousands of people
show up. They can feel stadiums, fill arenas, when people actually
go out and express their political views. What are my political
views? Millions of people voted for Bernie Sanders. Hundreds
of thousands of people, probably millions of people across the
country, vote for Democratic socialist politicians. And so when
we look at democratic socialist and socialist politicians, they
are clearly by ideological standpoint and by their propensity
to collaborate within democratic party frameworks and electoralism
much different than Hassan and much more implatic of the standard
by which we should judge people who label themselves as socialists
in this >> I would then
real quick I got a quick hold on I'm sorry. Why didn't the DSA
then endorse AOC? >> Because they came out with that vote
on on uh well for the national DSA uh retracted retracted their
vote because of the Iron Dome vote that uh AOC took. Seems like
kind of a problem. That's not a socialist. That's not a PSA is
not >> Destiny. Destiny, you're obvious. The point is not
a horrible example. No. No. Go Destiny. One second. The reason
I say you're obiscating is because my point was not that for
instance within DSA, within all of these different democratic
socialist politicians, even within those people, Mani is not
the same as AOC and no one DSA member is the same as any other
one. Okay? >> We're not talking about DSA member. The National
AOC
did endorse mom. Okay? They did endorse many other democratic
socialist candidates. I understand that there is if I can just
finish. I understand that there is I understand that there is
an exception to the general rule of democratic socialists like
the organization endorses you know different >> Yeah, Cherry,
we can't be we can't be too mad at Wick. Okay. He's got a lot
of uh a lot of ingrained behaviors. Okay. He he he co recoils
in fear of the whip. Even though Destiny doesn't have the whip
anymore, he recoils in fear. Okay. He's not escaped the plantation
in his mind. He's escaped the plantation in a literal sense in
some ways, but in his mind, he is still on the plantation. And
in fact, he might be getting dragged back there
intentionally. Okay. >> Who call themselves democratic
socialist
fundamental point.
It's literally Conor's in the house. >> Who call themselves
socialists and run their parties and have people come out and
vote for them and support them. That is a fundamentally different
group of people on average by the normal distribution of their
beliefs than people like Hassan. And I think that we should judge
them by who they vote for more so than by you know Hassan
>> Yeah.
Agree. Okay. Thank you. Okay. Got points. Go ahead. >> All right.
I I love you. Conor >> is a political prisoner. His socialism
was that if you actually go back to Bernie Sanders in the ' 80s
and 70s, he was doing apology for Cuba. He was doing apology
for the Soviet Union. He did apologia for Venezuela in the thousands.
And you know what happened? Each one of >> has he wait
has he totally disavowed that apologia or does he just not talk
about it because it's not politically effective? places ended
up being absolute for and so what he had to do shut up is he
had to move to social democratic models in the Scandinavian system
and abandon his previous hardcore but there's a question of whether
or not social dem I don't think he I don't think I don't think
he's like sincerely yeah I don't think he sincerely moved his
positions I think he thinks ideologically those all make sense
and that they were probably victims of CIA plots he probably
thinks the same thing Hassan does are actually just hiding their
power level because they're trying to inculcate a leftwing philosophy
in I'm not done yet
why is it relevant this is the entire conversation The entire
conversation is whether or not social democracy is your conspiracy
theory about socialist the center left. That's the whole [__]
conversation. So you're you're just you're you're asserting a
conspiracy without much evidence. You're just saying, "Oh, Bernie
actually conspiratorally supports
changes of opinion. He might just real
totally disavow. I don't know why you did that."
is that there are leftists who have said explicitly that their
goal is to infiltrate the Democratic party to move it towards
leftism. It is not a conspiracy in the the sense that it's crazy.
It is a conspiracy in the sense that these people have said this
is what we're going to do. This is our goal for doing it and
this is how we're going to >> Why is that relevant to our
discussion?
>> Discussion because should we, the Democrats,
allow or invite into our house as influencers, invite into our
house as staffers, invite into our house as um uh people we will
engage with or collaborate with in a friendly way. or I stop
I stop covering the chat but we go
it's only a it's only quoteunquote a problem in so far as it's
aggregately true of the 10% of the Democratic party base that's
actually engaged in that process now I understand that that's
you know we don't have a poll that says how many of you are engaged
in this kind of like manurian candidate like conspiracy whatever
the like Connor is describing but I would say that generally
speaking when I look at the actions of democratic socialists
who win elections when I look at the actions of democratic socialists
and the platforms of them they don't seem to be secret tankies
now I would agree that there are certain people People reference
Assan like Assan has said, "Oh, like I I want I want >> Well,
okay. Yeah. Oh, people reference other leftwing alternative media
influencers. Oh, sure. Okay. Like, whatever. People reference
people like that. And sure. Yeah. To the extent that those people
have like literally on record said that they're just trying to
obiscate issues and engage in this kind of uh you know, like
conspiracy or whatever. Then I've already said at the very beginning
of this debate that people like that probably shouldn't be invited
into the inner party and be given platforms in Democratic party
circles. Obviously, true. That's true. I understand that the
disagreement here is that and again they can correct me if I'm
wrong but Destiny and Counterpoints think that you are allowing
this to happen like you said no the disagreement the disagreement
is also mantic Connor is China a communist country or socialist
country >> is what >> is China a socialist country
>> are they moneyless stateless or
>> uh no there's they have class >> no then they're
not >> okay is there any is there any socialist country
in the world right now
>> uh I I don't think anybody has like >> who's no
true Scotsman so tell me who's no I'll answer your question No,
no, no. Don't pretend you have a good point. You don't. Okay.
Socialists, this is actually fundamental to my perspective. Socialists
are
and they can't implement their world view. Hold on. And they
can't implement their world view into the real world. So, if
you look at the 20th century, there's something called vanguard
Marxism or Marxist Leninism. And they have these things called
Vanguard parties that take over countries and turn them into.
And so, we have people like Hakee, Second Thought, Hassan, the
Vanguard >> tried to sweep this history away. No, I'm telling
you the truth. And these are the people
and you are useful idiots for >> no no so so under your
vision right single pair is not socialist there's no socialist
country socialism has never been done >> because I'm using
the definition that socialists themselves used >> who who
by the way like and I'm sure you're speaking from a perspective
of
but I'm going to tell you why you're speaking from a position
of ignorance >> So I just want to go Stephen you acknowledge
that Connor just said is [__] so stupid as you [__]
idiot speaking from a position to shut the [__] up.
So, so, so I'm asking the question to Stephen. Stephen, you're
speaking from a position of ignorance. Stephen, do you >> Let
him demonstrate that. >> Okay. Dude, this is Connor can't
be in this conversation. Connor is too dumb to >> Stop
counter points. Let him >> Not even not even dumb. He's
just like he's actually he's just ruining the entire conversation.
>> This could actually be person here,
You're all
goddamn minutes. Keep moderating, Conor. Stop. Stop. Please go
from a position of >> Okay, then let him demonstrate that.
up. Conor is misbehaving. Go. >> So, I have a question
for Stephen. Stephen, do you agree Do you agree with Conor's
contention that there's no socialist country currently and that
single player is not a socialist policy? >> Both of those
questions are very complicated. It's hard to yes or no them.
The issue right now that we're having with this conversation
is every single conversation that I ever had with a centrist
that defended and now it's going to be, I guess, for the next
years, every conversation with a center-left socialist or a Democ
who inevitably will play cover for tankies. The issue is that
you guys have come here to defend the proposition that socialists
are AOC, Bernie Sanders, and Mumdani. Okay? AOC is not even currently
endorsed by the largest socialist movement in the United States.
Bernie Sanders causes major contention over his endorsement.
All of these people run as Democrats. And you're going to pretend
like this is the main voice of the socialist movement in the
United States. And you're going to say it and you're going to
say it by talking about policies that they're using to appeal
to hear an answer. Didn't hear an answer to my question. Finish
my
You're going to say that these appeal to socialists in the United
States because they're doing things that are popular amongst
literally all center left people. And then you're going to say
that's an example for why we should try harder to appeal to leftists.
When my question earlier is let's look at the media apparatus,
the entire leftwing media apparatus constantly attacks and on
Democrats and then you guys like watching Pisco stumble through
not knowing 50 different terms related to what talks about on
his stream and play cover for him over and over and over again.
Whether it's the ridiculous
>> Dude, this is just about re-education. Pisco didn't
know what re-education was. Pisco read that thread. Oh dude,
this is so transparently bad faith. >> Or whether it's
his ridiculous political beliefs that where Pisco pretends not
to know what any of these things are, not to know what well reeducation
camp isn't like getting your GED. >> No, he doesn't know
what re-education is. Like Pisco didn't engage with exactly what
Hassan was saying. He's just lying. Desi is just objectively
lying right now. He watched it. He watched it happen and he is
now just >> Right. That's the issue that people have when
they look at us and go, "Okay, every time you come to argue with
us about defending socialists, you talk." >> Now, you have
to cut Connor off here and let Pisco respond because Destiny
is lying about him openly, right? Destiny is is just maliciously
lying right now. >> About a Bernie Sanders. But then when
you look at the media environment, they're talking about Stalin.
That's the >> Okay. So, I didn't hear an answer to the
question, so I'll just ask it again. >> Ask it again. I
want to tell you. >> Yeah. Well, I want to hear an answer
from Steven. So, he just filibuster. He's trying to dodge. Cool.
Does do you agree with Connor's contention that there is no socialist
country and that singlepayer is not a socialist policy? the the
the whole point of this conversation is you're hiding behind
the the obscurity of what these words mean like is like it depends.
There are some socialists who would say that there are no socialist
countries. There are other socialists that would point to >> actually
you you pretend you don't understand what these things mean and
you should take my mind reading of as like word as as the word
of God and um yeah that's what the whole conversation is about.
You don't take my word as the word of God. >> Most socialists
would say much the same that if I was on a podcast and a conservative
influencer said what is a woman? Define it in three words. I
would say I can't really >> keep keep embarrassing him.
just keeps saying Destiny will not take a strong position. He
won't say yes or no to anything. He won't point out where I'm
actually misrepresenting something. He can't do that. He'll just
say, "Oh, look at this guy supports Hassan." He just signals
that Hassan because he has no actual argument because he's a
spineless loser coward. Really do. It's more complicated than
that unfortunately. I'm >> Yeah. Bisco, can I can I tell
you why you're confidently ignorant and kind of stupid in this
conversation right now? I would like a minute, please. >> So,
the reason why you're confident >> now Desi just gets to
lay that all out there that that totally baseless accusation
that Pisco is covering for Hassan in any way. He gets to lay
it out there. And now Connor is going to talk next. And Pisco
gets no chance to respond. Pisco should totally ignore whatever
Connor says. Just say, "Connor, you're doing your best. I love
you. You're doing your best." And then respond to destiny. Is
because vanguard parties want to institute socialism as a stone
to communism. But in the early 20th century, Ma Dong took over
China and then he totallyed it up. He tried to do a command economy
where he guaranteed food, water, and shelter. And he tried to
do a massive industrialization in the middle of the 20th centur.
>> Let's go. >> So wrong that he caused the death
>> and how wrong you said. >> Oh, suck a boy. Let
go. >> Nobody cares, Conor. Nobody cares. Let me explain
how we're not sweeping for the 20th century socialist. Please.
>> So yeah, let me explain. Okay, cuz you're completely
wrong about your characterization of socialism, okay? And the
history of social. >> That's the spiciest econom he's ever
gotten in his entire life. Let's go. What's up, Gecko? >> The
exact time period. Okay. So, Connor, would you say that there
were other socialists on the planet engaged in socialist advocacy
at the same time as
>> Okay. So, your characterization that Mauoism and that
the people who followed Mao and the socialist models after that
were in reaction to Mao is necessarily wrong because there were
concurrent socialist movements to Mao. You understand that, right?
I can name half a dozen. Can you name half a dozen? >> Can
you answer that question? >> What's your question? The
question is since there were concurrent socialist movements to
Mao, it is necessarily not true that socialist movements that
came after were just in response to the Mauist model of socialism.
>> Okay, I'm going to be because I'm as big I'm going to
answer the question, but I'm going to be a dick about it. Yeah,
there were concurrent movements and a majority of them were Marxist
Leninist. They were whole pot. They were Soviet Union. So if
they're all Marxist Leninist and Mauism is a iteration of Marxist
Leninism and if they share similar issues like authoritarianism,
centrally planned economies and dystopian
nightmare states, then why the do I give a [__] about
your >> Wrong about your empirical claim. The Social Democratic
Party of Australia, the Labor Party of the UK, the Social Democratic
Party of Germany, every single one of the
New Democratic Party of Canada.
>> Oh wait, that might not have been concurrent with now.
Wait, one second.
Socialist who didn't do the murder.
>> The New Democratic Party of Canada are the people who
got uh universal healthcare passed in Canada. It was a socialist
party. It was a socialist party with an avowed socialist leader.
Broadly considered a massive achievement for the entire country.
>> no. The NDP is a fantastic example. You just have to
ignore the past 20 years of history.
We don't we don't care about the past 20 years. We care about
where they came from, who they were. Okay. Are they social? Just
hold on. Just cuz I don't know. Hold on. Stop. Stop. I have a
question. I have a question. I'm ask question. Stop. [__]
jihadist aren't the same. Stop. Stop. Stop. Question for you.
If you shut up, I can ask a question. Hey, Connoy. Those uh the
>> the ones you just Australia, >> Germany, Australia,
did they have control of the government? >> Tommy Douglas,
Canada. Clement Clement
>> Tommy Douglas had control of a province and then he
was the primary opposition and he a lot of things through like
he basically was the reason they passed universal healthcare.
>> Oh my god. utopia.
>> You're only socialist. You're so this is communist position.
You're only socialist if if you're able to execute this communist
utopia. No, no, no, no, no. Hold on. I want to hear social
been screaming. I'm going to scream too.
>> and the society might save you from yourself. So you
might be an inefficacious socialist. >> Okay. So can I
ask can I ask a simple question that maybe this is like the I
feel like this is what this whole thing is coming down to. Okay.
If you were to take a hundred people, have them read theory,
study history, and then look in a room, okay, and you were to
put, we'll say, Hassan and then AOC in a room, and you would
ask them which one is more of a socialist, what do you think
all of those would say? >> Um, I I don't know because they
would probably this conversation
answer to me >> because you're No, because to say that
is to again to misunderstand the diversity of the socialist movement
and
diversity of the socialist. I'm saying I'm saying that AOC, Hold
on. Is it fair for me to say that AOC is a way more outer perimeter
socialist than like a bog standard then look up
you think there are fundamental differences and what are the
fundamental differences between AOC and something >> let's
use Steven let's use Stephen model Stephen if you put a hundred
people in a room and ask them is Bernie Sanders a socialist how
would they answer yes or >> I I honestly don't >> that's
your
>> dude you're so bad fake why is he like this why is he
like this I'll tell you why he's like He knows the same thing
I know, right? Okay, hold on, hold on, hold on. Time for pigs.
Thank you for the five gifted. He knows the same thing I know.
Okay, and that's that if you give Pisco a lot of his premises
when he goes ask a question, you've already lost. And so he is
terrified. He has himself at the answer at the idea of answering
a question directly, right? Hey, everybody considers Bernie Sanders
a socialist, right? That's literally the thing that held him
down and held him back the most in his entire political career,
right? No, I don't I don't know that. I don't know that. >> You
just
did that. You didn't even ask me the same question. I was comparing
to 100 people. I said 100 people well read on theory. Do you
want to say 100 well read people? If you put 100 people who are
well read on socialist theory, you ask him if Bernie Sanders
a socialist.
>> Wait. Oh, ask this question. Is Hassan well read on
socialist theory? >> Yes. No. Absolutely. So no. He is
a liberal and he supports capitalism definitionally in every
single way. He is not a bog standard socialist. You want to say
he's like an outer outer outer perimeter suck. Maybe. Sure. >> Is
this Bernie Sanders he's talking about right now? the guy who's
like openly supporting Venezuela, Cuba, every communist nation
on the planet. But >> what? Damn what? What does sock stand
for? Damn what? >> Outer perimeter. Out. What does perimeter
mean? Outer perimeter. >> National Socialist. >> Yeah.
No. So, okay. To answer because the reason that we got off on
this topic was because Connor keeps we haven't really taken the
bait of Conor's constant conspiracy baiting about like people
are basically all just tankies that are socialist, right? But
I think that it's important to >> No, I think you guys
are useful idiots. I think there's
actually completely conceded that you had an complete incomplete
understanding of socialist history. You asked a question that
I wasn't able to answer. >> Absolutely not. You said, "Oh,
hold on, hold on. You asked me a question, so I'm going to answer
it." >> I didn't ask you a question. I brought up Yeah.
You said, "Are you going to concede that you have a completed
history?" No, I don't concede at all. You brought up socialist
who were you want you you mentioned western socialists who under
the control of western governments. >> So just to be clear,
when the western government is controlled by socialists, it's
a socialist government. That's how elections work. You take power.
You take power and you take power.
>> Stop. Stop. Stop. It kind of boy. If today we replace
Trump, Hold on. If we replace Trump with um pick a socialist
that you think is a good socialist with the American Just because
now our president identifies as a socialist, does that make America
socialist country? Now, >> I'm not saying that these I'm
asking a question. Yes or no? >> I'm I'm literally answering
directly your question. Like you gave me like one word before
you interrupted me. Okay.
>> So, yeah. Yeah. Well, I mean, I haven't been the one
interrupting you for the most part. Um, you're talking about
the guy who is, which is kind of what this whole about
>> has been interrupted far more than anybody else in this
conversation.
>> I'm not saying that these countries that these countries
became socialists because they had socialist governments. I'm
saying they had socialist governments for many points of time
in their history. Okay. Now,
please hold on, hold on, hold on. I got to change my question
now. >> Again, if we simply take Trump out and put an socialist
in, is America run by a socialist government now? >> Obviously
not. It's it's run by social government can be a reference to
the party in power. So for example like um you know Clement Atley
was a social he's a socialist government in the sense they're
you can have a a government that broadly avows socialism and
understands they work within a a democratic system and they're
not going to immediately seize the means of production. This
has been proven out in multiple countries throughout the world.
That's like econo's point is that yes you don't have to be a
socialist. You you can be who advocates for policies within a
liberal framework. Absolutely you can respect you can be somebody
who believes in democracy and is a socialist operates within
the liberal framework that most democratic uh democratic countries
have most liberal dem democracies have >> is zultan rami
is is New York City socialist because he's the mayor now
when you question is the government of the day socialist if he
said >> who's playing now
wait can we just why don't we just finish oh you're about to
get owned again so you're running wait
I'm trying to clarify terminology and you don't want to do that.
So like when people refer to the government meaning the people
in charge of the government, it's a socialist government. Doesn't
necessarily mean the structure itself is is socialist.
>> I'm telling you why there's there's different meanings
of the word. >> The reason the reason >> important
distinction because there are socialist government socialist
like leaders or parties that broadly kind of are define themselves
as socialist who will operate within the framework of the government
they're in. They won't try to change that framework cataclysmically
just because they're in power. Why I bring up all of the dozens
and dozens and dozens of different labor governments and social
democratic and fundamentally socialist governments that have
existed in all of these different countries and Europe and Ocean
and >> If if they if they acknowledge this then they absolutely
are insane for not picking Hassan as the leader of their country
over Donald Trump. American countries as well is because at the
same time that Connor says socialism is essentially fundamentally
in some conspiratorial sense an authoritarian ideology with authoritarian
ideals that will do authoritarianism and millions of people concurrently
to the very same things that Connor was describing. You had socialist
governments take power through democratic elections convincing
running on so
>> so Hassan wouldn't be moderated by the constitution.
Are you out of your what?
is a Connor boy like actually a genius? Is he just getting them
to argue for his position? Is a Conno boy like bathing them?
Is he actually like 100
190 IQ just like actually pi pipering these people into just
totally agreeing with his and Pisco's positions? >> Socialist
platforms being in charge of the militaries by the
>> Can I finish the point? Can I we just [__]
point? >> Okay. So when the socialist government is now
in charge of the police apparatus and the military and all of
that stuff when they lose the next election, what did they do
across all of these different countries? They left power and
there was a turnover in government. So your idea that every like
basically every socialist movement is stamped with the authoritarianism
of Mao is completely ahistorical. Conor, wait
for wait for Would you consider Would you consider Trump an authoritarian
if he gave up power and will probably give up power at the end
of this? Yeah. >> Wait, did he Wait, did Desi, are you
arguing Trump gave up power? Is that what you're arguing right
now? Are you serious, dude? What principle does this person have?
What belief do they have in this entire world that they're just
he just argued, well, Trump gave up power?
Huh? Huh? Huh? The guy making the January 6 documentary is like,
"Well, Trump gave up power."
>> Authoritarian. And we have right now the US government
is like authoritarian in stature. Yes. Sure. Okay. So I I just
quickly it feels it feels a little silly to say like we were
talking about socialist countries but now we switched to socialist
governments and then it's like you >> how did neither of
them just ask oh so you're arguing Trump just gave up power?
>> How did how do you not just say how do you not just
say literally so Trump you you'd argue Trump just gave up power?
>> Open up and look inside and it's just >> we were
talking about socialist we weren't talking about
Wait. Okay. Hold on. Also wait. You talked about like what socialism
is and you made it sound like the spooky thing of authoritarianism
and all this. Would you concede that like a central tenant of
socialism is the overthrow of the capital class often times via
violent revolution that is like a central tenant of socialism?
>> No. No, that's not like ideologically definitionally
like like in capitalism you have private ownership where individuals
can own firms and hire employees and whatever.
>> I'll answer your question directly. Okay. So I would
compare what the question that you just asked similar to the
development and emergence of liberalism. Liberalism developed
and emerged across the planet across different stages of development
across different points in time and it did so in sometimes very
violent ways and in sometimes through legislative reform and
so similar you say hey an I was just going to say you say hey
an ideal of socialism is the abolition of private property to
which I would say generally >> like boy's argument would
be the Nordic model is like an evolution towards democratic socialism
right they want a socialist government they keep pushing for
more socialist policies and they are doing it so in a democratic
fashion and there is nothing wrong with that >> speaking
certainly That's a that's a core tenant of almost every socialist
thinker across the history of socialism. But that is not a statement
on the method by which we get to that final instate. The method
is up for debate and it has been debated and many different methods
have been used by world. Okay. So just following this like very
briefly in what world is there ever a peaceful revolution where
all of capital is >> So well I what >> that hasn't
happened. >> You talking about there's there's you can
imagine could you conceive of a
>> like Yeah. So re the whole point of peaceful peaceful
revolutions basically never happen. Right? The whole point of
it being democratic would be it would be very slow over time.
This is the entire purpose of democratic socialists. They want
to move towards socialism. They want to move towards more social
policy, the abolishment of capital, the abolishment of like for-profit
enterprise, right? But they don't start there because they are
a country that runs on for-profit enterprise, right? You try
to move the whole world in that >> Let me let me let me
just ask you this. Could you conceive of a world where the means
of production are entirely collectively owned? Could you conceive
of that? >> I could conceive of that. Yes. >> Okay.
So, and and people have said worker cooperatives, national industry,
things like that. So, we know that things like worker cooperatives
and things like national industries and things like state services
do exist and we know that they've come into existence. They've
come into being with democratic frameworks and liberal democratic
sort of processes. >> So, none of responsive to what I
asked. So, I'm saying how would we abolish all private property
without violence? >> So, I so what I would say is that
we would abol in in this theory we could >> we would be
abolishing sections of private capital without violence. And
you would probably slowly work out the companies that you don't
want. Like right now, I think you could abolish basically all
private insurance. The government could run all insurance for
everybody on the planet. Like any government could run insurance
for everybody, right? So there's no real reason to have private
insurance. It's just about eating out a profit at the cost of
like taxpayers or the cost of citizens. That would be something
you'd get rid of first and then you could slowly weed out industries
that don't really need to be done for anymore because the government
has figured it out. That they've been figured out. Abolish private
property through. Now, I don't even believe in that, but like
I think you could slowly work out industries you do not want
running in a private sense because there's a perverse incentive
for the people who run that industry, right? You'd slowly work
them >> through the same exact means by which we've socialized
property in the currently existing world through the ballot box,
through democratic
Do you agree it's logically possible? >> This isn't a debate.
We're not lo
That's not relevant. Why don't you just grant it? Why don't you
just grant it? Why don't you just grant it? Then why don't you
just Tik Tok >> clips? Why don't you just grant it? >> The
issue The issue with saying that we've socialized some things
is we're not doing that because we want socialism. We're doing
that because we recognize it as a failure of capitalism to succeed
in some particular area. But if you want to move to a fully socialist
state of affairs, it seems like that would necessitate according
to what >> why do you have to move to a fully socialist
state of affairs? >> Almost all socialists will tell you
in good faith will require some form of violence, right? Because
what do they say constantly? Caught a liberal and a fascist bleeds.
When the revolution comes, liberals will side with fascists.
These are statements that almost every single socialist I've
seen everybody all socialists will say this, right? So in that
case, doesn't having the socialist concept in mind necessitate
some future
Why don't you make the case that it entails violence? >> I
literally just did
give up willingly their property, meaning they will always >> You're
literally on a you're on like he's going to go, well, who who's
arguing for like the democratic socialization of most industries
in the United States? And a Connor boy is going to go like, "Hey,
I am on a show with like Pisco and you've heard of me. I've been
on your show and that's me. That's me arguing for that." Yeah,
that's me. Hi. In spite violently defend it. This is why socialist
say things like the institution of policing exists only to defend
capital interest. I can walk you
me. I think
if what you mean is if what we mean is violence is entailed by,
you know, the use of the police force. If that's what you mean
by violence and enforcing these restrictions would require like
enforcement, I guess it would entail violence. But that's not
the violence that you're talking about. You're equivocating violence.
What you mean by
the point?
Would you agree? Wait, wait,
Stop. Stop. Stop. I I don't want to be. But again, >> you're
such a >> Destiny did ask a question. I do want that though.
He ask you, do you understand what he means when he says Well,
repeat your question real quick. Destin Socialist view police
is a violent institution. What do they mean when they say that?
Go ahead. >> I think the socialist Yeah. Yeah. I I think
the socialist and libertarian often times believe that it entails
violence because they're enacting violence but because
wait so I'm just going to ask you a question. Does capitalism
require violence in the same way? >> I don't know. I don't
have a good I don't know. I don't have a position. I don't know
about that. I don't know. I don't know. How many times can you
say I don't know like a totally
ballless spineless coward before people start noticing?
>> I don't know. I Man, it's hard to say. Man, I I really
don't know. I really Why are you debating? Leave. If you have
no soul, if you have no spine, if you cannot stand behind anything
you believe, then leave. Don't come on here and argue and then
go I don't know every time you have to answer an uncomfortable
>> Require violence. Yes or no? >> Yes. Not necessarily.
>> Wait. No, it doesn't. No. >> Wait, wait. Doesn't
>> like like Connor Connor is being good faith here. He
said yes. Obviously, >> this is if you've ever listened
to Andrew Wilson argue about anything, this is an entirety of
force doctrine, right? >> Necessarily violence. I don't
know. You're asking the most simple question in the world. Is
me owning a Red Bull, does that require violence? Not
>> Yes. What prevented So, the Red Bull would have been
made at a factory. What prevented a bunch of pirates from going
and stealing the ingredients and selling them off to a different
company? Violence. The implication of violence. Society running
peacefully inquire. It implies violence. Everything requires
violence. call the conse
just just relax. Does the widespread establishment of a capitalist
system in America require violence? >> Violence define
violence. What do you mean by violence? >> Violence meaning
the use of uh >> the trail of tears of course use of force
to defend property rights. >> This this is so embarrassing
for him and everybody should see this. This is not any less embarrassing.
Hisco arguing about like the food thing and trying to get it
down to definition so he could like eco out to win. This is so
much more embarrassing. Right. This is Destiny like performatively
pretending to be a so that he doesn't have to bite a bullet and
like lose a tiny portion of an argument. Like dude, just be honest.
>> Am I muted? Yes, you have to defend private property.
You >> agree with you agree. You agree with Conor, don't
you, Stephen?
>> Dude, what if somebody's stealing your blades of grass?
Stephen, how do you stop them from stealing your blades of grass?
Steven, do you not consider any argument you've ever made in
your past life at all? Stephen, how do you defend your blades
of grass? How will you defend them? >> You don't So you
don't agree with >> Let me know when I can talk for 30
>> Do you know why he doesn't want to agree with you? He
doesn't want to agree with you because he thinks that you're
making them morally equivalent in the violence that no
is not the same violence that's required. Everyone everyone is
doing this thing everyone. >> Okay. Everyone's doing this
thing where they're trying to tell like everyone else what they're
they're saying like Connor's place. Well, Destiny is saying this
and then D will be saying I will say Conor was correct though
like those are different types of violence. So for instance,
when you talk about does capitalism necessitate violence? >> No
way. He didn't think of a counterargument and then Conor gave
him >> And you say yes to that. Well, that's the same type
of violence that any country, socialist included, would necessitate,
which is the ability to
Hassan say could be used to uphold the socialist system, Destiny,
what type of violence did Hassan say could be used to uphold
the socialist system? Was that the exact kind of violence that's
used to uphold the capitalist system? Was that the exact thing
he said or laws or whatever? But that's different. That's different
than if violence that is necessitated ideologically to prevent
things like say free enterprise or private corporations which
kind of violence that socialism would necessit but capitalism
would necessitate that's saying what kind of violence you
>> no no so please go one second so Destiny so I disagree
that there's a distinction in the type of violence that we're
talking about here so for instance what I mean by that is that
in so
>> okay so >> it's a panel if you don't want to throw
elbows on a panel don't join a panel >> I just wanted
to [__] muddy the water let it sit for a little bit
>> yeah this Conor Connor is here for no purpose Connor
is actually worthless to this panel and it's just a very good
indication like oh I don't want to be here with like Connor's
content he can be content but he is worthless in this >> I'm
not
counter points was brought up because a guy I asked initially
declined. I thought I had a good point. >> So counter points
is is here to kind of balance the scales. >> [__]
you too for saying that I'm your second date. Jesus. >> It's
okay. I still love you. But >> anyway so I don't think
it's different Destiny. Okay. Because for instance, if you were
to say, hey, like necessarily if you were to achieve the socialist
ideal, that requires violence. In so far as what we're talking
about is a reestablishment of what property rights means, right?
So for instance, if we were to say like, oh, we did a con boy
with socialis and characteristics. We got 90% of the way here,
and now the socialists are in power. And they're going to go
the full hundred. They're going to say, hey, everything that's
currently privately owned has to be sold >> Hold on. You're
playing I feel like I I didn't even get to the >> No, because
you wait, hold on, wait. Because you just skipped all the hard
part. If you're going to tell me that how do we go from 90% public
ownership to 100% public ownership? That's not very hard to do.
You have a majority stake in >> this is why this is why
you probably have to do what don't want to do.
Start asking if Start asking about his quotes. Okay, Desessie,
how many times did you like double down on wanting to that 15-year-old
at an MLG event? How many times you start throwing those? Okay,
they want to throw elbows. Throw the elbows. Pisco's got nothing
like that, right? They Pisco's got all this whole quiver of arrows
that he use >> every single company in the entire country.
The question is, okay, so you get Okay, first of all, I'll just
say this briefly. If that's the harder part, then it's surprisingly
achievable. Norway has literally already socialized twothirds
of their nation's wealth. They already like have collectivized
twothirds of their firms. Now wealth is not wealth. Why did you
say that? I can't believe you're being intentional. So I can
answer question. My my question very specifically was how do
you do it without appropriation
as example? >> Yeah, use
I'm not talking about wealth. I'm talking about firms. >> The
reason why Nor Okay. So a lot of the firms in Norway are still
privately owned because Norway doesn't have as developed a capital
market as the United States. So shockingly, if the United States
had Norway Nordic institutions for collectivizing wealth, we
would be much more able to socialize our domestic economy than
those economies because a lot of the companies in production
in those societies aren't traded on liquid stock markets. Now
>> wait for Norway, I'm just asking for Norway. If you
said of the 90% of the wealth that's publicly owned, how much
of that is just tied to their oil? Okay. So,
what you just said was a total lie, right? I want to answer your
question.
>> He's just soying out the whole >> 90% of a broad
market that's invested across a whole separation of multitudes
of industries is way different than just socializing your means
of energy. >> No, that's not what Nor
have a misunderstanding of how >> No, you're probably right,
Cherry. These >> institutions work and you have such strong
opinions on them and it really me off at a certain point. You
don't know what you're talking about, but you have these very
strong opinions. Norway. Yes. A lot of the wealth that they've
accumulated doesn't necessarily come from their oil wealth, it
comes from the returns to their oil wealth being socialized in
a public fashion. Okay. So, I would agree that one of the prerequisites
to Norway's specific success is its oil wealth. But America is
a resourcerich country. America has a huge amount of land rents
that we could socialize. America has things like a central bank
that can create money, debt financing, other tax revenue. The
financing for this is just not a question. America is a richer
society than Norway. We have more financing hard economy. That's
why I'm asking about expropriation. The United States government
could I I'm not you know number they could print off however
much money they want. >> That's why I'm saying that's why
I'm saying that's why I'm saying we could get to 90%
because we have such liquid markets where people are willing
to share their >> like literally the point Econ boy is
making is that you can actually hostily take over a ton of firms
because like a bunch of the companies in the United States are
p or publicly traded, right? You literally don't have to go and
take money from people. You don't have to take property from
people. You can literally buy it through government financing.
That's what he's saying. He's not saying you have to. He's saying
you literally don't have to expropriate because you there is
a mechanism for buying this property already. They are publicly
traded. >> Sell their shares for essentially the the strike
price. And really quick
I want to get >> like saying something totally normal right
now. >> Get us back on on track. Finish. We're getting
we're getting bogged down. Essentially, my main point, skipping
past all of that, is that the estimate the claim necessitates
violence. Now, in so far as going from like whatever percentage
of voluntary transactions we could get up to, 60 70 80 90% whatever,
and then we have to go the rest of the way with some amount of
expropriation. Yeah. You'd have to pass a bill and reestablish
some property rights and you'd have to buy out those businesses.
private owners. >> I can't I can't make the point. Go.
>> No, because you're speaking in like the most like wish
you'd have to reestablish. You'd have to steal all the firms
from all the time. wanted to do another debate about this specific
>> we can make a one-on-one or something. >> Just
real quick, just real quick for now. I do have a question maybe
to get to to kind of take us on on a track that I I'm interested
in. Right. >> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Let's Wick,
just hold on a second. Why don't we grant that socialism only
means what Steven means and what Connor means. So, let's let's
put aside the semantic. So, if what you mean is by socialists
are specifically Marxist Leninists who want to do this mass expropriation,
then agreed. Wait, wait. Then, then agreed. They shouldn't be
in the halls of of democratic power. Where's our >> Okay.
No, no, no. Hold on, hold on, hold on. This is another problem
between liberals and progressives, and I'll be very calm while
I articulate this. My frustration with econo boy. >> My
frustration is that Hassan says he like only wants socialized
medicine. You believe that, but he's actually a Marxist Lenist.
And you guys aren't willing to excise all of these people who
are Marxist Lenists.
>> Is that expropriation is defined necessarily. Shut the
don't
I'm on your panel, you I can talk, but I feel like it. This is
the peace and destiny, you [__] So the definition
of expropriation is the action by the state or authority taking
property from it owner for public user. >> This guy is
this guy is actually the biggest content cook in the world
>> This should actually be criminal expropriation. So what
we're saying is that or at least what I'm saying is that I believe
a free market needs to have a balance between the appropriation
of a property for the public good and the privile to do its own
thing. A private market is necessary to generate the wealth in
order to create a welfare state. So if you say well we can just
go ahead and command slowly through the government voting increasing
control of public utilities and the parts of the market then
I don't care if it's done democratically. I don't give a
part of my what you mean what you mean by social is what you
mean by socialism is only those people who espouse these Marxist
lenist ideas that you find to be >> Who's the person that
dropped out is >> I I've defined for you seven times
through democracy. You can get it through democracy. That doesn't
make it >> You got to let peace go finish. Peace go finish.
And then I have a question. >> Let's get through the semantic
[__] If what you mean is that >> semantic I've
given you a specific definition seven times >> points.
You got to let him at least finish a sentence. >> Then
he needs to listen to what I'm saying. If >> he Conor is
such a waste of >> not listening to what you're saying,
it will be stupid and embarrassing. >> Yeah. Represented
accurately. So, we have a semantic difference. I'm trying to
chart that out. Like >> I honestly there needs to be like
a panel host who will just like actually say you're you're timed
out for like 10 minutes. You're actually detracting from this
conversation. I'm like getting rid of you. >> We literally
do some magic. >> So, you disagree that socialism is the
decommodification of basic human needs and workers only the means
of >> Yeah. So I don't So I think socialism means much
wait I think socialism means much more than that because for
me uses >> that's a good hold on hold on hold on hold on
that's actually excellent point please go what do you mean when
you say socialism be >> so so I think when I see things
wait when I think socialism as at its broadest at its broadest
I understand socialism to be workers only means of production
that's at its broadest I think that there's a lot of shades of
gray there and socialism doesn't just mean what um Connor means
and the reason that is I think that meaning right that of a word
is its use right like if what we mean by a word is Like there's
no like correct objective answer to what socialism means. My
theory of like words mean is how they're used by people in real
there's multiple definitions. But >> Destiny is right that
AOC Bernie Sanders AOC Bernie Sanders and Zodon Morami Salami
are not socialists because they don't believe in workers only
the means of production. >> Wait when you say Destiny is
quote unquote right? What do you mean by that? >> No. Wait
what?
Those people define themselves as socialists. Those people define
themselves as socialist. Are you saying he's saying I don't think
that definition is true because it meaning is used. the way people
use socialists. That's what I mean, right? We have democratic
socialist countries, these Nordic models, right? That's a part
of socialism by use.
So don't just yell and he just cuts in with nothing of value.
He just cuts in and basically windbills his on the screen. Shut
the >> I just said it. He's right. According to his own
definition, AOC, Bernie Sanders, and Zultan Monsami don't advocate
for workers owning the means of production. So by the definition
that you just provided for us they are not socialists kind of
silly. I >> I said at its broadest it's workers only the
mean of production but that means of production I think broadest
mean broadest means it includes the most amount of people. So
if your broadest definition
they necessarily follow under
Conor shut the up but I'm trying to chart out make your words
make sense. >> I'm trying to chart out a semantic difference.
You >> like Connor is objectively just trying to derail
anything Pisco says. Dude, it's actually getting to the point
where I'm starting to like I'm starting to think like, dude,
does Connor know that like Destiny's wrong here and he's just
going to try to derail this as much as possible because he knows
this is his meal ticket and he's like, oh, Pisco is like actually
a threat. So every time Pisco speaks, I'm going to basically
stand up and jerk off like a homeless person on the train. Is
that like actually what's going on here?
Cuz that's what it looks like to me is he's just going to stand
up and jerk off like he's a homeless person on the train and
disrupt everything and ruin everybody's day. Shut the up Conor.
>> Understand what I mean when I say a semantic difference
with the having to do with words >> and their meaning.
Okay? So in your version of of the word socialism, you would
not ascribe uh for example singlepayer to be a socialist policy.
You wouldn't say that someone like uh Bernie Sanders is a socialist.
You wouldn't say that China as it currently exists is a socialist
country because your definition of socialism is more narrow.
I say let's get past that semantic difference. I think like in
terms of how people use the word socialist, you guys are just
wrong in terms of the usage of the word. But let's get past that.
If what you mean >> I will not get past that. >> We
just spent this whole time arguing about what the right definition
of
>> Hey Pisco, can you tell me what your definition is?
Well, my definition is like meaning is use and so here's Shut
the up. You just asked me what my definition is. You agreed to
mean production. It's like no, I'm explaining to you what my
definition is. Could you let me explain it for two seconds? >> I'm
going to the girls. You're going to circle. You both are going
to circle the train again. >> Hold on. Stop. We are going
to get to a more I think we >> disagreement. So you're
using I think that you guys have a proprietary definition. I
think you guys have a proprietary definition of the word socialist.
That isn't how we use the word and it's not charted in in >> before
we move on. I want to articulate why this is important. I think
that you in a >> dude this is boy are I'll be rude even
though I love you. I think you are >> This is like having
a 10-year-old at like uh some serious discussion and you that
you have to entertain them. You have to pretend that they have
something valuable to say. >> Sleeves for tankies. And
so you're trying to expand you're trying to expand the definition
of socialism to be to >> this is this is unfortunate but
this is trust me this is formative for Pisco. Okay. These people
aren't going to be good faith with you. You're on the other side
now. They don't actually care in having a real conversation or
about having a real conversation. They don't care about entertaining
your points. They they know that you're right and they are here
only
only okay
to with you. They are here only to be bad faith and try to make
you look as bad as possible. That is their only goal. They don't
want to they they understand your point perfectly. They just
want to try to hurt you. They just want to try to hurt your reputation.
>> Redistributive social services. I don't like it when
you do that. And I disagree with you. >> You're here to
give cover to Stephen and that's fine. But I just want to be
very >> Cover has been given. I've argued with >> You're
trying to make the You're trying to make the conversation You're
trying to make the conversation You're trying to make the conversation
impossible. You're not You're making the conversation impossible.
>> With every single argument that you've given me. You're
making a conversation making the conversation impossible. >> I'm
going to please go is going to finish. He's going to finish his
point. He's going to ask his question and then we're going to
see if it goes anywhere. And if it doesn't, I have productive
ways we can go. The counter points are Hold on real quick. Counter
points. If you can't control yourself, you will be >> Okay.
I will mute you. Please go ahead. >> I thought this was
a battle. >> It is a
mute. >> Only took like what, an hour and a half. How long
would we go for? About an hour and a half for realize that Conor
has nothing valuable to say. asking what the word is like in
terms of what the definition ought to be if there's any ought
to what a word is like well how do people use the word right
so this is that's what I take to be a semantic difference and
you saying you have a vision of the usage of that word socialist
which is much more narrow than my conception of how that word
is used by ordinary people but we can put aside that right like
let's put aside the semantic difference about what words ought
to mean or what they actually are in any objective sense let's
just get to the meat of it if what you mean by socialist doesn't
include AOC doesn't include Bernie and their policies doesn't
include what I think most people would take to be socialist policies
then and it only includes people like Marxist Leninist and Mauist
then yeah I then with Then what's disagreement? They shouldn't
be included. They shouldn't be >> Disagreement. You asked
a question, I'm going to answer it. I feel like I am using a
narrow and tailored definition because I think that the people
who selfidentify as that and actually have read the text related
to the ideology, that's how they selfidentify. And I think that
they are using progressives and liberals and social democrats
and they're conflating these terms back and forth so they can
expand the at which point they are relevant. >> None of
this none of this actually matters. You already gave up Bernie
Sanders. We know what Bernie Sanders died in the wool beliefs.
We know Bernie Sanders read the communist manifesto manifesto.
We know Bernie Sanders doesn't misunderstand these concepts and
you've already given us Bernie Sanders is an acceptable member
of the coalition >> in the modern social parlance and I
believe that you and Econo boy are helping them and I don't like
it which is why I'm here to tell you I don't like >> Connor
just keeps he keep doing this. You keep just asserting that there's
some sort of conspiracy broadly within people who identify as
socialists to try and sort of co-opt liberal frameworks. And
when I point out the You said that millionth time. So I haven't
just said that I was about. >> So Counterpoint has not
actually engaged with what Econo Boy has said. And Econo Boy
is trying again to engage with a brick wall whose point is not
to have a good faith uh conversation with Econ boy or anybody
here whose purpose is to be a wall between Destiny and Pisco.
That's the only goal here. >> Finish the point. I haven't
just said that five times. I've included an explanation of the
history of a huge range of different democratic, liberal, socialist
movements over time that weren't just pretending until they got
power and then they would become
In fact, they were just democrats it turned out. And you keep
ignoring that and then assert reasserting without any backing
your conspiracy about the >> you and you don't refute anything
that Codle Boy says. You basically go, "Well, I don't like that
version." And then you just keep saying they're they have some
conspiracy that they're going to co-opt the liberal government
and and destroy
>> Broad 10% of the base of the Democratic party socialist
stop kind of kind of >> Welcome welcome straight ra. Thank
you very much for the ra they say that they're doing this that
there is a broad members of American socialist people who
stated again who state that they are doing this. They call themselves
the vanguard. Why do you think they call themselves the vanguard
kind of boy? Why do you think they chose that name? Every single
person on this panel said to the extent that there's evidence
that people are doing that, they should not be included in so
you are condemning specifically the Vanguard today. >> Wait,
wait, wait. Straight.
>> I haven't heard Shut up. Please go ask Conway today
on my show. You are condemning specifically the Vanguard. >> What
are they saying? >> Okay, I don't know what they said references.
Okay, so first of all, one clue is in the name, the Vanguard.
And we talked with the evidence. Hey, I'm giving you evidence,
right? Like with Han, there's evidence that he literally says
he just wants to co-op democratic frameworks. Like he's literally
said this, right? So that's a tweet today or yesterday calling
Pete a rat or that he looks like a rat. It reminds him of a rat
or whatever. >> Is that evidence that he is trying to institute
author authoritarian? >> Just be mean. >> Wait, what
is acceptable evidence?
>> Destiny, what did it mean when you tweeted at that that
father of that 12-year-old girl asking if uh the 12-year-old
girl's crushed her? What did that mean, Destiny? What can we
infer about your behavior from that? What did that mean? Is your
daughter dang kid? Is your daughter that kid? What did you mean
there Destiny? >> Trying to institute authoritarian communism
if they work in the media. >> Wait, wait. Statements like
Asange gave >> So they've done shows about ignoring the
Constitution and ignoring the Supreme Court dissolving. >> I
haven't seen that. Yeah. Yeah. So So to the extent they have
those beliefs and to the extent wait to the extent they have
the Vanguard for a reason.
>> Wait, let me give you what you want. First of all, the
rapist, right? Yes. So, so if they have the position that we
should ignore the constitution, if they have the position that
we should, you know, ignore democratic systems and get rid of
all that stuff, then no, they should not be part of a quoteunquote
coalition. And if what you mean by be part of a coalition is
be at the halls of power, design policy, that kind of stuff.
If the prescription is don't talk to them, I think that's a different
kind of thing, right? I don't think is anyone
Okay. Okay. So, to the extent that they have these positions,
to the extent that they're crypto about their authoritarianism
and test tendencies, there's no disagreement. They shouldn't
be a part of the quoteunquote coalition. What do you mean by
that? >> Can I Okay. Here. Okay. You know what? Let like
this is what this feels like. This is why this such a crazy conversation,
okay? If you have two groups of friends and people in one group
really likes Chinese food and the other group really likes Indian
food and you're trying to vote on where to go to eat, okay, every
weekend, all right? And you have this new group of people who
show up and they say, "I really like wings." And that's the only
thing that they ever say about your Chinese food that they like,
but you include them in your group of friends who are voting
to say, "I want to go eat Chinese food." Because they only show
up for the wings. But you know that when they go back to their
own group of friends, they say, "As soon as we have enough wing
voters, we're going to go to the pizza place." That's the issue
that we're running into here is you're pretending like these
guys who only like wings are supporting your entire Chinese food
weekly outing when in reality >> that no literally nobody
is doing that. Literally nobody thinks Hassan supports every
part of the Democratic party. Hassan is pro Palestine. Nobody
thinks that. That is a total misrepresentation of everybody's
point. You are a [__] Does this guy Dude I him and
Connor are in like a race to the bottom for who can bash themselves
over the head with a baseball bat and lose IQ points. Incredible.
They're just trying to build up enough people and they've already
said this so that they have enough people to go to the pizza
place next week. That's the issue that respond to that briefly.
Okay. And I think I can speak for Pisco on this as well that
my point is that that is true with the great of people that call
themselves
No, you're going to say yes. And you're going to say that of
all the voters, whatever. I'm talking about the entire media
apparatus. That's why earlier I asked you, can you give me a
single person in the media apparatus that identifies as socialist
that also supports the Democratic party? But then
I a joke to you? Am I a am I a Did you not You literally talked
about how I'm a Do you hate me because I identify as a socialist
and I am literally supporting the Democratic party or uh how
about Pisco's girlfriend, Joe? How about Joe? The silly serious
seems to be somebody who is a socialist or at least has strong
socialist leanings who supports the Democratic party.
Like I these people do exist. They do exist in the media apparatus.
Joe just had like a million view view uh a million view video
on YouTube like six months ago. What are we talking about? >> Okay,
so to to address your point extremely directly about the entire
>> uh I don't know that Joe is definitely a socialist.
She definitely is socialist leaning. She's far she's far more
leftleaning. I don't know if she qualifies herself or or classifies
herself as a socialist. >> I'm Wick
one individual.
>> No, no, he said that's why I asked you, but I'm addressing
his actual point. I want you to answer if you can. I I honestly
don't know. I don't know. It's probably the case. Isn't that
problematic if you you're now
>> Why is does a cado boy not know that he exists either?
Is Ko a cot boy actually failing to point out that he exists?
A boy. A boy.
No, it's the same question that I asked earlier. Central to the
point that I just gave right now. I asked you for a single person
that says they actually like Chinese food and all you can give
me are people who support 15our minimum wage or wings who really
want to go to the pizza place which is have the Vanguard party
which is why they're called the Vanguard which is why they on
Chinese food or the Democratic party over and over and over again.
That's an issue. we are talking if we're talking about media
figures who call themselves a socialist um and in terms of like
of them who sims for the Democratic party it's it's it's certainly
not a long list to the extent that I could Google and find names
right now for you but so I would agree with that and so I've
already said and everyone on this podcast seems to be in agreement
that to the extent that many people and it is a problem flatly
it is a what you're describing is absolutely a problem to the
extent that people in the media space that do that do the exact
things that you and Connor and Wick have >> uh Kingler
the idea here okay the idea here is the problem is who supports
the Democratic party no matter what And nobody does that. Nobody
who is an independent media creator supports the Democratic Party
no matter what. You don't need them to support the Democratic
Party no matter what. That's stupid. They should never be sitting
there as socialists and say, "I have no criticism for the Democratic
Party." They should never sit there with a moral opposition to
the war in Gaza and say, "I support the Democratic Party entirely."
That is totally disingenuous. Why the would you expect that to
be the standard? That is a insane standard.
That would be absurd for to expect that out of people. There
are plenty of socialists who do support the Dems who would say
vote blue no matter who. Sam Cedar would I think be an obvious
example. No,
Pisco and I are in complete agreement. It's not >> I would
imagine a lot of socialists are blue no matter who. Especially
in the Trump environment >> that we just disagree. It's
that we are in complete agreement that these are not people who
should be part of the inner party, who should be part of strategic
discussions, who should be part of the messaging of Democrats.
What I have said, and this is my last sentence before I guess
Connor wants to go, is that people like this should simply be
used as other platforms for Democrats to engage in for the purposes
of fundraising, for the purposes of spreading their message if
if Democrats want to go on Assange show or the Vanguard or Bon
and somebody was arguing that those people should be exised,
that they should not be interacted with. And now they've switched
their position. Right? This was the original disagreement. And
a Connor boy said no. And now somehow we've gotten to the place
where apparently Destiny and Connor go, "Oh, maybe that's not
so bad." No, you are. We're arguing it's bad. You're arguing
Assan needs to be exised on a Joy Gray or Kylin Clinsky or Kylin
Clinton Crystal show then that they should do that because they
shouldn't gave the alternative media spec in party. >> Sure,
but you understand that it undermines the Wait, wait, wait. You
understand that it undermines the out of the Democratic party.
If we're saying that all the good things that we support, I call
myself a socialist and I think all the good things that have
come to the Democratic party have come because of socialists.
And also all of the media people that call themselves socialists
hate Democrats and they constantly attack.
>> It's not that simple, bro. You're I know
Dude, just admit you lost. Just that all all the this entire
conversation should be you realized you took an insane position
that you can't defend and you're walking it back and you're doing
a whole dog and pony show here to try to argue why you've walked
it back or try to make it look like you haven't walked it back,
but you have out to me. You've admitted you lost. Stop pretending
otherwise. Stop every time I point out a question that proves
that you lost. Stop going, "Well, I don't really know. It's not
that simple. I don't know. I don't know. I don't know." really
like the
>> spine.
So to Destiny's question,
>> so to your question, Destiny, I do fully agree that
it is a problem that there is a disconnect between the typical
socialist politician and the typical socialist media figure.
I do agree that that's a problem. Okay. The only thing that the
only thing that started this entire discourse for the last week
was what I said was I just don't think that these alternative
media socialist media figures have that much of an effect on
electoral outcomes for democratic socialists and for liberals
broadly.
really what is the can I ask you then like so when you look at
like the like the 40 point drop in say like Dearborn supporting
the Democratic candidate do you really think that none of these
alternative media spheres have any influence whatsoever on
that is completely irrelevant or >> I I would never say
something so stupid as they don't have any influence or that
they don't have some determination of the outcome of elections
okay I would never say that when it comes to Dearborn specifically
I think that it is more sensible to say several things
I would say that generally speaking it seems like a lot of Muslim
immigrants revert to their not revert but like there there's
like a a coming to the mean of the average American conservative
view over time as they assimilate. You see that with other immigrants
groups as well as Muslim Americans. Number two, I think that
you see that with Muslim Americans specifically, they are particularly
sensitive to the Israel Palestine issue and whoever was in government,
it blew the up during a Democratic administration and so there
was a lot of reactionary sentiment with that issue in a lot of
Muslim communities. I think that reaction but two things. One
that so you said that it was a problem. I'm not going for gotchas
here. I don't give a [__] about I don't give another
but but the issue is that all of these elections are so close.
So if we agree that it is a problem and then we talk about how
I don't think I don't know that was a
reverted wait I don't think that they reverted to the mean in
one election cycle when it came to voting issues. Okay if you
say that they voted because they were super energized by the
by the Israel Palestine issue. It doesn't make sense to me that
they would vote for Jill Stein because if you really cared about
that issue, I think that the clear choice, even if you think
they don't handle it as well, would have been the Democrat candidate
over the Republican candidate. So, the fact that there were so
many people wait the fact there were so many people left saying
or not, but so people in the left wing media apparatus all saying
they're both the same. All protesting the DNC, all protesting
all the Democrat, isn't that a problem?
give it to Why does he keep Why does he keep repeating is it
a problem? >> You just heard economics and I agree it's
a problem. Why did you repeat that at the end? Well,
>> why are you why are you like this? Why are you just
being a [__] >> Because if it's a problem,
then I don't know if we should be trying to appeal to the socialists,
which is the name of this panel, appealing to leftists. We should
be trying to court them if they're actively attacking the party
and >> Wait, but that I thought Econo Boy's already said
that he doesn't believe you should court the far left, right?
Economy and Pisco both disagree with this position. It's actually
name for the panel. The initial point was we don't have to court
these people. We use their platforms. We should not like actually
we should not absolutely excise them. We should talk to them
and then if they have good ideas, we should call out them. That's
the whole point. >> Elections are already so close. Oh,
look at the name of the panel. Look at the name of the pan. The
panel is is totally the panel name is completely ironic.
Uh and I I'm sure Pisco and Econ boy know that this is clearly
like they they're going to going to get on the name of the panel
when they never when they never held this position that we should
court the far left. They've never ever been there, right?
close and they're already turning off so many of our voters already
just it's
okay this this is why I wanted to ask the question earlier because
I think this gets to the heart of the matter it goes us back
on track and this is a question to peace go first and econom
points I will get to you I promise but I'm going to >> when
he behaves himself when he puts his hand up you yell at him and
when he yells you at him >> he could have
I'm not yelling at him >> you're not reinforcing good behavior
on this panel >> let me get my point out. Okay, then maybe
we can get to something. Okay,
>> the question becomes, who should as a whole, the Democratic
Party, the DNC, etc., who should they be aligning themselves
more with? People like AOC or people like Josh Shapiro?
>> Yeah, I don't understand how that is related to what
Stephen was just talking about. Right. So, we agree. So, I thought
he was >> Wick, you're obiscating. He just said some and
you're offiscating now. Could could I respond to what he said
or >> consider a circuit breaker? I I'll >> the question
directly. So >> Destiny gets to make this the second third
time that Destiny's got to make a point uninterrupted. Pisco
asked him to clarify and Destiny can't clarify at all. And then
Wick goes, you know, I'm going to I'm going to move us in a different
direction, guys. So to to answer the question directly, um I
think that because socialists are about 10% of the Democratic
base, generally speaking, the platform and the types of candidates
that we put forward should probably tilt moderate if we if the
only thing we care about is absolutely maximizing our vote share.
Okay. Winning elections. Fair enough. Okay. >> Now, I'll
say two things. I'll say that that's not necessarily always the
literal only thing that we would care about. Uh, now it's obviously
very very important. But then number two, just because they're
only 10% does not mean that we should completely ignore them
or treat them as or completely ostracize them from the movement.
That they have to also be appealed to because the Democratic
Party is a party of centrists, moderate like what you could call
like moderate tilt left people, slightly more tilt left people,
progressive people, and socialists. Every single one of those
groups needs to be represented. If we can demonstrate that by
excising or um >> what do you mean by that excelling
topic? Right. So Wick might have his feeling over it. When I
say exise, we're talking about the media environment. If you
call yourself a socialist and you constantly on the Democratic
party, um okay, so now Destiny's going to say, "Okay, we shouldn't
talk to you." Okay. Do you think that's going to stop those people
from being on? Do you think that's going to be helpful to you
to never network with these people, never collaborate with them
in any way? Right? Because I have I have it on good authority
that not is changing her thinking on this. Okay. Pisco now. So
apparently apparently if you don't if you don't include Hassan
if you don't bring Hassan to the DNC he'll stop complaining about
the Democratic party. Huh. I'm happy that your messaging evolved
on this. Yesterday you were saying you should go on places like
Hassan stream to fight with them. Sure. That's fine. I agree
with that. Nobody. I don't think anybody would wait no wait.
You just heard something changed. What changed? >> What
changed? that before it seemed that before it seemed like you
were a lot more lukewarm on whether or not Hassan is like kind
of an ally or whether or not those types of people >> No,
no, no. You find me one place where I said Assan is an ally.
>> You I never I never said that.
>> Destiny's just Destiny's just going to make assertions
without evidence again. He loves doing this. Destiny's favorite
thing in the world is making assertions with no evidence and
looking like a [__] when anybody calls him out for
it. Okay. And then having his cultlike audience clap like seals.
You guys so good, Destiny. You just said you said his goal is
inconsistent. And he never proves it. He never gives any evidence
of this whatsoever whatsoever, right? But they will all clap
and say, "Yes, yes." Oh, absolutely, Destiny. Absolutely. Yes,
Destiny. And oh, and yes, Rhox just pointed out precisely. Yes.
He's implicitly right now begging his chat, "Find where Pisco
said it. Find where Pisco said Hassan could be an ally." Right?
Because Pisco just got baited into saying, "Well, have I ever
called him an ally?" And it's like, well, what did Pisco mean
when he was saying that? It's it's it's
like this accusation of oh this accusation of a radioactive trait
and you go I don't do that and then there's like something you
could possibly spin in that direction and they're going to go
oh it's proven it's proven it's proven oh look pistol lies the
the bar for which the bar pis has to clear here is like the world
record high jump and the bar Destiny has to clear for his argumentation
is literally like like a millimeter from the floor. It's so cooked.
It's such a cooked environment to be in
>> through your entire I go I don't listen the same the
same way that you've been in this space and you can't remember
a single thing Assad has apparently said I'll say I don't have
your exact quote here okay but all I'm saying is that all I'm
saying is that it shouldn't be the goal of Democrats to appeal
to the center fold of what socialism is
what do you mean by excise I don't know what you mean >> somebody
calls himself a socialist if they constantly shut the Democrat
party then you don't treat them like they're part of your party
So when has Pisco ever done that? What is the actual What is
the actual contention here? When has Pisco ever said, you know,
somebody who on like the Vanguard people or something? When has
he ever said they're a part of the Democratic party? When when
has that happened? You're just making something up again. Destiny
can't argue within reality. He has to constantly twist reality,
right? >> Wait a second. Wait, no. So now we're now we're
different. If someone calls himself a socialist, because you
agree Bernie Sanders calls himself a socialist, right? >> We're
talking about the media sphere. Media media media. But econom
boy calls himself a socialist.
>> So should he we should excise him from that party? Correct.
>> Connor boy was coming on my platform. Can I >> It's
going to be Destiny added the uh what do you call it? The oh
constantly on the Democratic party. >> It's not a yes or
no question. I don't even know what part of your life you would
even in your lawyer school. You wouldn't have picked up on this
yes or no. So I don't know where any of this
>> Oh, I see. That's why people are saying I did this because
Destiny does this now. Destiny like dude, it's just funny. It's
not a bad tactic. It's it's literally something you employ when
people are being bad faith and they refuse to concede on things
that you know they're conceding on and they go I don't really
know. That's the whole purpose. Destiny is now trying to attack
the tactic trying to make Pisco stop doing it, right? Does a
would would a lawyer by the way just on as an aside would a lawyer
really not try to get a solid yes no answer in argumentation
in
Is that really true that a lawyer would not try to extract yeses
or nos? I think that's almost precisely what is for. Hey, did
this happen? Yes or no?
That's lit. I I watched all of the Karen Reed trial, right? I
have a very good idea of how they It seems like they do that
quite a bit. It's a fairly popular tactic actually.
Answer the question. Answer the
Answer the question. Answer the question, [__] Answer
the question. Why was coming on my stream is probably generally
right now it's going to be a fight over things like we are right.
Yes. And when earlier said, "Oh, we should go home on stream
and hash out something." It's going to be a fight over stuff.
Somebody who identifies >> as him from the party. Should
we exercise him from the party?
>> I don't know. I don't know what you're asking. I don't
know what you're even saying. What are you even saying right
now? I have no idea what you're
>> Dude, no spine. No spine. No spine. Pisco needs to keep
calling him a >> running. I dude I can't believe I pointed
this out with the zip zip guy and I explained Pisco needs to
just cut this guy's head off because he refuses to to stand with
a spine on anything. And now Destiny is doing the same tactic
today. Destiny must have watched that zip zip combo and gone,
"Oh, I'm actually totally wrong." And yeah, I have to be I have
to be the most spineless piece of to have any chance in this
debate. A show or running a program and they call themselves
socialists. Earlier I asked you guys, can you name a single one
of these people that don't constantly [__] on Democrats
and you guys couldn't think of a single name? I would say yes.
That is the subject >> Should I stop live and learn? Should
should he be on the podcast? Live and learn. Should I exercise?
>> You guys are going to start supporting socialist. Yes,
you should live and >> Hang on. Wait, wait, wait. So, so,
so you you think that econo boy we should not be platforming
econo boy because he labels himself a socialist. Is that
>> He's like moving in the direction of there. I'm much
saying like Sar of a was like moving in the direction. So even
though so even though economy gives you his understanding of
what socialism is, he explains himself just as a way I I assume
that Bernie Sanders and AOC would. Even though he says I'm not
a Marxist Lenist, even though you smeared him as saying he's
anti-democratic when he isn't anti-democratic. So even though
he caveats all what he means by the term socialism, just because
he labels himself socialism, you think that he really shouldn't
be on live and learn. >> Yeah. No, I wouldn't platform
him. You guys do what you want with your platform, but I wouldn't
want to.
>> So for me personally, I wouldn't. Desi, we're asking
for your moral prescription. This is another weasly
loser spineless thing to do. We're saying can you take a moral
position on anything? You
holy [__]
Holy [__] How many times is he just going to go?
I don't know. I don't know. I'm I For me personally, I wouldn't
do it. You think we're asking you personally or you think we're
this whole purpose is what you're prescribing your prescription?
No, he's asking about you personally. What is your prescription
for the world? Holy [__] Platform him and say, "Hey
guys, go check out their podcast where anti-democratic party
people like the Vanguard will Vanguard will be treated as friends
and allies that will come on to for a while and then immediately
where they'll go off to their own platforms to relentlessly on
the Democratic party." >> So So why are you hanging out
with >> Do you deny that any of that? >> Oh [__]
>> Hey, why you hanging out with Myron >> Because
every single time I hang out interaction my own, every time I
hang out with my own, it's a contentious >> Okay, so like
But >> wait, hold on. You recognize how stupid I was. You
realize you thought you had a big ass. >> Wait, wait, wait.
You totally buff up. You say Myron's a good interlocutor, that
he's good faith, that he is a really nice person, that he's very
loyal in the background. You You buff up things about him that
have nothing to do with actually. You don't you don't follow
that up by him and saying anything. You just all the time,
right? Wait, wait, wait, wait, but you guys have a nice conversation,
right? You you platform him, you have a nice conversation. >> Yes,
but it's combative. Nobody comes away from my stream. Hey guys,
make sure >> that's literally, isn't that literally what
economic boy was just advocating for? Go on socialist, go on
socialist platforms, talk to them, but be combative. Like actually
point out your differences. That's literally what Pisco and Destiny
were advocating for. Destiny just said, "I wouldn't platform
this." Right? He wouldn't platform this, but he does platform
iron. And he gives the exact reason that Pisco and Econo Boy
have given for why they go on other platforms. It would be to
be contentious, to actually disagree, show where the disagreements
are, right? That you wouldn't just go on there and say, "Oh,
yeah, we agree on everything. You guys are awesome. I want you,
my audience, to come over here. >> You go check out Fresh
and Fit. Like they have a lot of you guys going back and forth.
So just to be clear, when the Vanguard came on the podcast, they
were challenged at some point. >> They were challenged.
Correct. >> Wait, can we get him to agree that were they
challenged, Stephen?
>> Barely. Barely. Nitpicking. What do you mean they were
barely challenged? >> Just again, weasel weasel weasel.
Not taking a real position. Not saying anything. Not taking real
position.
>> Pisco should just keep calling him a spineless loser.
No wonder you had to share all those videos. non-conensual. You're
probably too scared to ask for a solid position on whether you
could share them because you're a spineless. I think that for
the most part you're >> yeah, cuz you're reacting like
a sped and you're like, oh my god, I can't believe they're being
nuanced and you're reacting that way. And the way yes or no is
going to talk about nuance the way the way that you're presenting
it makes people think that, oh, we're socialist. We're econo
socialist. No, we absolutely challenge them on the point of >> you
see this is this is how destiny works and it's so easy to see
through it, right? That Pisco is saying I'm not a socialist.
I'm not a communist. I don't do these things, right? And you're
you're trying to smear me as one because I have share a show
with somebody who will come on and explain and run down all of
their opinions with me. Right. >> Example of where he challenged
where you challenged specifically specifically on the point specifically
on the point of mansion. Specifically on the point of >> that
it was evil to make fun of the yes no argumentation style. What?
No, it's very funny to make fun of it. I'm saying it is actually
useful. It is a useful tool. That's why I employ it. That's why
a lot of people employ it. Right? If somebody's being a spineless
about whatever their their point is, you just say like, "Are
you making this point? Yes or no." Was this not our contention?
Yes or no. Right. Just say yes or no whether or not I understand
this
>> Lone. Stephen, you tried to use that against you. Oh,
sure. Oh, right. Well, no. He was saying that it was inconsistent.
I always thought it was funny. I always thought it was like it
was But it is effective. You agree? We did challenge them with
facts and logic.
>> Yeah. Facts and logic. >> So when you say so,
so when you said barely, what did you mean barely? What did you
mean by >> barely? I think people would go on that show
and they would assume that all of you guys like had a similar
political project in mind. You all shared like a political goal,
a political project. >> Okay. Okay. So why where why do
you get that impression when we're disagreeing with them on specific
issues? >> Hold on. [__] this. Everybody else
minutes. I've had my goddamn hand up for 30 minutes. There needs
to be some variety on this panel. I'll tell you why. It's because
you were playing footsie and when they came to the next [__]
day. What do you mean you're playing footsy? >> Let him
explain. Let him answer. >> No, he's not expl He He already
went on to the next day. Wick, you [__]
He wasn't answering. He wasn't saying what he means by playing
footsie. He was just saying something vague and then moving on.
All right. So when we were talking about how oh everybody's being
so mean to hutch the next day and all that then you're like oh
well you know we technically challenged them on their perspectives
and all that kind of but realistically anybody who watched it
tonally felt like it was like a five and a half versus one against
you guys sound you guys sound like the biggest woke scolds tonally
what are you talking about the [__] up you [__]
anytimes
you roll your eyes like a [__] girl
you're basically the same thing.
Okay. Okay. You did disagree with them, but you were your tone.
It sounded like you were nice in your tone. Like it sounds like
you're It sounds like you're the youthful
social. That's what it sounds like. Like Steven is dude. Dude,
how can you open yourself to the chicken waffles or Lauren Southern
responses? Pull the Lauren Southern card, Pisco. Pull it now.
I'm I'm communicating to Pisco through time and space. We're
actually behind on this, but I'm going back in time. Pisco, bring
up Lauren Southern. Bring up how. Despite not disavowing any
of her white nationalist past at all, Destiny continued to platform
her and never question her aggressively about it. Des Pisco,
please Pisco, I'm I'm channeling this to you. Bring up his close
relationship with Lauren Southern. How has later revealed that
they're in a romantic relationship the entire time and calls
into questions any reason anybody should trust him on anything.
>> Nice in his tone with Myron Gaines. He is he absolutely
>> has Has has Dessi not tried to use that exact argument
against me? Even though my relationship didn't overlap with any
of my advocacy, his advocacy over overlapped perfectly with his
relationship. Oh, weird how that happens, right? But it didn't
bother him. Didn't change his political opinions at all.
>> Contention and he still clarifies the ideology. I still
have a point 40 minutes ago that I wanted to make. >> I've
had my hand up for 40 minutes. >> Counter your Go ahead.
>> Yeah. Thank you. Okay. Anyways, my turn. >> Guys,
you weren't really mean to them. Counter points. Aren't you really
good friends with both Destiny and Lauren Southern? Would you
say that Destiny was approximately mean with her given the difference
in their beliefs? Do you think he was appropriately like chastising
of her when she would come on stream? Do you believe that Connor?
>> Thank you. Thank you for coming to the Peace Go Destiny
show. All right. So earlier Econo Boy made a point saying that
I kept appealing to conspiracy and he's made this point three
or four times. So I want to address this >> Please do.
>> Now Paul Pot, Joseph St, Stalin, Tito, Castro, every
leader in the [__] union came together through revolution.
Okay. They all we get too and not just that but Gshi was arguing
about why leftists aren't relevant for western societies because
they have strong social order and Marcuse and modern lefty philosophers
tried to normalize Granch and Marusian argument in order to infiltrate
western societies in order to make them more socialist. Corbin
Sanders and Nchonsky all swept for authoritarian socialist regimes
when they were in power and only disavowed them once it was found
out all of their authoritarian abuses of their populations. So
when you say Hunter, you're being a conspiracist, I say no. Plenty
of youthful western lefty idiots. You >> wait, where where
in the west was was where in the west has socialism ever as an
authoritarian force actually risen and taking a hold? >> The
playbook that Grand
Western society of conspiracism when conspiracy is documentable
in the words of people who
you listening. Let's say you've been listening to what I've been
saying. Um what do you think I would say in response to that?
uh that you're not like them, that there are plenty of democratic
socialists who are actually nice, whose primary motivations are
democracy over socialism. They're incrementalists.
And so, as a result, they're not interested in sweeping for the
human rights abuses of these authoritarian regimes. >> Germany
National Socialist Party. Hitler, do you believe the National
Socialist Party actually embodied any of the values of socialism
by their own words? Do you believe that? >> And they're
not conspiracy? >> No. Okay. All right.ist. they actually
just think that this is the correct ideological outcome. So if
you understand that that is true and that that is at the very
least my point then we've already admitted we've already said
we've openly said multiple times that certainly there are a portion
of socialists historically and a portion of socialists that live
in America that do have these kind of like ulterior motives right
the thing that I've said is is well two things I've said number
one that historically that is not the great majority of socialist
movements that there's a at the very least a large >> okay
I just want to point out guys I'm not I'm not Sure. What? Dude,
Destiny hasn't had a chance to speak and like not take a position
on something in like 10 minutes. Can we get back to Destiny so
he can tell me how he doesn't know that he doesn't know for sure
that he's not sure what that means? Can you define that word?
Actually, I don't know. I don't know. Oh my god. Between >> I
just want to get back to Destiny like having no spine. Isn't
that why we're here? Isn't that what we're all here to >> Those
two different, you know, methods you could say of socialism.
And in America, I don't think that even close to the great majority.
I don't think even 80, I don't think even 80%, not even 90%,
probably. I mean, perhaps it could be that way. >> 99%
of the 10% of people that vote for Democrats that call themselves
socialists, they don't engage in that. So, I don't want to make
very
show. Okay. One more point. >> There's never been a successful
Democratic Socialist Movement. Uh, can you go Google the New
Democratic Party in Canada and tell me that there's not a successful
Democratic Socialist
>> Go ahead. before we get back to the piece and then we
can get >> didn't didn't seize national power but abs absolutely
seized provincial power to pass tons of reforms that were that
are universally like still hailed as as very very successful
>> back to the piece of I agree >> okay so if I told
you that I was a democratic fascist and I believed in uh political
corporatism and flexible authoritarianism but I don't agree with
the mass slaughters and as a matter of fact I'm like a human
fascist I don't want to do ethnic divides and I don't want to
do uh >> if you could explain down to the nuts and bolts
all of the things you believe Connor then yes I would say that's
valid if you if you could make it make sense like a Connor boy
does like he spent his entire career in educa or in uh research
or whatever the he did to get his like I think he's got a PhD
in economics right if you'd spent your entire life working on
that Jack Leighton wasn't an insane person though Jack Leighton
is not the founder of the new democratic party and wasn't a part
of the provincial party either as far as I know like wasn't yeah
I don't know >> you know racial divides I actually want
human beings to be put into a political >> I'm not I'm
not referring to Jack Leighton I'm referring to the early new
democratic partyation,
a body, and I want flexibly authoritarian governments or whatever,
you would probably still call me a idiot because even though
democracy was my primary virtue, fascism is still a dog ideology.
Right. >> Question that I would ask you, the question that
I would ask you is, is there a robust history of people calling
>> uh extreme dad? I've literally explained why I'm annoyed
at this at this conversation and you're not paying >> Fascist
and then winning elections and then leaving after they lose elections
and you couldn't answer yes to that. You couldn't answer yes
to that. But I can absolutely answer that. the drama show. Okay,
last point. I think the reason why I think it's like a house
cat versus a lion. Okay, >> wait. Do you recognize what
I just said? >> psychologically studied. Hold on. House
cats have been psychologically studied that if they were capable
of eating their owners, they would. Okay. I think >> you're
just going to say socialist. I know your game. >> I think
that yes, I think that western socialists are house cats. They
cannot eat our faces, so they won't eat our faces. But I think
if they were the size of a jaguar, they would start eating our
faces. And with that yelling at Destiny, >> I want to give
it to >> trying to hear the criticism of of what we did
with the Vanguard. And it sounds like uh Connor, you identified
it and earlier in our conversation as well tonally that tonally
it was footsy. Is this your problem with what we did on the Vanguard,
Stephen? That's just it. >> Yeah. Yeah.
>> No, shut the up Connor. No, shut the up >> Well,
I think Yes. Yes. Stephen, go ahead, Stephen. >> I So totally
I like So I prepared more for the Hassan stuff than the than
the Vangar. I'm more familiar with his content. Like for instance,
when like you immediately and easily would eat the idea that
like I would prefer Hassan over Trump as president with a system
>> Can you He's not He's just not going to answer the question
at all. Can you You're You're just going to totally run from
that question. He knows that if he says no and undercuts Connor
that he doesn't have a real criticism of the Vanguard stuff,
right? Cuz that is the only criticism. And if he says yes, then
he gets hit with Nick Fuentes Chicken and Waffles and Lauren
Southern and he is totally decimated, right? So he is going to
once again refuse to actually take a position again. Ding, ding,
ding. Hit the counter again. There he is being a total spineless
loser with absolutely no constraints. Like that's >> You
can go to, but I just want to get clear on this. So, as you sit
here, do you have a problem? >> Totally. My impression
with the >> Yeah, he's an issue. >> My impression
my impression was that almost all of the push back there was
coming from Hutch. And I think that's why you guys thought about
it the next day is because Hutch felt like he was kind of on
an island there. And that while you guys did disagree with some
points like the student loan thing, um you were very quick to
make a whole bunch of what I would call insane concessions about
Biden, whether you're calling him Trumpian or whatever because
he gets mad at the attorney general um or whatever else. And
that seems weird to do almost minstal showish in front of a couple
of people who are literally hardcore like socialists who Democrats
constantly. That's surprising to me. >> You so you acknowledged
that we did disagree with them significantly on the Sun point.
You acknowledged that I said you can't believe Mansion. You acknowledge
I said that and I supported touch on that and you also acknowledge
the way that I supported the notion that Biden had great uh policies
and that they were downplaying um for example the inflation reduction
act and other measures. Correct. >> So I so I did vote.
>> You acknowledge that you acknowledge that you are giving
me exact quotes and what we're criticizing is the tone. You acknowledge
how pointless, right? >> Yeah. No no you didn't criticize
the tone, Destiny. You actually p pulled back and did not criticize
the tone. So you have a problem with the tone he took. Say I
say yes or no right now. Can you just confirm for me your your
concern is a tonal concern? Right. You destiny are the person
with a tonal concern right now. Right. >> So I'm just asking
so is your problem the tone of the disagreement and what we're
doing. >> The problem is that it seems like you guys share
a political project when I would argue that the socialist movement
in general and all the media figures >> So Pisco has now
been unfortunately this works very well on people. Destiny's
gone, oh, you're going to do the yes or no thing like an Pisco
should be doing the yes or no thing right now. This is why the
yes or no thing exists because spineless weasly losers like this,
like slippery losers like this, won't answer a question and won't
give the concession because he is about to drop the exact thing
that everybody knows is coming. So, Lawrence Southern or the
uh the Nick Fentes chicken and waffles thing, right? >> Included.
Do not cherry political project that while you obsess about building
bridges with them, all they do is on your candidates in exchange.
>> Where was the bridge building? What is the bridge building
is? be nice to. So you were building a bridge with Nick Fentes,
you were building a bridge with Lawrence Southern. >> You
never have a scenario with a Vanguard or any of these other people
like oh we should try to build bridges with more moderate temps.
It will never happen. Has
>> one of the problems is one of the problems the tone
is the tone one of the >> Well yes I
he said he said yes P. So really quick let me ask Destiny a question.
So um >> so now how do you justify that given your history
with Lawrence Southern and your history with Nick Fuentes? Would
you say
that the ideological disposition, >> by the way, I think
that tone policing on like, oh, you shouldn't be a nice person
to people while having disagreements. I think that's insane.
I think that's totally wrong. I've always thought that was totally
wrong. But Destiny is so spitebased that he's willing to take
his history of doing that and arguing for that exact point and
throw it in the trash because Pisco bad. Piscoll is very bad
>> of someone like Joe Mansion versus the ideological disposition
of a guy like Joe Biden. Would you say that they share a political
project? >> Yes.
Okay. So I would say that >> Wait, you're doing this thing
again? Huh? Actually, I'm not even going to allow this. I'm sorry.
You keep doing this thing where you jump to elected lawmakers
that are working in the
>> Is AOC not a media figure? Does AOC not do constant
media appearances? Is AOC not the a media darling for the Democratic
party? Are we really going to pretend that AOC is not a media
figure in any way? Because I think you'd have to be insane to
make that claim. I don't think you could make that claim with
a straight face that she is not somebody with a media profile
that actually overlaps many true media figures.
No, they're not. No, no, no. They're not. >> They're literally
elected representatives. Destiny, what the [__] >> They're
not representatives of Stop. They've won an election in a particular
district. That's it. Do you are you gonna I'm sorry, hold on.
Are you gonna go to West Virginia to figure out who the who the
movement leader is of anybody on the left wing? Answer that question.
Are you gonna go to West Virginia to figure out who is the leader
of any kind of left >> rip? What what is making Desi change
his position on this? Like overall the position that you can
go on and by the way Pisco's position is you can go on and argue
with them, right? But you don't have to basically like scream
at them. What do you think's changed Essie's position on this?
Is it the fact that Lauren Southern dumped him? Cuz that seems
to be the thing that actually changed. That was right at the
time he changed was he got dumped by the conservative he was
actually courting and trying to build a bridge with and now she
dumped him and oh, I'm going to actually lose my mind. Find me
a more approximate cause and I'll I'll take that leftwing movement.
>> That's not what I'm doing, Destiny. >> Then why
would you say that Mansion represents some like leader of some
movement? They won election. I'm not talking about politicians.
The Vanguard and our politician. I'm talking about the media
environment. That's what I'm talking about. >> Would you
I'm just Destiny. I'm just using them as an example. Would you
say I'm telling you why. >> Are you saying Destiny did
not do a debate with Nick Fuentes
after this position was changed? That he said he wouldn't he
wouldn't let them be on his platform? He wouldn't he wouldn't
be a part of stuff with them, right? Believe he's done seas has
he not done several? >> I don't like the example. I don't
like the example because he's elected official, not people in
the media. >> Okay. Well,
you you you referenced one of the Hold on. I I think I can also
>> Sorry, I forgot this part with Rhox. Um he cut off Dick
because of the Mr. Jo stuff like entirely, >> right? one
of the the problem. >> No, there is no gap. >> He
was still he was still banning people who were making his argument
right now. He was still banning those people from his subreddit
as he cut Nick off >> at the bridge. He can't find an example
in the media. And that's my issue. That's the exact problem.
>> Okay. Okay. Well, look, how about this? How about this?
How about we just stop if that's the case? We've already said
this several times, okay, that in so far as people in the media
don't share this political project as you've described, oh, they're
actually, you know, to Connor's point, they're just hiding their
power level and they're actually authoritarian socialists or
whatever. We've already agreed several times that that's the
that's the extent to which they shouldn't be involved in like
the strategic or like you know like whatever like in like deep
involvement within the movement means. We've already agreed with
that several times. So how about this? Well, we can maybe if
there's another question you can ask because we've we've actually
already agreed on that topic. Is there any question the strange
thing the question the strange thing is so like for instance
right I think that strictly definitionally I might be considered
a eugenicist because I'm okay with people getting tested to see
if their child might have Down syndrome right and not having
those children right technically speaking that's a form of eugenics
but realistically would I go out and call myself a eugenicist
probably not right so it's just strange that when you're working
in a media environment and then you take on the label of socialist
if you were to look up any other and all other socialist content
that's being created in that sphere All of it is dedicated to
on the Democratic party. That's
only gotten it's only gotten worse in the past eight >> Shouldn't
we promote economy? Shouldn't we promote economy? Economy. You're
saying like where is a socialist figure? A socialist figure who
uh respects him. >> Wait, wait, wait.
>> That's basic argument here is I know economics better
than the economics PhD who spent his entire life trying to build
these positions of like democratic socialism in his head, right?
I know more than him. When he declassifies himself as a socialist,
he's actually like somebody who wants, you know, Down syndrome
tested out of the general population. He's actually the a socialist
in the same way that that person's a eugenicist. There's a totally
obviously disingenuous comparison. That makes no sense, right?
That's what he just argued. So he knows more about socialism
than the economics PhD, the guy who's actually spent his like
basically entire adult life trying to figure out how to make
these positions mesh because he wants the benefits of socialism
without the authoritarian overreach and without the violence.
Right. But Destiny has decided I know more than you and here's
a comparison. And yeah, don't try to explain it to me. So, shouldn't
we therefore if we're looking for these kinds of figures to to
take some of that energy perhaps or to use the label and get
it back to like the roots that um that economy is referencing
at least in specific traditions referencing, you know, the Labor
Party in in UK and Austral.
>> Yeah. So, like so, so on that front, why would I kick
Economy off? Why wouldn't I promote Econ Boy? Well, uh, >> because
because that label because that label has already been co-opted
by by all not co-opted, more accurately represented. But then
I guess this also goes back to definition or issue, right? Like
if you if you put um if you put AOC and Han in a room and you
give a bunch of people who know what socialism is and they're
red on theory, 100 out of a hundred of those people are going
to say Hassan is more of a socialist than AOC. If you put 100
people right on theory and you say, do you think AOC is more
of a capitalist liberal or more of like a socialist? Okay. So,
all we have to say here is what positions does Hassan criticize
AOC on, right, versus her actual platform? Because what I've
seen is basically possibly like some Israel stuff, but otherwise
he's almost always totally in line with her, right? What political
positions does Hassan not? Because Desi's point isn't what like
Hassan says. It's when he Hassan says, "I hide my positions."
That's where the point is, right? That we don't believe what
Hassan says, right? We believe we actually believe that he's
hiding his power level. It's not. So Hassan doesn't criticize
AOC. Hassan overlaps on what he supports almost entirely with
AOC. >> almost all of them.
Find me all of Hassan's criticisms of AOC. I want to see all
of them. I want to see all of them. Every single one. Let's let's
check them out and see what he disagrees with her on. >> Square
square this for me. Square this for me. So you said earlier that
okay, it's not necessarily about the socialist label and you
agree that there's a diversity in what that actually means. It's
about socialists within the media space. But then mentions, well,
what if like just for what if what if AOC retires from Congress
and starts an MSNBC show? Like it sounds like you would be against
that, but it's but then you say, "No, well, no, because she labels
herself as a socialist. I would be against it." But now it seems
like you're saying it's it actually is the >> No. Well,
no. There there's it's absolutely coherent. It seems like because
you're not familiar with any of the politics behind any of it.
the um it would be it would be challenging, but the issue that
you run into is so you could say could they wash the socialist
label and make it so that in your mind >> for the love
of God please somebody point out that econom boy is an actual
economist he has far more reading far more understanding of these
things and Destiny is totally saying I am I should be trusted
more than you Destiny is literally a co conspiracy theorist right
now right he's he's has somebody who's a PhD in this exact field
who's telling him what these things mean and what they mean to
him and Destiny's going no no you're wrong Actually, that's what
he's doing. Oh, whoops. I hit playing the wrong thing. >> Don't
say it again. I don't think that you are a secret tanky. I hope
you're not on the way to tank. I don't think you are. And I don't
think AOC is. Just from what I've seen, I don't think she's a
secret tanky or anything. Could she, you know, clean the socialist
label in a way that these people are more compatible with a liberal
form of government that's not like Vanguard or whatever? Maybe.
But then if I look at what's happened over the past decade when
people like AOC and Bernie Sanders have popularized the socialist
label, what actually happened? All of the people that worked
with them and then were spun off became insane radicals, right?
A lot of the people who are criticizing them now are other socialists
who are all saying they're sellouts. It seems seems like that
didn't work too well. >> So So AOC so if AOC started a
show uh media-wise, quit her job, started a show to promote her
ideas, would you have a problem with it? Yes or no?
>> Okay. So you don't have a problem inherently with with
someone having a socialist label and being a media figure, do
you? >> So why do you have this prescription? Oh, no. No,
I just made a whole point. God damn it. Sorry. As soon as you're
grounded to reality, Destiny just concedes right now. He's going
to pretend Oh, Pisco is being totally unreasonable.
Pisco is being totally unreasonable now, guys. Totally >> Can
I get a
This is all I know what you're doing. So, so why is your prescription
therefore if you don't have >> Can't do wise. I only >> So,
so Pisco doesn't understand that optically what you have to do
here is say the reason you don't like the yes or no tactic is
because you are a spineless who will not answer a question. You're
going to continue being a spineless who will not answer a question.
And that's why you have to mock me for saying yes or no because
you don't want to be held down to any position here because you
know you're wrong. You have to you have to totally totally bend
your spine to make any of this make sense. >> Yes or no.
>> That is why I'm
choice I could do. If it's the case that you wouldn't have a
problem with AOC if you start stopped being a politician, became
a media figure to start a show. Why then? So you don't have a
problem with in principle. Why would you have a prescription
that we should kick econom boy off the show because he's
even hold on. I have an important question. Stephen, I have an
important question and you need to answer it yes or no. >> Uh
do you think think that Nick Fuentes should be able to have a
TV show?
>> Nice cover for Nice cover for Stephen. >> That's
literally not the question here at all. You idiot. It's about
whether or not you should associate with them, you stupid. Actually,
okay. Okay. I need to stay within the lines of the toos. Connor
just said a whole Dude, I'm I'm sorry, but it's very clear the
homeless man just stood up and started off in the middle of the
train again. That is his only purpose here is to be a homeless
man who stands up and jerks off in the middle of the train, derails
anything happening. He has no valid points to make. He should
be kicked off. He is actually totally derailing for nothing.
What a [__] >> Do you think No, no, no. Do
you think that Nick Fentes should be able to have a TV show?
>> A free liberal country. >> These are actual questions.
These are >> Oh, yeah. No, but the reason why I'm asking
this question, Hold on. You can't understand where this is going.
No, no, no. I'll go ahead and explain it because you don't understand
where this is >> Wait, actually, wait, wait, wait. Can
I
go? You can go right after. This is a really important point.
Hold on. You can go right after. I swear. Okay. This is If you
would have asked me 10 years ago, should AOC run as a far-left
progressive and never use the word socialist? I would say yes.
And we would all be better off for it. That's what I would >> Not
the question. Not the question. Another question.
Hold on. Hold on. I do want to hear I do want to hear where is
going. >> Go ahead.
>> That again, that's not even remotely relevant to the
conversation we're having, but it's fine, dude. It's so performative.
And like this has to hit some people. Some people have to see
this, right? Like no matter how cultlike you are, some people
have to see this. I feel like I've always seen this. I've always
seen like when this disingenuous happens, no matter how cultlike
it ever >> Why? Wait, wait. Why do we make the question?
You guys are running. Hold on. Hold on. Stop.
No, he me. No. No. Come on. You know he me there. You know he
me there. You
stop. I'm making a point. >> He's like a white blood cell.
He's a white blood cell and he's trying to >> Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. He sees it. He sees it. Right. He's a Don't call
him a white blood cell. Oh, see another optical mistake here.
That is going to go Oh, oh, oh, no. He's like Mr. Girl. This
was like Mr. Girl now. This goes like Mr. Girl. That's what they're
going to do. And that's going to lose you like 40% of that totally
moronic cult, right? That's exactly what's going to happen. Is
it is entirely precisely what is happening here. It is a perfect
explanation of what is going on, but that won't matter to a lot
of those EGs. I'm saying, but realistically, I'm I'm holding
Pisco to a standard. You can't possibly do this, right? Pisco
wants to shed them. Yeah, it's probably best, right? Like realistically,
you don't want people who support this kind of thing anyway.
And it is 100% correct. I'm referring it to as the home to it
as the homeless man who stands up in the middle of the train.
Uh but you know what? It's more like a Mission Impossible version,
okay? Where like you need to distract somebody to steal something
from the briefcase. And so Connor is the homeless man who will
stand up and jerk off in the middle of the train. Okay. While
Destiny goes and steals something from somebody's briefcase while
he gets to make a point. That's actually what's happening. this
because you know I'm not like this is my >> Conor had a
legitimate point on the question whether or not a make a TV show
has no bearing on any other part of this conversation there was
a >> no it was if AOC starts a TV show should she still
be a member should she be kicked out of the coalition now because
she is a socialist and she has a TV show should she not be she's
now a media figure instead of a politician if we flip AOC from
politician to media figure is she now exised that is the point
Connor asked should Nicholas Fentes have a TV show as if anybody
Nobody was arguing that AOC shouldn't have a TV show when that
happens, right? As if anybody was arguing that. Nobody was arguing
that. Connor just made a totally worthless interjection. That
maybe he'll say, "Oh, well, this is why I wanted to ask that
question. Maybe he'll have a point after this." Right. But that's
a totally worthless interjection.
>> It's called having a Loki Koko, explain to me where
Pisco has been bad faith in this conversation.
Go ahead. Uh, it's a weak timeout if you can't give me a time
stamp in this debate for when you you can take 5 minutes, but
it'll be a week timeout if you can't give me a time stamp for
Pisco being bad faith in this conversation. Go
back. Hey, [__] Hey, >> it's called an internal
critique. It's called an internal critique.
>> You had a standard. You had a standard. >> He
knows what an internal What is an internal critique? I watched
Andrew Wilson explain to you what an internal critique was. You
said you knew what it was. This is this is actually really really really
funny. I watched the debate the January 6th debate with Andrew
Wilson. Andrew debate said, "I want to do internal critique."
Internal critique is this. And Jesse goes, "Oh, no. I I could
have sworn he went, "No, no, I know what an internal critique
is." But even if he didn't, Andrew Wilson explained it completely.
>> Wait. And everyone knows, "Holy, Connor, everyone knows
your your standard was I don't really have a problem using a
socialist label if you're a politician, but I do have a problem
with it with your media figure. So, I'm testing your logic. I'm
testing." >> Obviously, obviously that's what's happening.
You're taking from being a politician to being a media figure
who happens to also be the most popular leftwing person in the
United States of America. It's obviously not the >> Wait,
wouldn't are you are you are you appealing to popularity as if
that makes a difference? Uh I have I got bad news for you, Destiny.
You didn't lap Hassan. Han is still 10 times more popular than
you at minimum.
What are we talking about? What the is he talking about right
now? What is blood yapping about? Standard. You're going to the
outer perimeter of the outer perimeter of things. Why don't you
answer it and distinguish it? So why don't you answer instead
of meing out of it instead of out of it? >> Already did
answer. Do you forget the >> Did you get the answer? I
already said yes. If you want to do a show, I guess you could,
but I don't think she can use the label socialist. I think it's
harmful to the country. >> No, no, no. I'm not asking.
I'm not
>> There's not asking can she do a show, idiot. This I
already answered the question. No, you didn't. You didn't answer
the actual question. >> No, you're not asking because you're
>> the entire like we can all see exactly what's happening.
I I explained it before Pisco did. It is, hey, you're saying
that if somebody is a media figure, they have a different set
of responsibilities for interacting with the Democratic party
than a politician. They politician could say they're a socialist.
A media figure can't or a media figure doesn't because it always
means they have some more uh sincere socialist beliefs, right?
So, if AOC keeps the same positions, keeps the same like rhetoric
and defines herself the same and she becomes a media figure thereby
losing that I guess armor that political figures get, would you
still support her or or want her a part of the coalition? That's
the question. express it in the narrow yes or no questions to
go down your particular dialogue because you have no
this is why you have >> it's like it's actually just a
totally logical question to ask for checking Destiny's consistency
in any way and he knows that it makes him look bad right just
every time he knows one of these questions makes him look bad
he goes well maybe possibly uh I don't know can you define that
word right he doesn't take positions because he's been he's been
caught every single time he's done that I can go back and show
you how he's been caught precisely it's very easy to >> a
prescription that we should kick uh econ boy off the off the
show because he used the socialist label. That's your prescription.
You actually want >> That's the name of your show is live
and learn, not something, right? >> So So you you literally
want us to kick economy off because of the label. I'm trying
to test your internal consistent. >> By the way, I don't
even know if Destiny said that. I don't know. But he he thinks
it Destiny is so like discombobulated with what his actual principles
are. I don't even know if he advocated for a Connor boy to be
kicked off the show. I actually don't think he did that. But
he's now like he he's so lost in what he's actually arguing that
Pisco got took something that way and Destiny's just going, "Yeah,
I did. Yeah, I did." He did? Are you sure? I could have sworn
it was like he had another qualifier there of like they constantly
rail against the Democratic party. I could have sworn there was
another qualifier there and he didn't actually have to give that
up. But hey, >> and we're not here to test my entire internal
entity.
It's not preposterous. I asked you guys to leave. You can name
a single other socialist figure in media that supports an immigrant
party and can name even one person. You can't even name one person
and you're sitting here swinging out about whether I should be
appealing to the left. You can't even name one. >> I was
I I don't know why it took them so long. I literally the second
Destiny asked it, I just like zoomed in and waited and neither
of them said it right away. I don't understand how it took them
so long to say it actually. >> Hey, Connor boy. Econ boy.
>> Uh Joe. Joe. Joe. I assume I think Joe's into socialist
politics. But >> wait, is is he kind of boy example?
>> No, he's not lying. So we should >> I mean that
is that is what he's doing. Yeah, that is that is 100%. >> Kick
him out. >> Like he can joke about it. He can joke about
it all he wants. That is what he's literally doing. >> Holy
[__] >> So for just commerce we shouldn't enforce
the silly serious the silly serious Nemo. >> So if we look
at at uh what is it blonde philosophy politics or whatever her
channel she got like a million view video on Elon Musk right?
She is a socialist. She's a political commentator who's a socialist.
Supports the Democratic party. Obviously organized the Democratic
like the the what do you call it the interviews that Destiny
and Pisco were doing. She like set up that stage. She helped
them organize all of that. Right. Which I believe. So I'll I'll
get it from somebody else. But only is very much into her content
and says she's a socialist. So >> see, hold on. Do you
think that can have a positive influence in our media sphere
to push people? >> If you think if I could you mean logically
possible, then yes. >> Okay. Wait, hold on. Do you think
that there might be at least one person that could help the Democratic
party or help people get elected? By the way, I identify as right
now. Also, let's say, by the way, identify right now. Do you
think man? >> No, wait. I'm just asking. Hold on.
If I might be logically possible
by if I might be, if by might be, you mean logically possible.
The answer is yes, but let me just put it to you. >> Hey,
Destiny, let's go back to your Nick Fentes chicken waffles arc.
Uh, what part of which part of the negative labels of specifically
the anti-semitism? Which one do you think overlaps with the goals
of the Democratic party? Just curious. >> Just curious.
>> You right. So your standard was that right now we should
actually kick econom boy off of the podcast because he uses the
term socialist label. You wouldn't say the same for a politician.
You wouldn't say the same for a politician running for office.
And so you were given the example of a politician who stops being
a politician becomes a media figure. Should we treat them similarly?
So like if AOC said, "Hey, I want to be a part of Lib and Learn."
And what? What the [__] You can turn.
>> No, not your turn, homeless man. Sit the down, homeless
man. Wick, kick the homeless man out. Tell him to shut the
>> Dude, again, Pisco is trying to clarify. He's trying
to say, "This is obviously what we're doing here." And Connor
steps up, stands up, drops Trow, and starts humiliating himself
off in front of the entire train car. Why? Why have we let this
pattern occur multiple times in a row? Why do we continue to
allow this to occur? What is going on? >> I wait 10 minutes.
My >> You will wait as long as I want you to >> [__]
running.
>> you will wait as long as I want you. You know where
this is going. You know that's why they won't let me finish the
question. The question is if we kick out if you answer the question,
you can ask the question when I'm done. >> We we
answer live and learn, guys. Should we say no? >> Okay.
I No, hold on. before you guys go on another >> Conor's
going to go in a different direction again.
>> Dude, I I'm sorry. Uh I'm going to officially start
like hosting panels. I I think this is like what's going to make
me do it. I'm going to actually start trying to host panels on
these topics. Wick is like I I'm sorry. This is totally ruining
content completely. Conor's a complete This is so embarrassing.
The question, so I'm not white blood selling. So you can answer
the question. If AOC wants to join the show, should you say yes?
Okay, so write that down. So, so Pisco can't accuse me of white
blood selling. The point that I was making for those of you who
have ADIQ in the audience is that Steven, as far as I know, is
a liberal, meaning that he believes in freedom of conscience
and freedom of speech, meaning that socialists
I'm not done yet. I'm not done yet. Thank you. I'm not done yet.
Thank you. I love you. Shut up.
So if you ask Steven, hey, should a socialist be able to create
a TV show? 99% of the time he's going to say yes. The same way
that I presume with Fuentes, even though he's an evil, nefarious
Christian national
talking about the right to make a show. No one's talking about
your legal. >> Connor is discombobulated. Connor is a total
and like this is actually this should I'm not even joking like
I'm actually from watching this I'm actually kind of at the point
where I'm like oh I I I now have legitimate question about Connor's
engagement anywhere. Um like I actually have like I don't know
if he should be allowed on these panels because of how he's taken
money to go to advocate against his own beliefs. I don't know
if I if I feel like I could rely on Connor to have a sincere
belief on anything anymore. This is so embarrassing. This is
like so disingenuous, so stupid. I I have serious doubts about
like like it's it's honestly I don't know where I could find
a better example where I would think of somebody like being paid
to just take a dive. Like this is this is sad.
>> And I realize I realize like how serious that that like
allegation kind of is. Dude, this is this is beyond like like
it's actually he would have to be totally mentally impaired
to to think that this was a valid line of questioning, right?
Like like going back and walking through this, he would have
to be totally mentally impaired. Like he if he was drunk right
now, completely drunk, maybe. But but I just don't I don't understand.
Like I don't I've never found Connor to be somebody who can't
like he reads fairly complex theory. He does engage in good faith
most of the time. I've never seen him be this like bad faith,
this incapable of engaging with the actual point. I'm sorry,
but like I've seen him be way smarter than this a lot. So I don't
understand where this is coming from. You guys are all talking
past each other.
[__] idiot. This is frustrating. This is frustrating.
>> This is very frustrating.
I just have to ask a question. I just have to ask a question.
Peace. Do you think that there is any utility in gatekeeping
a label? >> Yeah, sometimes it can. >> Yes. So, if
you want to gatekeep
Democrat or liberal as a label, do you think that it it makes
sense to say, "Hey, we can have a show. We could have you on
it, but if we're going to call ourselves liberals, you can't
be on it because we only accept liberals."
>> That could be for the purposes. Wait, wait, no. That's
a That's a different question. So the answer is if the show is
called Live and Learn, I don't have a problem I don't have a
problem in uh theory with you um having a non-liberal be part
of the show live and learn if that that has to do more with like
I don't know your artistic consistency or your title being consistent
or something. But the question is fundamentally different. The
question is would it be your preference to kick off people who
have that label? Not would we want them to change the label.
That's not the question. The question is should we even let them
when by let I don't hear of course to Connor's preposterous straw
man mean that like legally take away their right to have legally.
>> Yeah. So he's like >> answer the question that
way he can't accuse me of being a white blood cell because he
wouldn't have any evidence for it anyways. Answer his gay little
>> So no one here is talking. First of all I like the heteronormative
language. I think it's it's really distressing. Uh >> I
love heteronormativity. >> I don't like the heteronormative
language. It's distressing. Um but just be by the way the misogynist
language.
You are a [__] >> By the way, you guys are
so out about tone. So, you were the last people. But just to
get a fine point on it. The >> tone is in so far as tone
to a certain person. We wouldn't be complaining if you had a
bad tone towards somebody that was your ideological. >> You
have a good tone. You had a nice tone in my
>> Say Lauren Southern. >> I was defending Conor's
arguments here. >> I'm paying up for my bad take. >> Oh,
thank you. Second. I appreciate it. Say don't do Lauren Southern.
Actually poke him with that. Do Lauren Southern. Don't do Nick
Fuentes. Do Lauren Southern. Don't do Nick Fentes. Do Lauren
Southern. Do Lauren Southern. Do Lauren Southern. Oh, hold on.
Hold on. Hold on. I need to go back. >> A bad tone towards
somebody that was your ideological.
>> This is I'm sorry, but yes, this is like this is what
we were talking about. Okay. Pisco is he is not he's not the
uncaged
rabid Peruvian mountain gorilla yet. Okay. And as soon as he
understands what holding back costs, he will become the unhinged
Peruvian mountain gorilla. Okay? Which is, by the way, he should
still he should still make the points. No, no, no. Peanobub,
I'm not saying he should go and like talk about any of Destiny's
weird leaks or anything, but he should make the point. Hey, what
was your tone like with the person you were in love with and
lying about your audience to or lying about to your audience?
What was the your tone with a vowed like anti-semite?
What when you went for ice cream with him with you, you and your
wife? What was it then?
>> You had a nice
Did you agree that you had a nice tone with Iron G? Nobody will
come out of that conversation.
Nobody will come out of that conversation. Tone is more than
just your like actual >> Pisco doesn't want to go to the
classics, right? Pisco doesn't want to go to the classics, but
the classic should be Fuentes and the classics should be Lauren
Southern. And the reason is nobody would watch him go for ice
cream with Nick Fuentes and do an IRL, right, where they go for
chicken waffles and then ice cream after and go, "Oh, this is
like these are two people totally politically disengaged from
each other, right? I don't think that's a problem. But he's now
specifying it as a problem. He argued at the time it wasn't a
problem.
>> Were you? >> How many Hold on. How many people
would come out of that conversation thinking, "Wow, Destiny and
Myron seem to agree on quite a bit." >> And how many people
would come out of my conversation think Well, sorry.
You got yourself.
>> No, people in good faith don't think Pisco agrees, right?
It's it's literally all Destiny framing. And this is the issue
is like he's basically created he like sets the media environment
in this like Twitch politics ecosphere or ecosystem, right? in
this whole thing. He sets like the media environment for people.
He gets to say like what's right and wrong and it's fading. They're
going to lose all of this, right? They're going to lose all of
this. But Pisco, okay, Pisco is realizing that like, oh, actually,
it's just a totally bad faith criticism from Destiny that makes
people disagree with me. Oh, I actually I don't know. Like, I
have to like point this out. I'm going to have to do something.
It's Destiny just gets to say, oh, well, I said it and other
people agreed with me. It's like, yeah, your entire your entire
cult agrees with you. True, true, true, true. >> Andrew
just tipped $5. >> I paid Pisco to never bring up my
>> Okay,
okay, dude. Chill, chill, chill.
Um, thank you very much for the five though. Didn't Destiny yell
at Nick F because he should be thankful for bringing his career
back? I'm like your only bridge to other creators. What are you
doing? I'm like the only person who will talk to you right now.
I'm like the only person who gives you any networking opportunities
at all. Why are you Why would you do this? Why would you report
one of my friends? cuz I'm the only person who helps you. Cool.
Wait, wait,
Oh my god. Okay, >> dude. This is This is just sad. It's
just sad. It's just sad. He thinks the the spuring is like effective,
right? I will say Pisco's like, "Oh, who who?" But he should
have said, "Who in good faith like thinks that, right?" Like
they understand I had a bunch of substantive disagreements. Destiny,
you yourself agreed in this debate. In this exact debate, Destiny,
you agreed that I disagreed with them on multiple points, right?
that I was totally antagonistic towards the points where where
I actually disagreed. Yes, when they said things I agree with,
I would agree with them, but I was totally antagonistic for the
points where I disagreed. You you already said that
on broadcasting live exposed. >> So, no, no, I'm not backing
off. >> He thinks he thinks he cooked here. He thinks he
cooked here. He thinks he cooked here. He thinks he cooked. Yeah.
This is why like being like like Destiny is so
unbearable in debates like this, right? And I I'll point it out
and as long as you remain calm, it's fine, right? Uh the person
I've seen most effective against this these kinds of tactics
is that black dude from Tik Tok. What was that guy's name? The
guy who debated with Natsuite and was just slowly like stalking
her down on points. You need to be in like a 1v one environment
or else it gets derailed. But that guy who's like very calmly
just pointing out like the the inconsistencies.
Jordan. It wasn't Jordan. No, no, no, no, no. That wasn't the
name. What was that guy's name? Someone's got it. I know somebody
I know a lot of people watch those Tik Tok debates, but that
guy that's what you do, right? You just slowly stalk them down
on the points and what they're saying. Like Destiny is saying,
"Oh, I totally got you." And it's like, "No, Destiny, like you're
Jaden." Jaden was the name. Yes. Thank you, Crab Navy. Jaden.
Yes. >> And end position. So, I'm saying if you watch the
actual stream and listen to the words being said said, then no
one would come away from that thing that we didn't combat them.
If they watch the Destiny stream, if they watch the Destiny stream
where you're hearing us,
okay, so so here's the thing. Wick says, "Oh, I watched the stream.
I don't think you push back very well." Okay, Wick, give me a
position where you think I held back or hid my beliefs or did
something to signal to them. Okay, go ahead, Wick. Make your
criticism.
Right, that's Pisco has been out here for like a week begging
for anybody to make this point. Hey, I disagreed with them on
these points. Where do you think I was like too nice to them,
too kind to them, didn't disagree with them? Right? So, Wick
has his opportunity right now. Wick, you've got your opportunity.
Don't spill your spaghetti. You have to have an example of this,
right? You can't just go, "Well, I kind of felt this way a little
bit." Because that would be moronic. You would never cut in to
this heated debate and say, "Well, I kind of disagree with you
on that." with no examples, right? That would be embarrassing.
I would I would think far less of you as a political advocate,
as a political influencer, as a panel uh host. Okay? If you did
this, if you cut in with no example, no precise example right
now, that would be embarrassing. I would not advocate for anybody
to watch you as somebody to take seriously in politics. Wait,
so if if you watch the Destiny stream where he's throwing you
down every two seconds and if if you watch the Destiny stream
where then maybe you get that impression, but if you wait I'm
curious. Wait, if you look at the chats, do you think there were
more people in my chat who are favorable to my in our conversation
or more people in your chat that were favorable to
>> That's not the answer. That's not the >> Wait,
why would that be an effective analysis? This guy thinks he cooked
again. Why would people in your chat like Myron Gaines other
than a propensity to ignore women's consent? Why would they What
What other thing do they overlap with Myron Gaines on, idiot?
Yeah, of course. Vanguard and Lib and Learn. Of course. Uh, of
course there'd be way more overlap there. They're They're like
apart from each other, but they're on the same side of the political
sphere, right? I totally I totally disavow I totally disavow
this comment. It's very gross, very disgusting. Okay, he just
said something that was obviously true and means nothing. And
he did this face, right? He did this face as if like he cooked.
I totally cooked here. I totally did something here
at all. The question is that question
were you being did you have a nice answer the question. Do you
have a nice tone with Myron? Yes or no? >> The point of
tone is what did you have a nice tone yes or no audience? Did
you have a nice message? Did you have a nice tone? Did you have
a nice tone? Yes or no? Did you have a nice
audience with will eventually move on because I guarantee Wick
will penalize him for this. Right. Wick. Wick will absolutely
not. Wick Wick sees which way the winds are flowing. Which way
the winds are blowing rather. He will not penalize Pisco for
this at all or sorry he will not penalize Desi for this at all.
The total refusal. Desi has not actually taken a position on
anything. He's refused to make any moral statements on anything
this entire time. Right. He's totally run for Pisco. Wick has
done nothing to enforce this. And this will basically go Pisco
Pisco. No, no, no. Let Destiny talk. >> That means that
I'm doing my job. My appropriate I would not have the same tone
if my audience was in the background probably
you really want to do this unfortunately. I wonder what his audience
thought when piss when when my was like Pixie is a total she's
a gold dam. I wonder what his audience thought >> A little
bit harder than yes or no. So you keep asking the same question
over and over again. But it's not really
in your chat. You see a ton of people spamming Democrats Democrats
Democrats over and over again. You don't see the
>> This is why you should actually go and and start legitimately
just totally trashing him, right? Like this is why this is why
you shouldn't stay away from the Lord and Southern example. So
why you shouldn't say stay away from his crimes is because he
is not a serious person and he is now being totally bad faith
with you and unless you make comments about how he's bad faith
exactly which ways he's morally bankrupt it's like it's actually
a difficult conversation cuz he's just very good at continuing
to spur
the entire time somebody else is talking
so so my chat does not spam that at all
my chat does not spam that at all the question is like for you
to be accusing anybody and tone policeing anybody. Oh, in your
conversation, you seemed too nice in your disagreement is laughable
and everybody knows it because you've had nice conversations.
>> Only laughable if your understanding of tone is that
of a
thing
and shills. >> And it's so crazy that my >> He doesn't
want to he doesn't want to do it. He does. Pisco is not strong
enough yet. Okay, he's not strong enough yet, but we're getting
there. Okay, this is like uh this is like Frieza versus Goku.
Okay, all all Destiny has to do is take a shot at one of Pisco's
friends. Okay, that's what that's what's going to push Pisco
over the line. Okay, he needs to cut Krillin in half right now.
We need to see Krillin get cut in half. Okay, that's what we
need. And Pisco is going to snap and he's going to actually go
he's going to actually go gorilla mode. Okay, it'll happen. >> By
and large, 99% of them reject it. But your audience is halfway
down the
>> Halfway down the ML pipeline. >> You say that.
You say that, but my audience my those videos where where I'm
pushing back are disliked. My audience is not close to the Marxist
>> because I'm watching them. Yeah, you >> dude.
Really? Uh yeah, your videos are disliked cuz I'm watching and
pointing out how disingenuous you are. >> But I won't I
won't actually engage with anything you say. I won't agree. I
won't make any concessions on my points. I won't actually take
any positions. But you're the one who's bad faith,
>> dude.
You just going to admit it the most. It's going to be people
that are watching Destiny watching it. Yeah. No, >> my
own audience. My own audience.
pushing back at all at all on so you're so so my my did push
back. We definitely objectively did push back and you're not
contending with the fact that you Steven Bennell you are a massive
hypocrite if you're going to come to us and say we need to watch
our tone when we vocally disagree and by the way you take it
completely out of context that we need to watch our tone but
you're fine you're fine doing all the jokes you want in other
context you say get soy you think it's soy people call you out
for tone police and that kind of [__] but now with
us you're going to nitpick and say oh did you really
communicate to the audience [__] believe me. >> Your
argument is $3. You always talk about Frieza versus Goku. No
one watches Naruto, bro. >> Nice try, bro. Nice try. >> You
go to my audience. They're not. They're not all supporting my
games. Your audience is like, who the knows if they're socialists
or not? Half of them are, right? Like what there? Hold on. There
are Wait, Destiny just said the videos are just like cuz I watch
them. Uh the people who are socialist in Pisco's audience aren't
coming from Pisco. Those are coming from like other creators.
They'd be people who watch like uh like unaronically probably
Queman right me like there are people who are absolutely like
leftist pretty far leftist maybe even socialist in my audience
and I watch these videos too those would be people coming from
this place but my audience isn't particularly like uh isn't primarily
political I do drama content first right so I have a lot of people
who are leftists from YouTube who come and hang out here Sunday
fans via straight raid I would say like like uh who do we have
here I'm trying to look there's definitely this guy the the verain
toty That guy is definitely socialist.
There's a couple other people, but a lot of those people would
be um would be people who just overlap. But that doesn't mean
Pisco's content is is socialist, right? >> Have you seen
the LNOD comments? No. >> Like a >> Oh, Matt Matt
NLT is a socialist. Like I think there are people who broadly
have like socialist leanings, right? I'm a leftist drama perf.
Like there there'd be people who have socialist leanings here.
I don't think that's like I don't think that means anything.
Yeah. I don't think that means anything
like this. >> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So, so wait, my co-host
is Marcus Lenist >> for Aaron is an ML. Yes. That's like
where your audience is going. Yes. >> You you understand
that Aaron says she's not a Marxist Londonist. Do you agree with
that? That she's >> I don't identify people. You you know
that Trump doesn't call himself a fascist, right? >> Yeah.
So, so what's your evidence? What's your evidence that she's
a Marxist Leninist? Go up >> ask her about a political
police. >> No, no, no. You you made an assertion, didn't
you? Did you make >> because she would support the violent
>> Okay. Okay. Okay. So straighter is a Marxist Leninist
because she would >> of the capital class and would say
>> orchestrate the violent overthrow of the capital class
to bring about the social revolution evidence of that. What is
>> okay? Uh yeah I guess like I have no idea on straight
raids like truly held like oh we need violent revolution now
beliefs. I don't know what those are. So hopefully we'll see
some evidence here of those beliefs. I would say I wouldn't take
a an equivalent to Hassan's like let the let the streets run
red with their blood with the blood of the landlords. I wouldn't
take like memes like that quite so seriously, right? I think
um unfortunately for a lot of people who like meme pretty hard,
Trey Raid who's pretty dry in her in her jokes, I would expect
her to do like these people got to die or some I would expect
that kind of thing to be brought up for better or worse.
>> What did she say? What did she say? What did she say?
>> The [__] vod.
>> Do I want you to have Do I want you to have evidence
for your beliefs as you spur the [__] out? Oh my
god, it's actual fat. Dude, this is going to be Ri's going to
love this for fat destiny. This is actual fat destiny right here.
Ry is going to love this one. As you spur the out uncontrollably
and just make random wild assertions, right? Like that you can't
back up. You've been doing this a lot lately. You've just been
making random wild assertions that can't be backed up that you
don't have evidence for. Yeah, I'm going to ask you for evidence.
Has Arerodite provided evidence, by the way? Hold on. When I
go to when I go to Twitter, did I get did I get a response from
Arrodite here? I hope I got a response from Merida here. Oh,
actually, hold on. I can't I can't actually check with this tab.
Give me a second. Did I get a response to like, "Hey, would you
mind um maybe like not, you know, totally throwing your weight
behind this uh behind this baseless conspiracy Destiny starting
or?" No, I don't have a response from Arodite yet. Nope. Don't
have a response. Hold on. Let me see. Not so Aerodite. I I would
really hope she did something other than just maybe like block
me or some No, I can still Yeah, she just hasn't responded. I
would just, you know, I'd love people to stop making baseless
allegations. That's all. >> [__] tell me what
you said about
stop [__] What did you go? >> I'm like communicate.
I feel like I'm I'm like sending messages to Pisco in the future
right now. Like this is tech or in the past. I feel like he's
he's hearing me and he's like he's getting it. He's getting it.
He's getting it. >> Let me let me let me do a little translating
here. Um I would like an example uh from Destiny. Destiny,
what specific uh position or uh take that straighter has had
that you feel uh by the way this is once again guys I've made
an allegation that I have no proof of at all. Guys, please find
the clip. Guys, can you please find a clip? Guys, guys, guys,
can you please find a clip for me? Guys, chat, now chat, do it
now. I need a clip. >> Leads you to believe that she's
a Marxist Lenist. But in the past when you used to hop on stream
and like argue and [__] her position is generally
that of like a revolutionary socialist. That's one position.
>> Quote it just quote what you literally give the position.
Yeah. >> She would support the violent overthrow of the
capital class. She probably thinks the only >> she said
she came on your stream and said, "I would vi I would I would
support the violent overthrow of the capital class." Is that
what she said? Why don't you I don't even need like a specific
quote. Could you just tell me what position she took? So she
came on your stream and said, "No, no, no. Actually,
we need right now the thing America most needs is to violently
overthrow the capital class, which by the way, she might believe.
I just haven't seen it, right? I would wonder why he's making
this assertion when he doesn't necessarily know. No, I I could
imagine her saying it. I could imagine her saying it tongue and
cheek, right? Like straight seems like somebody who has those
aesthetics, who would make those comments tongue-in-cheek, I
think. Right. I think she would make those comments tongue and
cheek. I would need to see the context of those comments, right?
Like if she if there's a joking environment and she just like
leans into that, I would have to see what that looks like. >> The
evidence for that, that's conclusory. What's the evidence? You
say probably what name one position. >> You think I just
>> Now, here's the other thing about Pisco. Pisco is very
very principled
and he's being he's being baited. I And it sucks. Okay. I see
him being baited. He has a he has a co-host who memes a lot,
who would joke a lot or joke around a lot, right? And he's going
he knows he would never make those jokes, right? and he's saying,
"Show me any evidence of this." Right? Show me any evidence of
this. And it's like, "Bro, I think I think Aaron would totally
lean into that in a totally dry fashion where
where like I I think he would look bad if a clip came up." So,
I would just I would be careful of this kind of stuff. I know
exactly what he means. Like, would Aaron actually people? Is
the person who is my friend actually supporting the of like politicians
and capitalists, right? No, he has to do this. I understand why
he has to do it and lean into it. I'm just saying that like he's
on a he's on like a he's playing on like ultra difficulty. Okay,
Destiny is being bad faith. If he's going to sling accusations,
show proof. I think Pisco should be should be actually putting
the screws to him on proof for his own conduct that he knows
full well. Right. I agree with you that Destiny has to show proof
of the conduct he alleges. I'm saying that like he's he's now
putting it on somebody else who he doesn't know the full history
of who he could easily like, you know, fall behind. Ah, the Philly
donation. Imagine being the fan of a consent violator. Yeah.
Yeah. True, true, true, true, true, true, true, true, true. So,
I'm just saying that like I think I think probably there's a
decent chance that Aaron would say something like this. Not in
like a serious sense, but something that could be like construed
that way. So, I just I wouldn't risk >> going to bring
about the the revolution requires a violent overthrow of the
capital class. And you're saying that has made that position
that that's her position is that she has said that the the or
maybe in a years ago [__] Democrats she canvased
for uh uh what is this progressive
dumb ass? >> That's actually a fantastic point, Destiny.
She's been on your stream a whole bunch. What changed about her
beliefs? What did she say about her beliefs that changed your
opinion of her beliefs such that you can no longer canvas with
her? Such that you can no longer have her as an ally? What has
changed about her beliefs? Exactly. Destiny, can you help? Can
you help me know what the difference is here? It seems like the
difference is uh her and Lyken are kind of like, "Yeah, this
guy, he's kind of a loser." Like that's that's the difference,
right? Is a personal beef. The same thing with Pisco. It's just
a personal beef.
>> You have nothing. You have nothing. >> Pisco Pisco.
You understand that just because
Democrats does not mean that she does not hold that position.
>> So So here's my evidence that she's not a Marxist Linist.
I asked her, "Do you are you Mark Slenn? Do you uphold it?" >> Yeah,
exactly. What changed is her opinion of him. That is what changed
about straight raid, right? That's what has changed about Straight
is she now thinks Destiny's like a weirdo consent violator. That's
that's what's changed, right? Maybe even beyond that. I would
say probably she could have maybe let that go. Maybe she could
have been like, you know what, everybody makes mistakes. I've
like probably shared something I shouldn't have shared or something.
And but then it comes out that there's this massive pattern.
And then you see how he treats the people who he's done this
to, right? People who are objectively victims. And then you go,
"Oh, actually this guy's a total piece of he's actually a complete
piece of Oh, I didn't realize what a piece of he was." >> So
So here's my evidence that she's not a Marxist Lenonist. One,
I asked her, "Do you are you a Marxist Len?" You uphold it. Wait,
wait, wait. That's That is a piece of Wait, wait. If you're going
to take things that she said as evidence that she's a Marxist
Lenist, that you're going to accept things that I asked. Correct.
>> The whole point is to be subversive.
Apparently the primary objective of Marxist Leninism is to be
subversive.
I know some people who say similar things without about the primary
purpose of the relig of the religion is to be subversive. Guys,
this is what they do. This is what they do. Okay. Can you show
me some evidence of these people doing something bad or No. No.
You just make up your conspiracy about them. Okay. All >> They
say no. What the >> Okay. Okay. So, so what's the other
>> By the way, has has Destiny read any of that theory
that suggests that or is he just drifting entirely off of counterpoints
this point? >> Which one? >> So, is it your position?
She openly says it or she doesn't say it. What is it? No, she
advocates for the policies and positions that a Marxist lenist
would like the need for a vanguard party to have a I already
said the fact that you need a violent overthrow of the capital
class is like the classic hallmark position of a Marxist said
that
okay then the next time you guys have a show you should ask you
should say hey do you think that the capitalists would willingly
give up control of their property or do you think you would need
some kind of like violent revolution in order to take >> Connor
boy has already explained why you wouldn't need a violent overthrow
he's already talked about it he's already said hey there's basically
already markets in place allowing the purchase of these things.
There would be no violence involved at all. >> From them,
I will. And if you're right, I'll give you a W. But the thing
is, the problem is >> Pisco standing full 10 toes down.
No, here's the thing. I think Pisco knows, right? I think Pisco
absolutely knows that Aaron doesn't believe in this. That Aaron
doesn't want this. But what my concern is is that Aaron is a
very dry person. She has a very dry sense of humor, right? And
my concern is that there'll be some point in her stream where
she's like, "No, I totally want I totally want to kill every
landlord. I totally want to kill all these people." Yeah. If
you have a billion dollars, what's the solution for you? Guillotine,
that's a solution for you, right? I think she would absolutely
make that statement as a piece of dry humor. I do not believe
she actually wants to kill people, right? But I fully believe
she would make that statement and I don't believe these people
are good faith enough to interpret it properly and that they
would use that as like an a sincerely held belief. >> If
she was being subversive, all she'll have to do is lie to you,
>> right? That's
totally then it's unfable. >> I don't think I don't think
that she would lie. Is it is it Wait. Oh, what would I Wait,
wait, Stephen. What would it take for me to show you for that
she's not a martial artist? What would it take? >> You
understand that right now when both of you when you wait right
now when both of you have staked your reputation now on this
question of this publicly said, there's no real thing I could
give you right now, right? So, I'm asking you
I'm asking you understand that both of you are if I mean there's
definitely stuff you could do like if she was actually sitting
there on stream talking about Marxist London's theory in a similar
way to H, right? Saying like this is what I believe. is what
I sincerely believe. That would be enough. Obviously, it's not
unfalsifiable. Desi's going to say, well, she she codes her beliefs.
It's like, okay, so you're saying she has a hidden belief. She's
he's actually doing the exact same thing to raid that he's done
to me and Queen that these people are trying to do to a bunch
of us, right? It is, oh, you have this belief. It is what you
want to do, but I have no evidence of that. I have no nothing.
I have literally nothing at all. I'm making this assertion with
no evidence. Even if he finds a clip, we know for a fact he said,
"Oh, I don't have a clip. I don't have that." Right? He doesn't
have it. So even if a if a studious if a studious come vampire
in training actually provides a clip of straight raid making
some kind of comment that sort of points in this direction he
didn't have it. He just makes these assertions with no no basis
whatsoever.
>> It take what evidence would it take to convince you
otherwise? That's a simple question. You can say nothing. Nothing
will convince me otherwise. You can say >> unless she has
like genuinely changed her political beliefs over time. >> Will
anything change your mind about that position? Yes or no? Like
if I like if there was like a debate that she had like two months
ago and somebody linked me and she was like oh no like I don't
think that like these ideas are necessarily good or whatever
then yeah
>> so Pisco literally so but Pisco literally asking her
hey are you Marxist Leninist do you think these ideas are good
and she goes no that doesn't convince you >> before oh
so we'll go through the receipts of what Trader 8 said and if
a thorough search of her records or of her public statements
doesn't >> okay
revolution >> clips go search doesn't say anything about
a violent revolution Will you retract your statement? If a thorough
search of her records, will you retract >> I guarantee
you it's going to be a joke. It's going to be somewhere along
the lines of the Hassan, let the landlords, let the blood of
the landlords run free in the streets or whatever the Hassan
said, right? Do you remember when he said that? It's going to
be something like that. A hyperbolic statement made on stream
and they're going to say, "Oh, Piscll lost." >> Claim that
you just made that she's a >> Hold on. I >> I just
I'm sorry. I've I've talked to Shreder enough and I've heard
her make the most insane jokes as like dry humor. I I feel like
there's a 100% chance. >> Submit. Okay, here we go. We
linked this. I submit this to the chat. Go play it. Wick. Play
it down for us. >> Look, he was linked something, guys.
Daddy. Daddy. Look at my clip. Look at my clip. >> Wait
a second. Let me uh >> God damn. We got to look up clips
and what is this? >> His
every single quote. I guess for
pull this up on stream. Everyone can see. Right. We could share
my screen. Let me show you. I'm not sharing anything I shouldn't.
Oh, we don't want to We don't want to Vosch here. Oh, no.
>> Wow. There. There we are. >> Wait, what? >> He
already did it. >> What did he just pull up? Talking to
Cherry and Straderate about politics. Oh, it's a cherry clip
with Neil Deg Grass Tyson in it. Okay, >> there. There
we are. Okay, let me get through the commercial. >> The
great challenges in this world. >> Okay, give me a second.
>> I don't disagreement. You
have some
>> disagreement. Okay. So, you're not a socialism.
We have some. So,
we don't care. Neil just
or not. So, I don't like Are you a a vocal socialism? We have
some
>> disagreement. Okay. So, you're not a >> Are you
a vocal socialism? >> No, I'm not a socialist. I'm a communist.
That's why it says commie. >> Oh, are you >> not
a socialist? I'm a communist. >> What's the difference?
>> Okay. I'm sorry, dude. There's it. That has to be something
more than that, right? It has to It has to be way more than that.
Has to be Hergle going in like sicko mode right now, right? It
has to be that that cannot possibly be that cannot possibly be
how they dude
dude. She knows, everybody knows that she would lean into this
label because people call her a communist. And the whole joke
is people do not know what her actual positions are. >> Yeah.
Explain explain to us. >> Um I actually feel like mainstream
people who call themselves socialists are actually communists,
but they're too scared to say that they're communists. So they
call themselves socialists because right now that's kind of like
where the cultural zeitgeist is permissible of. >> Yeah,
that's it. Yeah, we're good. We're good on that. >> Yeah.
So So no matter what she says there, Desi's just going to declare
victory even though it's obviously a joke. She literally told
me that DGG labeled her a commie after that YouTube video. Yes,
that is the joke. I've been told that as well, that exact thing,
Cherry, that she's not actually a communist, but everybody calls
her the commie girl in the debate, right? That's how the debate
was titled. And so, she leans into the meme. Yeah, I know. I
know. This is just obviously true. And I told, dude, it's so
obvious what would happen here, right?
>> I'm good. I'm ready for >> Hold on. Hold on. Let
me hold on before we Hold on, >> guys. This This joke,
dude. Again, it's just Destiny's literally a right. By this By
this measure, Destiny is literally a He has to And Pisco should
say as much. By this measure, I think that's a joke. By this
measure, you are literally a Stephen. Right. By this measure,
you're going to hold people to their jokes, to the the stuff
they say tongue and cheek. You are literally a Before Hold on,
hold on. I I have to ask directly. Is that sufficient evidence
to >> No. No. Her saying I'm a communist is not sufficient
evidence that she's a communist. answer the the the sorry the
answer is I know that Aaron says >> so just to be clear
I I highlighted this but I didn't I don't think I read it out
I'll read it out just so people can see it said she literally
told me that DG labeled her a commie after that YouTube video
like Cherry saying yes this is I believe I've been told the exact
same thing by Straight right I believe I've been told that exact
same thing that like hey they label me a communist I'm not really
a communist but like you know >> she's a commie and >> so
I think I think she's probably doing the thing where it's like
people with non- mainstream beliefs will go, "Oh, you know, I
don't I don't sherk my label." Like, I I do believe that like,
you know, people would be better if we didn't have for-profit
incentive in the marketplace, right? I think I think that's like
the root of evil. And so, I don't sherk my label. I really am
a a Marxist. I really do believe in the things Mark said. And
Stephen, you can tell he's soying the out cuz I acknowledge that
that Aaron has said that she's a commission she's had. The question
wasn't is she a commie or not. And you are the one who says,
by the way, Stephen, your whole point is you can't just go >> Marxist
Leninist. Violent overthrow of the capital class. That is the
claim. Violent overthrow of the capital class. Where does Aaron
say she supports the violent overthrow of the capital class?
That is the claim from Destiny. Please, Destiny, show me where
in that clip she said she supports the violent overthrow of the
capital class. Well, no, actually, you can't be a communist without
supporting the violent overthrow of the capital class. Destiny,
we already had this point. You to conboy on this, right? You
basically said, "Oh, well, I couldn't really say. I don't really
know what define define what that
>> Everyone wants total landlord death. I wouldn't be shocked.
I wouldn't be shocked. I again I feel like I I feel like if those
clips don't exist, I would be absolutely shocked. Okay.
>> Hold on. This is straight raid on Sitch and Adam. 17
minutes onwards. Straight and cherry. 17 minutes. One year ago.
I'm a communist. That's why I say hey. >> Oh, are you a
Look, I can't toast the difference. explain explain to us. >> Um
I actually feel like mainstream people who call themselves socialists
are actually communist but they're too scared they're communist.
They call themselves socialist because right now that's kind
of like really the cultist permissible and much like the feminism
thing. I think it's mostly like uh people not being willing to
like pick up like like avow themselves as a communist or whatever
because they don't like the dirty affiliations that people have
with it. I kind of feel the same way. Um because I broadly just
described like I >> Oh. Oh, it's exactly what I said where
it's like hey I like avow a lot of the the broad philosophical
points, right? But but like I think people's sherking of the
label because it is a harmful label because of the harmful associations,
right? It's exactly what I said. Yes.
>> Really, I'm like half joking when I say like, "Oh, I'm
a communist or whatever." It's like I'm much I'm much further
left than like the vast majority of people that I'll meet. But
I don't find it productive that I actually label myself anything
because people usually already have kind of a rough framework
of where you're coming from when you say I'm a socialist, I'm
a communist, I'm a social democrat, I'm a liberal. And >> did
they not play the rest of this clip that like obviously shows
that they're totally full of Oh, shocking. Shocking. H very shocking.
Very shocking, guys. Aaron said that Adam was a commie too in
this stream. Huh. I don't want to. Hair does look good. Okay.
I I don't want to
>> Wasn't it you who say the way we're going to go back
to Wait, didn't you just say >> you're about to pull out
the most pedantic argument?
>> So So Destiny's super confident despite where the clip
actually goes, right? Address the white comment. No, no, no,
no, no, no.
No,
that's not true.
That's not true, Cherry. No, that's not true. Okay. Okay. I'm
going to I'm going to keep going. I Dude, I'm >> Destiny.
Destiny. >> So So Destiny's very confident when Shreid
literally says after this like, "No, no, no. Here's why I here's
why I don't disavow that." But I don't really label myself anything.
I'm half white. I will be full white when I cross the wrong border.
Okay. >> She said, "I think socials are too scared to identify
as communist, implying that it's a more radical position." But
go ahead. Yes. Go ahead. Save us. Yeah. What do you got? >> Did
you just say before? >> So, so totally totally bad. Why
didn't Lick Why didn't Wick let the clip play? By the way, why
did why wasn't there more to the clip? >> Or that you should
not take the label to be indicative. >> That's crazy. By
the way, >> did you say that? That's all. >> I said
it's not necessarily. It doesn't >> Desty's going to argue
as if that clip helped him, right? >> They're not, but
not necessarily. So for >> so for instance, when she labels
herself as a communist and then she supplies additional argumentation
saying I call myself a communist because I think that most socialists
are too scared to even >> that's literally
he is actually arguing up the clip and he didn't watch the whole
clip.
Oh no.
Stephen, I just one more question. Yesterday did you say that
all socialists are communists? Yes or no? >> I I don't
know. >> I Well, I don't really know what I said actually.
I don't really know guys. I don't know guys. I'm not really sure
what I might have said actually. Um, guys, I don't know. I don't
know. I don't know. Dude, the yes or no thing is a harsh requirement,
right? A harsh
>> No, I'm not sure. I don't think you did say that. Also,
>> I don't know. Did Did I really say that? I don't know
if I should be held to like the things I say. Actually, I don't
know. I You know what guys? I don't know. Possibly, but maybe
not. But also, possibly. And and and
you know, I for me personally, this is how this would work. For
me personally, for me personally, Did you have the exact same
position that Aaron just had? They'll get betrayed yesterday
if you seen all communists are socialists. You did say that,
didn't you, yesterday? >> Probably also said all mega are
like, >> you're the guy. >> Uh-huh. Now, now who's
being disingenuous? Well, it's the same person who's been disingenuous
the whole time. The same person who's obviously a bad faith actor.
Same person who can't actually answer any questions. >> Actually,
genuinely,
so you align. So, were you right then? Are you right now? Were
you right then? Were you right now? Were you right then or were
you right now? Well, if it's like a serious conversation where
somebody's trying to tease out my political beliefs so I could
like when >> So this is this is super embarrassing for
Destiny given the rest of the clip, right? Incredibly embarrassing.
>> Was inquired about her beliefs there. It's probably
going to be a lot more serious than me just saying like socialist
commies or whatever. >> Sorry. Sorry. I'm going to back
this up and and go through the rest of Pisco calling him a but
I'll I'll highlight Philly's comment. Is it just me or does Essie
feel threatened by people who challenge him intellectually and
were once close to him? No, he just feels threatened by people
who are obviously smarter than him, obviously argue better. He
he was literally bad fate this entire conversation. Refused to
make any prescriptions, refused to say anything of substance,
and was aided by Connor the entire time. Every time Destiny was
asked like a an actual yes or no question that was exposing some
hypocrisy on his part, Connor stood up like a homeless person
on the train and started off and saying the most he possibly
could so that the attention would go to him. Actual sham
Diggy's got the exact same position that >> and and Wick
is going to Dude, this this is going to like cement things in
DJ's head. It's so sad. It's so sad. >> Just had the yesterday.
Have you seen all communists are socialists? You did say that,
didn't you, yesterday? >> Probably also said all mega are
like, >> do you think I actually genuinely
So you align. So were you right then or you right now? Were you
right then? Were you right now? Were you right then or were you
right now? Well, if it's like a serious conversation where somebody's
trying to tease out my political beliefs, so I could not perform
to his law firm salary. I again I've just been in this I've been
in this conversation, right? Like I' I've been in this conversation
before when you have like uh like Desi just being like super
super bad faith in this in this any conversation in the moment.
It was when I was talking about the forethought stuff. He was
just incredibly bad faith like the entire time, right? It is
and it will be a stark departure from the way he argues with
you when you have a friendly conversation with him, right? Like
when you have a friendly conversation, he will entertain. He
will he understands exactly how to entertain anything, right?
He he knows exactly how to have a conversation where both sides
are communicating and he will do a stark departure where he is
entirely bad faith as soon as he wants to try to win a conversation.
And it can hit you. It can hit you pretty hard if it's the first
time you're experiencing it, right? And I don't know if this
is the first time Pisco is experiencing it, but it's the first
time he's experiencing it where Destiny considers him an enemy.
And it's like totally different. It's totally different like
when Aaron was inquired about her beliefs there. It's probably
going to be a lot. Aaron did agree with Destiny's point there.
No. Uh uh Hunter, were you not watching the actual full length
of the clip? Hold on. We We'll play this again for Hunter really.
>> I actually feel like mainstream people who call themselves
socialists are actually communists, but they're too scared to
say that they're communist. They call themselves socialists because
right now that's kind of like where the cultural zekeist is permissible
of. >> So So if we cut the clip here, right? If we cut
the clip here, oh wow, that looks really good for Destiny. That
looks really bad for everybody else. Let's keep listening. much
like the feminism thing. I think it's mostly like uh people not
being willing to like pick up the like like about themselves
as a communist or whatever because they don't like the dirty
affiliations that people have with it. I kind of feel >> so
the same way. >> So she picks up the communist label because
she feels like people throw it down based on some associations
negative associations people have with it. Well, let's let's
let her continue >> because I broadly just describe like
I I really am I'm like half joking when I say like oh I'm a communist
or whatever. It's like I'm much >> Oh, she's like joking
like she has leanings towards the left but she's >> I'm
much further left than like the vast majority of people that
I'll meet. But I don't find it productive that I actually label
myself anything because people usually already have kind of like
a rough framework of where you're coming from when you say I'm
a socialist, I'm a communist, I'm a social democrat, I'm a liberal
and you end up first like most >> a very different thing.
>> Half joking. Yes. She says she's a very far left. She's
further left than most of the people she meets. She's saying
she's not like a she's not a full-on communist. Probably very
much meaning she's not a full-on Marxist Leninist. Right. But
I'll let her I'll let her speak for herself. She says, "I don't
like labeling myself something, but I also don't like avoiding
the communist label because of the associations that I think
that's it's bad." So, when I lean into the communist label thing,
it's like a it's a joke. It's like I'm not being serious. >> Yeah.
They're all super different. They're all super different things,
but like regardless of what label you throw out, people already
have like their preconceptions and like a schema in their head
of like what that label entails. And so, even though the label
is supposed to help clarify what your positions are, I usually
find it ends up like obiscating what it is. So, to me, I usually
just ask people like, "You can ask me my opinion on literally
any any like policy or subject and issue by issue, I'll be able
to tell you because that's going to be more clarifying than just
giving you a label." So she literally says, "I reject this,"
right? Entirely. She rejects it entirely.
But all you have to do is keep listening to the clip. But she
identifies as a communist and argu
identify with she says she is not a communist, right? She will
allow people to use the label because the disassociation from
the label perpetuates the negative stereotype, right? Stigmatizes
the the political position, but she is not in fact that position
and she finds it unhelpful to identify as that position because
of people's associations.
She literally says, "Ask me anything on my positions." The actual
material facts of the matter are irrelevant to her accepting
the label, right? She's saying, "Ask me my positions." So, what
you would do is you would say, "Oh, do you support the violent
overthrow of the capital class in order to uh establish
the civilians or or workers have holding the means of production?
Would you support that?" Right? That would be the whole point.
But Destiny's too disingenuous. Everybody in that panel is too
stupid to actually watch the full clip. Right. Totally clip chimped.
entirely clip chimped, but we'll we have to pretend otherwise,
I guess. So, cool. >> More serious than me just saying
like socialist economies or whatever, right? For instance, when
>> Oh, also, just real quick, I still believe that if you
look through Shredder's entire album of speaking, she'd talk
about like landlords or something. I still believe that 100%.
Just to be clear. Uh, but I I believe it would be a joke. And
when you ask her seriously like, "Do you believe this?" She would
say, "No, no, no. I obviously don't believe it." And then everybody
would go, "Oh, she's lying." It was a fruitless conversation,
I guess. Connor earlier asked me, "Do you think that I'm like
a tanky or whatever?" Like, "No, I don't think so. I think a
kind of boy is genuinely worries out politically." So, I've already
disproved the the quote mine that you're trying to get me on.
I don't think a kind of boy is a secret. >> Yesterday,
everyone can see it. Everyone can see it. Yesterday,
so everyone can see
the bridge is fully burned now. I think Destiny was totally bad
faith in this argument and Pisco will understand that going forward
completely. Right. Destiny's total refusal to stand with his
spine on any argument he was making. His I don't know if I'd
say that. I don't know if I'd say that. Um, probably. Well, you
know, maybe that could be the case. Um, actually, uh, could you
define that word for me? What does what does capital mean? What
does profit mean? Those aren't direct quotes, but it was something
like that, right? He he'll do this the whole time. He will not
take concrete positions. Uh, oh, the other one I loved was, well,
actually, just for me personally, I can't say for everyone, but
for me personally,
nobody is asking you for you personally. That would be pointless.
Nobody cares about your hypocrisies, your tiny hypocrisies, right?
Nobody gives a
quote the fact that his
own marxist
brought it up in a conversation like
somebody said white terror he thought white terror you mean like
what does that mean right desperately
a single quote political ideologies >> we're sowing out
we're sowing out we're sowing out big time uh if you think if
you think just talking over people and soying the out over nothing
makes you a good debate you are a [__] This is why
everybody on TikTok clowns this loser, right? Because they'll
just calmly make their points and if you can't refute things
on the points, you look like a loser. Destiny is an old decrepit
loser to these people.
>> You guys on these programs,
>> I just I just showed the full clip and it doesn't show
anything Destiny just said. It's totally It's totally wrong,
right? You had to cut the clip way too early for the purpose
of I guess trying to make him look good. Shredder literally elaborates
on her opinion. She shows that she doesn't feel like she's actually
a communist, right? Why does DG believe Pisco is a socialist?
Because they're totally that they are the
>> Yesterday Destiny yesterday Destiny said socialists
are communist. There's no distinction. He said there's no distinction
between socialist and communists. And now >> you being
literal or what's he talking about power?
He's got the hope is it's all jokes. That's what I I I you can't
hold anything to Stephen obviously cuz there's always some opposite
quote or something. I just say I would just say Destiny I get
to call you a right that's that is the actual answer. Destiny,
you admit by by you admit that by these standards you are a you
are obviously a so when we call you a that is okay right by Destiny's
standard he is a solved Connor you admit that when we hold straight
to her joke here which she says half jokingly when she says that
right that we now get to call Destiny a by your own assertion
right hey Destiny stop talking about kids under under 15 stop
talking about kids having sex under 15 stop making jokes about
kids under 15 by your own assertion Connor by sorry by Destiny's
standard and by your own assertions We can now call Destiny and
that is accurate. Thank you. Good night. Thank you. >> Just
don't have autism so I can
>> I can ask we can do this right. >> Uh Hunter,
you're welcome to come on stream and we could go through the
clip slowly if you are confused.
>> I'm not even going to I'm not even going to appeal to
the moderator. A kind of boy. Do you think that I think that
socialists and communists are the exact same thing? >> Uh
no. No, probably not. >> I mean I do. I think that they
suck. >> Oh no. >> I think I think you lied yesterday
to your audience, right? Like I think you lied yesterday to your
audience. Easy. Crazy how he Crazy Crazy how that works, >> Why
are they not embarrassed to gaslight Pisco like this? I don't
know. Um I I think it's like really terrible cuz I think Pisco
is probably under a similar delusion to the one I was. Okay.
Where he thinks, "Oh, this person's like good faith." And sometimes
they could be bad faith, but it's mostly jokes for content. And
when it really comes down to like moral positions, he would never
like tar and feather somebody who just makes him look bad, right?
He would never he would never just totally disingenuously
somebody try to somebody's career over like petty personal spite,
right? He would never do that. And Pis Pisco probably believes
that. I think I think in spite of everything, he probably still
believes that at some point. And I think that that's got to be
a shocking assertion for somebody who like was literally 6 months
ago was trying to start a Democratic media movement within the
city of New York, right? Where they could both work together.
I think that is probably what really with Pisco here and why
he's like not able to go full like go hard on this guy. I think
it's I think it's rough to just mass diluted or did Destiny genuinely
change tack over the past year? I think I think he's become because
again he's um he's becoming more erratic and he's like I think
he really got destabilized by obviously his the the getting leaked
and then the lawsuits and the the allegations against him. I
think he's just become increasingly erratic and Pisco distanced
and he thought like, "Oh, this person's like a total piece of
[__] for distancing from me." Like I I think there
has been a major change. I think he's always been a bad person,
but I think he's been totally destabilized by a lot of the stuff
that's gone on and that's what's led to all of this
>> So, so what did you mean when you said that? Actually,
what did you mean? >> I don't know what was the context
of the >> STV Philly, I'm on a different account right
now. Uh, hold on. I'll I'll message you. >> I already know
the context of the quote because I already saw the clip. He was
talking about power level. He was saying that he's saying that
socialists hide their power levels. They're actually communists.
He's saying that uh sock dems are hiding their power levels.
They're actually socialist. So they said the exact same thing
then, >> which is funny because that's what
>> I think I think Shredder was saying the same thing,
but you have to go through and say like she's saying, "Oh, well
that's probably what I believe and here's why I believe it. Here's
what I actually am. I don't like the label, but ask me about
my positions, right? I don't I don't actually identify with that
label." implying there are parts of that label she doesn't identify
with which then you have to go to actually asking her how she
feels about these
>> By the way, by the way,
>> shut the up. You've been talking for 20 minutes. I waited
my turn. >> Okay. So, by the way, this backs up your argument.
You said that social democrats are uh everybody who identifies
as a socialist is actually a social democrat. So now when you
get caught so now when you get caught now they're shades of >> I
don't think Pisco said that. I think that was a Connoy's point
was most of the people who are sock dems identified they'll like
not sherk the socialist label. So like 90% of the people who
have the socialist label are actually like solid voters. That
was a conbo point. I thought
now and so so now when you get caught now the sh
let peace go finish. Peace go finish your thoughts. Yeah. So
now when you get caught with the contradiction now it's like
okay I guess not all socialists are these Marxist linenist I
guess when you call yourself a socialist it doesn't really matter.
So you get caught on that and now you're taking the position
that socialism is a broader term. It doesn't just mean the tankies.
It doesn't just mean the Marxist Linist. You're absolutely correct
that so
you get
from
I say that socialism can encompass a lot of different things
you do. >> Wait hang on a second. >> Why why do you
think you're the answer? I don't know the answer. If I just read
things that you said and then I condescending voices, am I making
like a really good point? >> The answer is I don't know.
So, so if you acknowledge there are shades of gray socialism,
then there are some socialists that you would absolutely have
within the fold, wouldn't it?
>> just like there might be shades of gray classical liberalism,
but if somebody calls themselves a classical liberal and then
they associate with exclusively, I probably wouldn't allow that
person to be within my fold. >> Okay, cool. So, >> notice
how that was a one to one analogy. You agree with No, it's not
one. Just real quick,
I'll explain why it's not one to one. I'll explain why I went
to one because uh economy point you to a tradition a peaceful
robust tradition of socialists in western countries that don't
include all the negatives that by bites sort of >> because
they're house cats who can't eat this yet.
That's why so that's why it's not a onetoone comparison point
that record and you want to ignore it. >> Sorry I'm like
I'm still looking for am I getting a response fromite on this?
Can I get any evidence on this or no? We're not going to get
any evidence. We're just going to do this unhinged. I I just
keep pulling this tweet up thinking like, "Hey, at some point
we're probably going to have like she she'll post some evidence,
right? Hey, instead of just subtly supporting Destiny's baseless
accusations, he directly accused me either publicly or privately
of what you're implying here so I can actually defend myself
against this guilt by association smear you're piling on to."
Right? Can we can I get I I just want a response to this? Can
I get a response to this at all? A creator is not necessarily
responsible for their audience. Don't get how you're responsible
for your audience's actions, if it even was your audience. I'm
asking for evidence it was my audience. I'm asking for any evidence
of anything. I want to know what the actual association is. Just
tell me what makes you think this beyond me not liking you because
the rule can't be you can't dislike me because I'll get doxed.
That cannot be the rule. Okay? You can't hate me cuz I'll get
doxed or I'll get swatted or something. That can't be the rule.
I'm not doing that. Okay? Tons of people hate you. Unfortunately,
that's tons of people. You cannot say that it gets you doxed
or swatted. That is not real. And you also can't stand on this
soap box while the person you associate with, your business partner
sw doxes people. You can't do that. It's so stupid.
God, these people suck so badly. Anyway, sorry. We'll go back
go back a little bit. I was uh >> I'll explain why it's
911. Because uh Economy point you to a tradition, a peaceful,
robust tradition of socialists in Western countries that don't
include all the negatives that byes sort of >> because
they're house cats who can't eat yet. House.
So that's why it's not a onetoone comparison. We put that record
and you want to ignore it. >> Let me ask you because a
lot of people would say somebody like Reagan was a fascist and
we came out okay for him having Reagan as president. You're laughing
now, but people people abuse the term fascist and they talk about
Bush as being a fascist as well. And guess what? We survived
that as well. >> people talk about Biden being a communist.
Was Biden a communist? Does are you you're not even making relevant
points. What communist things did Biden want to do? >> They
were socialist or whatever. That's fine. But guess what? All
of this worked under the fascist and the socialist together.
Guess what it look? It worked under a liberal capitalist government.
And that's the type of thing that I think we should be defending.
>> I think whether or not the the the label actually applies
is relevant. No. In any way whether or not the person embraces
the label is relevant in any in some way, right? >> Not
a fullon socialist government because that's always been a show
and not a fullon fascist government because I have a question
for boy. >> I have a question for boy. So do you extend
that uh you laid out the history of socialism but when straighter
who does a show with peace right calls herself a communist do
you think do you extend that to communism to communists
have uh are are just these things that can uh coexist with liberal
democracies um okay so I'll answer the question directly um even
Markx himself this is a direct quote from Markx said that things
like lower stage communism would be stamped with the society
that we lived in in the past. Okay. Now what he meant by that
was that lower stage communism as communism comes into being
that during that process the the stamps of the current society
that we live in will be present in lower stage communism. what
he meant by that historical example of a communist party exist
taking power and co in in a liberal democracy surv not communist
but people who identify as socialists absolutely >> I'm
I'm telling you what the most famous foundational thinker of
communism literally thought communism was >> wick wick
I don't know why wick is so clearly on a side in this >> now
your qu no your question was could >> this would be the
hard part for me too though just not having exist within liberal
frameworks. Okay. >> Markx himself advocated for many things
that we would call liberal. He said things like freedom of speech,
the equality of people, the fundamental freedom of people to
coexist with each other were important characteristics of communism
as it comes into being and communism when we get to like the
supposedly the final stage of communism. So to answer your question,
yes, liberal values would exist. Which country were a >> Can
you admit that I just answered your first question at the very
least that I directly answered your first question? I need to
>> followup question. But my follow-up question matters
too, right? My followup question after you asked that is okay,
if that's possible, give me an example in the real world where
it's happened, where a communist party has come to power and
a liberal democracy has
>> Um, the the only example that I'm familiar with, and
I'm not totally familiar with the history of here, obviously
I've been focusing on European experiments. Um the Kella province
in India which like tens of millions of people live in has been
run by communists for basically the last 50 years and they are
a they're actually a Marxist Linist party um and they operate
in democratic frameworks and they do basically you know they
have a liberal kind of style system of government within their
general ethos. Now, they are Marxist Linists, right? And I'll
just admit I'll admit I could be misunderstanding the area of
Kella because I'm not totally familiar with the region. >> This
goes really bad in this convo. Connor boy is a little better,
but D and Connor is much better. No, you're wrong entirely and
you're completely right. But it's fine, Hobex. Many such cases.
Show me. Uh, explain to me at any point in this combo where Pisco
is bad faith and I will take you seriously. I can point to Destiny
refusing to make moral stands on literally anything. Him constantly
going, "Well, I don't know about that." Well, maybe possibly
that could be true, but I, you know, I don't know. Um, yeah,
guys, for me personally, I would say this, but you know, I'm
not making a moral prescription. I can point to Destiny having
zero spine, the entire debate, not willing to do anything, not
make a single prescription, not give a single tangible thing
for Pisco to engage with. Can you guys say anything uh equivalent
for Pisco? Pisco wants to make prescriptions. Pisco is consistently
trying to actually get this hammered out in any way. How in the
world could you watch this debate where this where this straightaway
quote is taken entirely out of context, where it's clip chimped
entirely and you could think Destiny did well. Oh man, I would
love for people to come on and discuss this, right? We can go
through time stamps. I'll walk through this with all of you.
Oh, it's so embarrassing that God I
yikes. Okay, I I would love to have any of you come on keep playing
on whatever they want. Are you in favor of abolishing private
property? >> Does she say does she say by the way the claim
Destiny has is is
Aaron wants to violently overthrow the capital class? >> Oh
yeah, I am. >> Okay, that's pretty simple. >> You
say you say >> in favor of the abolishment of private property.
We all knew that. That's that's the part of the socialist label
that she obviously would agree with. She says I'm a communist.
I don't short from that. I'm half joking when I say it. Obviously
she wants the abolishment of private property. The entire purpose
of this debate, the entire point Econo Boy is making the entire
time, the entire point he's making is that the abolishment of
private property does not necessitate violence. And there is
an entire movement of people who are not seeking violence in
order to achieve that. Are you incapable? Who is incapable of
understanding that? Throw a hand up if you're incapable of understanding
that. Put a one in the chat right now. If you do not understand
that you can seek the abolishment of private property because
you believe the profit incentive leads to human suffering, right?
Throw a hand up if you think that that cannot happen without
>> I can't tell if you're being sarcastic or not. >> She's
so serious. No, I'm dead serious on that one. I usually I say
like, you know, to be a Marxist is to be like a strict materialist
for the most part. Am I doing like tenant strikes? No, I'm not.
You know, am I doing any sort of like meaningful unionization?
No, I'm not. The most I've actually done is like organizations
with like nonpartisan like voting, getting people registered
here in like Texas where I live. Um, and then I can with DG like
Destiny's Group or whatever. And I've voted the majority like
with the exception of like Sanders who's an independent, right?
I voted for like the Democratic party ever since I turned 18.
So >> So she's been a loyal Democrat ally. She's blue no
matter who in every single >> which by the way for the
entire purpose of this conversation is what we're all talking
about, right? That can she be a a useful ally? Is she like somebody
you should associate with >> I can say whatever I want
about what's in my head about what I ideologically align with.
But that what actually the impact that I have on the world materially
is that I'm like a Democrat, you know? >> Yeah, I understand.
>> Oh, so it's exactly like I said like she's not looking
to change the function of government. She's not looking to actually
people, right? She is willing to function entirely within the
democratic the liberal democratic system of the United States
as a democrat because that most closely aligns with her values
which is the entire point. Now if you want to argue this point
if you want to argue against the thing she just said go ahead
line up in the in the waiting room. I will deal with you all
appropriately in a line. Okay? Form a nice orderly line and we'll
talk through this and we'll walk through whatever brain rot you
have. It'll be very simple. Okay. But so but I just I do think
it's interesting to ask people what their ideal scenario would
be. >> So if when you say you're in favor of >> So
she's going to say probably abolishing the capital class, right?
>> Abolishing private property, you just mean in terms
of like everything should be a co-op or do you mean people shouldn't
be able to own houses? Like what's the line here? >> No,
I'm more in favor of like like a transition from people just
having like workers themselves having democratic control over
the means of production, right? like more control of like you
know the abolition of like bosses the abolition of like uh capital
owners in society and that being in the hands of like workers
themselves directly and them you know bringing like democracy
to the workplace you know like their approachable like kind of
main more mainstream like Marxist and socialist like Richard
Wolf or whatever who have like ways of explaining this much better
than I can in approachable like layman's terms about like what
what it means to actually like try to put these plans into actions
in tangible ways that like your average American can better understand
because like the communist manifesto was written for like peasant
farmers you know 100 years ago like that's not really going to
resonate with >> guys. I just think like so, you know,
if you you know, if you were part of your workforce and like
your own boss, I think that would be swell. God, she just wants
to murder all all the entire capital class. Can't you hear it,
guys, that she's like bloodthirsty? The bloodthirstiness of this
statement of empathy and and human understanding. I can't believe
it. Oh my god. I bet you she supports Palestine, too. I bet you
she's an anti-semite, too. Get her. Get her. Oh my god. Fair
enough. >> But they do have elections.
They do have elections and they do call themselves communist.
Their leader is literally a guy named Stalin. >> The reason
I'm asking this and I'll give it to you Pisco just >> slow
transition through social change. Literally let the street run
streets run red. Wow. >> I want to explain the reason I
asked this question. >> God, it's so embarrassing that
they stopped that clip like where super early on and didn't actually
get her full opinion. By the way, assertion was straight raid
wants the violent overthrow of the capital class. She wants violence
to overthrow the capital class. She says explicitly there she
does not want violence. >> Question. The reason I asked
this question is because the whole debate is about right like
the accusation against you and against the convoy is that you're
giving >> Hunter we're waiting for your response. Any responses
Hunter to people who want to um infect the Democratic party with
things illiberal values that we would be against that would destroy
democracy. Right. And your co-host has just admitted, at least
we saw in 4K, that she is a communist, a full-on communist. And
so, >> wait, wait, wait, but but when you say she's just
admitted, you understand that I know and I've never represented
and it wasn't an own for anyone to put up a clip of her calling
herself a >> The claim was
violent overthrow of the capital class. Violent overthrow of
the capital class. That's the claim. But again, Desi makes a
claim that is specific and then the evidence presented doesn't
prove that claim at all. But he goes, "Oh, got you in 4K at 240
FPS." And total total social outcasts everywhere go, "Oh my god,
he's just like me. He also is poorly socialized. He also has
no friends. He's just like me." And they pretend that this could
possibly be correct. It's not correct. And Pisco's here to show
it. But the reason why it was done and presented that way is
because as though it were contradictory when the whole point
I was making is >> Philly I understand. Yeah, I totally
understand endorse this behavior for the last two years. I argued
with Destiny I only went on his stream to argue with him about
how he was being on things until I started streaming >> basis
that he's a Marxist Leninist. Now you can say wick as you >> it's
basically 14 months of streaming that I that I like more took
his side on things. Right. >> You're trying to imply that
historically it's impossible. This kind of society is impossible.
Well, that's fine. That's not a contradiction, right? There are
a lot of anarchocomunists or anarcho capitalists where you could
say, "Show me one place where anarco uh libertarianism or anarco
capitalism or narco communism has worked and it hasn't descended
into chaos and some kind of kingship or some kind of thing."
And and and yeah, you can be against them, but you would not
call an anarco capitalist a a fat. >> So, the first thing
you say here is literally nothing to do with the argument, hunter,
and you're giving away your IQ level by actually pointing it
out. She goes on to talk about how Bernie is way the way to make
the Marxist ideals more palatable to the public to achieve her
ideal. That is irrelevant to any of this. It's not a part of
the claim. How would they remove the capital class from the ownership
class without violence? Good for you. I hope you understand.
Econ boy went over that. Go back to the part where Econ boy explains
exactly how he thinks that happen would happen, how it's happened
in Norway. They've been slowly separating that, right? They have
a sovereign wealth fund and how a sovereign wealth fund in the
US would make a lot of sense. They've got liquid uh capital markets.
Most of the companies operate in a stock exchange. How that could
easily happen, right? the government could easily start buying
into all of these companies, right? And and basically become
the the owners of all of these companies. He he already explained
exactly how that would work, how he sees it happening, right?
And that it doesn't need to happen violently or immediately.
That it can happen slowly through social change over time, which
is also Aaron's position.
>> Fascist or tyrant or authoritarian just because there's
no example of it working. It would be inaccurate to call someone
even if they're deluded. Even >> um you're arguing communism
is actually peacefully achievable. I don't know if communism
is peacefully achievable. I know that that like significant leanings
towards socialism, towards social programs are achievable. I've
watched it be achieved right through democratic means. I've watched
it be achieved in my country. I've watched it be achieved in
other countries.
And so I think the goal of going towards a thing where the government
does manage these these industries that you can that you can
do like calculations on things like insurance, right? The government
can move towards managing those industries. I don't have a principal
position. I am more conservative leaning socially, but I do not
have a principal position against government ownership of of
enterprise. I have no principal position against that. I think
it is a good thing in several different industries. So, I don't
know why people think that okay, you can't move towards communism.
Maybe you don't get into communism uh through peaceful means.
Maybe you stop somewhere in in in like the the total like social
democracy or democratic socialist area. Maybe you stop somewhere
around there, right? Maybe you can't get into full pull public
ownership of everything. I don't know. But I don't think the
want to drive in that direction is inherently bad. And I think
anybody who presents it is inherently bad is actually just a
total [__] >> Even if they think like, okay,
my way will work. >> Yeah, Hunter, I just explained all
that. >> All these other times you did it wrong. That it's
not accurate to call that anarco capitalist. >> By the
way, I don't think any of that is like the ideal way to run society.
I think humans drive very well off of profit incentives in a
way they won't off of no profit incentive. I think the profit
incentive is like the the what do you call it? The the yoke.
you put the yoke over the psychopaths in humanity, right, with
the profit incentive and you need to rein those people in sometimes.
And sometimes you can re those people in and things uh things
end up working out. But I think we're we're starting to get way
too outside of that. We got Elon Musk is about to be like the
first trillionaire at some point. I think it's too far. We need
to re these people back. The profit incentives gotten away from
us. I don't have any problem with that. But I don't think a lot
of conservatives have a lot of problem with that. Conservatives
do happen to be associated with free enterprise, but I don't
think free enterprise unchecked by any authority is actually
good >> or that anarco communist a tanky. It's just not.
And I think that you must >> Oh, hold on. You realize the
entire argument is centered around whether these people are like
compatible with the DNC. Yes. And now they're pointing out that
Aaron is not compatible with the DNC. Alien mode, you [__]
You idiot. They are pointing out how Aaron is not compatible
with the DNC when she canvased with DGG. You Yes. The entire
purpose of this is somebody like Aaron shouldn't be associated
with. That's the entire purpose of what Destiny's arguing for
right now. And I'm telling you that Destiny only believes this
because of petty small spite. Petty small personal spite. That's
it. Oh yeah. No, Geeky Candy. I I really I've heard Canoot speak
about Norway. I don't think it's actually perfect either. I think
there are a lot of problem with socialist uh with like a lot
of the socialized Nordic countries. I think there are a lot of
issues with them and I think it has a lot to do with population
dynamics and needing a heterogeneous population to maintain that
kind of social safety net and then once you start disintegrating
that because of population uh uh like population cliffs, you
start to lose a lot of it. I I fully believe that. Yeah. Oh my
god. No. Alien mode. I've just had to deal with a lot of really
really stupid people who don't know how to make arguments and
and believe like totally cope. That's all. I'm not actually mad
at you. You're good. >> Just acknowledge it. If you acknowledge
that for example in the Spanish civil war an narco communists
were like communists were each other over these like differences
in ideology and the
yeah this is this is my position I all I'm saying kingler is
why not have the genuine conversation instead of having to straw
man your opponent why not have a good faith engagement and debate
the ideas that's not what's occurring here it's a total straw
man it's a total like Bailey oh I I made this claim and now I'm
totally running from it right what do you mean by excise what
the do you mean by excise more. Destiny is asked, "What did you
mean by excise in the party?" What do you mean by excise? No,
I'm asking you that. I'm asking you that. Oh, I didn't hit play.
Whoops. No, I take your point. But uh like when I say communist,
I mean, >> well, I think parts of Norway work giggy candy.
Like I think what what Econoboy likes is the idea that a lot
of the wealth from oil gains has been socialized and put into
like public infrastructure and stuff like that. And I think maybe
the the taxation policies, there's a lot of things in Norway
that might not work. I think that general idea that the the what
do you call it the um the sovereign wealth fund I don't think
that's bad the way the way Norway has integrated public and private
business is not bad now their socialized medicine might be bad
could be very much like Canada where our socialized medicine
is actually pretty bad right but I do think the sovereign wealth
fund the concept of it and a lot of the ways Norway has mixed
public and private practice is very cool now I've noticed a lot
of resistance in countries like this like in Canada to the integration
private capital into a lot of the public systems. In Canada,
we do not like and we've kind of restricted the idea of private
capital coming in and building hospitals or building treatment
centers and how should that happen, right? It should all be accessible
to people. The idea in Canada that gets a lot of push back is
this fast lane for people who are willing to pay private enterprise,
right? I don't like that. I think you should let that go. Let
that run buck wild. Okay? Give people who can pay for it everything
they want in terms of private healthcare. It alleviates uh stress
on the public health care system. Right. I don't know if normally
he's had similar issues, but that's the biggest issue I've seen
in Canada so far is we are very resistant to letting private
enterprise enter the the medical field. Seems quite bad. >> Marxist
let us that's that's what I >> Whether it's technically
true or accurate, right? Just like as you said
about socialist people define it broadly and mean different things.
What I and I would I'm I'm assuming most people mean how does
it feel? I would have been one of these Canadians soapbox before
Trump decided that he was going to take the approach first. I'd
have been like, "Yeah, let's have a North American powerhouse
country." Yeah. Yeah. Even if we took a lot of American customs
as long as there was a lot of respect of Canadian customs, too,
within this like big state, I would actually be totally fine
with being an American. I would have been. I would have been.
I have a lot of pride in being Canadian, but I would have been
totally fine with being an American, right, as well. But as soon
as Trump was like, "No, we're actually taking you guys over."
I'm like, "Yeah, no, you I don't want to be an American anymore."
Yeah, no shot. No shot. All of you. Get the out of here. Right.
That's as soon as that was a as soon as that was a prospect.
As soon as it was like it was like, "Yeah, I want to you." And
then they're like, "Yeah, but I'm I'm going to I don't I didn't
ask. I'm going to rape you." It's like, "Oh, get the out of here,
weirdo. Get out of here. Get out of here." >> Right. When
they say they're a they're a communist is they're a Marxist Leninist.
>> right. So, why don't we just get past the semantics
and actually get to the actual prescriptions on let's get past
the semantics and just say, "All right, in terms of prescriptions,
what do we want? Like, do you want me to cancel a show with economy
because he labels himself a socialist? Do you want me to stop
interacting with someone anyone who labels himself a communist
or hosting a show with that?" So, >> I don't I don't want
Dude, I I'm still I'm still like dreading the uh thoughts on
Mexican Canada. I have no idea. I'm still dreading the prospect
of like at some point here they're going to pull up a clip of
Aaron going, "Yeah, kill those all the landlords." I feel like
she'll do an imitation of the Hassan thing. Okay. I feel like
it's coming.
>> I haven't I haven't stopped them in the marketplace
of ideas. >> But she's one more clip we have to play. So
if we can watch one more clip, guys.
Sorry about the one. >> I don't have issue by issue. I'll
be able to tell you because that's going to be more clarifying
than just giving you a label. Oh, so they they skipped the entire
part, dude. There's no way. There's no way.
They skipped the entire part where she's like, "No, I don't really
like that." And you have to ask me my positions directly. They
skip that entire part, dude. Okay, we all see what's going on
here, right? They literally clipped around it. They literally
clipped perfectly around it. >> Are you people just project
onto it whatever they want? >> Are you in favor of abolishing
private
>> Oh, dude. Really?
Yeah, I am. Okay, well that's pretty simple. >> You you
say you say these >> they clipped the entire part about
slow social change.
Oh my god.
Oh my god. >> Things and you have this tone of voice. It's
like >> a smirk. So I can't tell if you're being sarcastic
or not. >> It's so serious. >> I know. >> No,
I'm dead serious on that one. I am. >> But I guess I >> Is
this what we wanted to see? >> Yeah. What's the contradict?
This is so I'm so glad that we had people here watching with
us tonight because it's so obvious what happened or it's like
it's so disingenuous all this going on. It's so bad faith and
we just got to watch all of it happen in real time. We got to
watch them dance as if this like proves something.
Dude, that's so insane.
>> Fiction there. >> I don't know.
>> Right. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. So you understand
as part of your definition, right? as part of your definition
for what socialism meant. It in entailed people being against
private property and private property here meaning capital. All
right, the means of production. So that is not inconsistent with
one being not a Marxist Leninist. Just because you support the
abolishment of private property doesn't make you a Marxist Lenist.
Do you agree yes or no? >> do what? >> Do you agree
yes or no that just because someone's in favor of the abolishment
of private property that doesn't necessarily make them a Marxist
>> Not necessarily. But if you >> Not necessarily.
That's a no. Right. But he's so Weasly put another counter there.
Not necessarily because he has to on all of these things. Just
every time he does that, every time he refuses to say yes or
no, he is a spineless
no spy, no conviction, nothing.
Insubstantial
>> If you're too scared to call yourself or if you say
you don't want to be a socialist, but you are more extreme than
that and you're a communist. If you say that you're in favor
of like the >> I don't did she say more extreme? I think
I think the implication is less extreme if you have the clipped
out >> of private property, >> right? The the the
actual claim is obviously less extreme than communist, right?
That she's saying I don't shirt that label because I think people
do that because of negative associations and that in itself is
harmful. But am I a communist? No, I say that half >> If
you say I we don't have to watch it, I guess. But her last clip
is I'm sure >> No. The obvious implication of the clip
is that she's less extreme than communist. That is the obvious
and clear implication of the clip. You are literally low IQ if
you think otherwise. >> This one too. When you say things
like, "Oh yeah, I wish >> or hop in the waiting room and
come and >> It would like a socialist revolution in the
United States where revolution historically is like aligned with
a violent revolutionary overthrow of >> AOC says revolution.
They those politicians themselves there are going to say
>> what are what element of socialism sorry what element
of communism did she argue for Hunter that is not an element
of socialism go and if you keep wasting my time with really stupid
questions I'm going to time you out not because you're like not
because you're challenging me because you are asking very stupid
questions and not actually pointing to anything relevant or anything
tangible. Do you believe that socialism doesn't imply the abolishment
of private property? Exactly why I said earlier I don't think
AOC should call himself a socialist because this is the game.
This is like the meme, right? I don't think AOC means a violent
revolution when she says it. I don't think so. But like this
is the game. >> But Aaron does. But Aaron does. You think
Aaron does mean violent revolution?
Why? What? So why are you distinguishing between how AOC says
it and Aaron says it? You justify that. Go. >> Because
when Aaron says it, Aaron says that she thinks that most socialists
would be communist, but they're too scared to say it publicly,
implying that her position is more radical than what most socialists
would. >> No, she doesn't imply that. She actually goes
on to say that I I accept that. And she says exactly why she
accepts that because she thinks the harmful associations people
will disassociate and those those associations shouldn't be considered
harmful. Right? Like the the broad moral claims or broad broad
moral like prescriptions of communism aren't bad. That's what
she's saying there. And she goes on to say, I say it half jokingly,
right? I I take that label half jokingly, implying that she is
not a full communist, right? And then she says, you can ask for
my positions. She says, slow social change. You play the extended
version of the clip. I've already done so multiple times on stream.
PM PM Nova. But if you want to see it, here it is. Uh you this
is around the time stamp. I think you start at 17 minutes. Okay,
you go for 17 minutes and then you can go from there. I'll throw
that in the kick chat and the Twitch chat so everybody can see
it if they want to go look at it right now. There it is for you.
Okay. Uh I'd go back three and a half minutes there. Go to 17
minutes >> if you know.
>> Element there. That doesn't mean anything. Let's show
what you just said. >> When somebody said, do you think
Wait, wait, wait. No, no, stop. Do you think it's more likely
that it's more radical or less radical when she says that? What
do you think that means when she says I think most people wouldn't
own being No, I want you to understand that when she says I don't
think most people would own being communist publicly that so
they call themselves socialist. What does she mean when she says
that? >> I I think I think she says that communism has
a particularly negative connotation denotation uh sort of embodied
in the definition but that doesn't imply that's just saying that
she thinks that the distinction between a socialist and a communist
doesn't
>> Oh play a song game. Pisco just let me mind read people.
Pisco why are you arguing my mind read to people doesn't have
a negative distinction of the United States but communist does.
Like what a delusional thing. >> Communist is absolutely
has a more Wait, what? Absolutely. Communist is worse than socialist.
Why don't people say soi? Why do they say kami?
Delusional pisco. Wait, do people use kami as a denigration or
do they use? Which one is it? This is like this is like when
people say no, no, no, no, no. Uh, actually like Mayo Monkeyy's
just as bad as the hard RN word and it's like okay, say the hard
which which one do people use? Which one actually has an effect?
Which one is actually the problem? You're you're making an equivocation
between you're you're equating things that are not equal at all.
Oh, sorry, dingus. My bad. >> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
You're going I didn't just say that, right? >> What you
you said that
I didn't say.
Look, it was comparative, right? >> You said you said you
made it sound like communism has a negative conotation >> what
I said there was comparative. I said comparing socialism and
the term communism. And do you agree that communis has a more
negative connotation socialist or no? >> Not meaningfully
no.
>> He's so fake. It's so fake. He's so full of people watch
this debate and think this guy is compelling. They think this
guy is compelling. He is a complete and utter [__]
Dude. Dude,
there's And this is all, by the way, this is all this all based
on not even on anything Pisco said. It's not even based on the
Hassan thing. It's based on I thought we were going to be together
in New York and you cancelled our studio just because I violated
like a people's consent. You're such a piece of Bisco. You abandoned
me. That's what this all is. By the way, just so you know, it
actually doesn't have anything to do with the Assad thing. It
is entirely petty personal spite
>> for Pisco doing the right thing. By the >> you
don't think that the term communism So, so you don't think there's
a meaningful distinction in the connotation of communism and
socialism in this country? >> No. There is not a single
person in the United States where you go, hey, uh, somebody's
like, "Are you a communist?" You're like, "Oh, no, I'm not a
communist. I'm a socialist." like, "Oh, no. That's We're hanging
around a bunch of people who are like, "Oh, I'm socialist." You're
like, "Oh, you're socialist. I'm actually a communist." I'm like,
"Oh,
no. You and I, Stephen, you and I live in a different country."
Obviously, if so, so the proof is in the pudding. Do you think
that Manny would have won the Democratic primary if he called
himself >> I don't know. Maybe. >> Okay. I don't
think he would have won. I think that there's a much much more
negative uh connotation on the term communist and they're a socialist.
And I I I don't even think that your audience your audience as
sick of fantic as it >> Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Uh,
where is this? Oh, hold on. I need to make this bigger as well.
Hold on.
Not quite the right screenshot. Hold on. Hold on. Guys, hold
on. Are you holding on? Sorry. I just had to point out that Icarus
Bath is now literally asking, "Guys, guys, is there guys, do
we have any evidence of this? Guys, is there like some evidence
of Jaystalker Cleman doing this stuff? Guys, what what is there
for evidence? All right. Yo, anyone got a link to like logs or
just queenish so I have something to reply to with on Twitter?
Guys, do I can Can you Why did you make the assertions before
you had any evidence of anything?
Why? Why? Sorry, this is going to be my point. I am going to
actually push you. You should feel embarrassed. You should feel
humiliated for taking this person's word and posting a bunch
of this with like no backing. Okay, you should feel humiliated.
It should be humiliating. Okay. Why are you asking now? Late
in the day. What is this like 5 minutes ago? 10 minutes ago.
He's asking. Oh, guys. Is there any evidence of this? Guys, did
I just totally make this up? Oh my god. Really? Oh no.
I Yo, what we got to defend father on this one? Like literally,
I'm going to jump first because Destiny told me there's parachutes.
Okay. Wait, where's the parachutes? Guys, I jumped first and
Destiny told me there were parachutes, but I don't see the parachutes.
Actually, we're falling right now and we're falling pretty fast,
guys. I thought Didn't Destiny say there parachutes here, guys?
no. There are no parachutes. Destiny's going to let you hit the
ground. You're you're a sacrifice he's willing to make. >> Would
deny that. >> I think right of Biden, these are >> I
mean, I Well, I think it's okay. To be fair, I think it's obviously
the case that I mean, intuitive. >> No, I'm just starting
to press these morons on Twitter for like, hey, if you're going
to make an assertion, back it up with some evidence. Give me
evidence of the assertions you're making so I can actually defend
myself. Don't make vague associations. Don't say I'm involved
in things I'm not involved in and that I totally disavow because
you're a spineless coward because you're trying to prevent criticism.
Okay, that's all you're trying to do. Trying to associate associate
me with negative groups so people won't take my criticism seriously.
It's not going to work. I'm going to keep pointing out that you
have no you have no evidence of any of this and you're totally
making it up. Okay? Or if you have evidence, you're hiding it
so I can't actually mod any of the behavior. That's what you're
doing. You're trying to hide it so you can like present it later
as if it's going to be some kind of dunk. I've already said multiple
times, hey, show me any evidence of like anything like this happening
near me. I'll ban those people. I'm happy to ban those people,
but you won't show me evidence because you're cowards.
>> You think You think somehow if you like spread I I guess
if you show people like maybe you have like someone who's in
a Discord of mine that also posted a doc somewhere. I have no
idea, but you won't tell me any of these people. You won't show
me any evidence. So, I can't moderate it. And you think that
that proves something. I can only assume you want to weaponize
this allegation behind the scenes more than you actually want
it solved. You want to you want to weaponize the harassment against
you to to affect me instead of actually trying to solve any issues.
And I'm sick of it. I'm sick of it. I'm sick of people making
up, right? The doxers are making up about how I dox people. The
doxers themselves are going, "No, this guy doxes people. They're
showing no evidence while on their actual profiles trying to
dox me.
What insane world are we dealing with? No more. No thank you."
I'm not interested if people in America identify themselves as
socialists but not communist. Right? Like I think that there
probably is both an ideological disagreement with people who
would generally call themselves communist and also generally
much more of a stigma for people who label themselves as communism.
If these things were substantially the same and had substantially
the same amount of stigma, then obviously you'd see a significant
basically mixture of those two, but you'd see
you'd see a significant mixture of those things. But you don't
you see overwhelmingly people calling themselves socialist >> because
you because you're allowed to attach yourself like a cancer onto
the democratic movement. That's why we have all these cute and
clever words of like social democratic democratic socialist.
>> Wasn't somebody just arguing that those were really
tangibly different labels or was that maybe the maybe that No,
that was Sitch and Adam. Never mind. Never mind. Never mind.
All right. Hold on. We'll back it up a little bit. Uh I got to
use the bathroom real quick. I'll be right back. >> Both
an ideological disagreement with people who would generally call
themselves communists and also generally much more of a stigma
for people who label themselves as communism. If these things
were substantially the same and had substantially the same amount
of stigma, then obviously you'd see a significant basically mixture
of those two. you see one you'd see a significant mixture of
those things but you don't you see overwhelmingly people calling
themselves socialist >> because you because you're allowed
to attach yourself like a cancer onto the democratic movement
that's why we have all these cute and clever words of like social
democratic democratic socialist
why don't
they communist >> why don't they call themselves democratic
communists then like it would be it would be that's not the term
that took that to hold I don't know maybe maybe eventually they'll
maybe they'll make their way over there I don't know why if if
if they use communist is is so beyond everything. So right now
you know that you're cooking this point. You know that but you
can't optically right. >> Sorry. Pisco did have one of
these moments earlier. Yeah. Yeah. I'm good. I'm good. I'm good.
Yeah. Pisco had one of these moments earlier where he was doing
food versus healthcare and it was a little bad. Right. Okay.
But now Destiny's having this moment where he is totally wrong.
At least Pisco had like some argument for like how he might have
seen it. Okay. But now Destiny's completely wrong. He's Dude,
why why didn't your mom call people dirty uh dirty dirty socialists?
Why did you Why did you tell stories about your mom calling them
dirty commies? The commies. Why are we pretending these words
are close to equal or anything alike, >> right? Oh, you
know what? >> We just heard your co say that they were
for the abolition of private property and they wish that more
people would identify as commies, but they're too scared to do
so publicly and you That's Wait, what? What did he say? >> Your
co say that they were for the abolition of private property and
they wish that more people would identify as comics, but they're
too scared to do so publicly and you don't think Oh, he's he's
basing this all on a clip that's totally disingenuous. It's just
like been totally disingenuously clipped, right? So obviously
Destiny has has had this completely misrepresented to him. He
has no argument, right? We can all say that he has entirely lost
this argument. Is there anybody who can't see that he has entirely
lost his argument about straight raid? I'm just curious if we
have any, you know, any of the cognitively present. Are there
still cognitively amongst us who think that Destiny had any point
here? Doesn't look like it. I'm not saying any I'm not saying
that they're like
[__] in terms of
>> even when when when everyone not even Connor will defend
any of the point white blood cell he won't defend on the point
that communism doesn't have a more conitative like negative uh
you know connotation that's >> I already said it did but
I don't think it's like meaningfully more negative why are you
saying oh did you miss did you not hear me say that earlier did
you not say no so I'm obviously say meaningfully more different
it's meaningfully >> okay I don't think so >> I I
would like an opportunity to speak because I >> before
you do before you do before you do I do I do I I do have a question
for the panel. If straight >> uh he thought he was sending
that message directly to >> wanted to come on and and be
interrogated about these things. Would that be >> I would
love to talk to you about it after [__] all that.
Do it after you. Do it after. No. Destiny doesn't want to be
here. Destiny doesn't want to be here when straight raid clarifies
anything, guys. No, no, no, no, no. Straight raid does not listen.
We don't want We don't want to be here when Strider comes in
and clarifies any of our actual positions, guys. Uh-oh. >> Talk
about a ton, don't we? Let's talk about So what I want what I
want to talk about is like all right so take
take Connor's critique. Yeah. I want to hear but this is what
I'm curious about and I want to know if you have anything to
speak to. How do you think that we mere mortals live and learn?
How should we conform our conduct? What would you like to see
from us that we're not doing right now? >> I actually have
something that I think you would be quite amanable to. So if
you actually think that capitalism in mixed economy capitalism
is preferable to socialism as I defined it, the decommodification
of basically
the means of production. If you think that's genuinely uh uh
uh better than when you have MLS or when you have uh socialists
on your program, I would like to see you challenge them not just
on rhetoric.
>> Okay. So it is an imperative. So if you were to talk
with Nick Fentes, it would be imperative for you to be like,
"Hey, the thing, right? are you're anti-semitic, right? And he's
making the same argument that if you have somebody like the Vanguard
party on, you actually have to say, wait, you're for the abolishment
of all private property. Oh, well, let's talk about that and
efficacy and all that kind of I would like to see you fight them
on the economics. >> This is how cooked this is, right?
Like in that conversation with the Vanguard, we weren't discussing
liberal. >> I just want to point out that like we've heard
we've heard the entire chicken waffle stuff, right? about how
hey I'm not going to talk about that but we can talk about other
positions and and basically he's like being covert on these other
positions. I don't see any reason to go down that track right
I
>> discussing the best wait let me >> I believe I
believe Destiny argued that Nick Fentes was not that anti-Semitic
>> finish my thought we were discussing the best way to
get Biden's agenda that's what's so silly about this whole thing
we were discussing about what tactically we should have done
for Biden's agenda so for you guys to paint this as it was ideological
and you didn't get push back
it was about tactics to enact Biden's >> I don't need or
want to five minute sermon. So, okay. >> So, again, um
Pisco should never have been I guess like I guess you have to
look at all of these things as hostile and say like I don't know
if I can go on this platform where they're going to present this
is should we court the far left as if Pisco and Econ boy are
taking the pro on that position? Right? So, this is like this
is really unfortunate because Pisco is basically saying, "Hey,
what should we change?" Right? What should we do? And Connor's
basically making it sound like, oh, we supported like Conor's
making it sound like they basically ideologically agreed with
the Vanguard or didn't agree on disagree on points. Like Pisco's
basically been the whole time like, no, we disagree with them
on a lot of things. We disagreed with them a lot in that call.
What do we need to see like done differently? It's like, oh,
you need to actually bring up Marxist Leninism. It's like, oh,
so we need to do this entire like 10-minute disaval anytime we
want to talk to the Vanguard. If the Vanguard's coming on, we
need to have included in the video. They believe in Marx Marxist
Leninism. And actually, we can't we can't allow any of that at
all. So, we have to debate the economics before we talk about
like whether or not we should vote yes on the $15 minimum wage.
>> So, Pisco Pisco, let me tell you about this. Okay, this
is my problem. This actually and it it's indicative of this entire
2 and a half hour conversation.
What I'm saying is that there are authoritarian dissident freaks
on the far left and on the right. And on the right, the dissident
right-wing freaks have infected and destroyed the party that
I was a part of. 55% of the party that I identified with growing
up is now dead because of these monsters. And so when I look
to the left and I see a bunch of normie liberals, capitalists,
all this playing footsy with revolutionary socialists, not >> So
where is the footsie? Can you tell me which position you felt
like we were playing footsy on? Can you tell me other than I
guess basically I I don't know. It's like tone. What is the tonal
thing? >> Only does that turn me. >> Connor, did
you have a tone
off? It turned Hold on. I'm not done yet. Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you for your condescending look and your open mouth. >> Connor
absolutely plays footsies with Lauren Southern. Right. She absolutely
would have played footsies with a bunch of people who are very
very far right. And I don't I don't understand where the criticism
comes from. >> I don't need it right now. Thank you. So
when I see that, I'm going to criticize it because what I don't
want to happen is you and other people like you spending 3 hours
sweeping for the far left and then as a result they become more
powerful and more emboldened. It's indicative in this conversation.
It's indicative in the Vanguard conversation. It's indicative
in the way that you talk about Hassan. It's indicative in the
way that you talk about the far left.
>> it doesn't matter. When people told you about the things
that he's done, you said I don't know that I research it. Anybody
who knows the name Hassan knows half a dozen of the bad
deal. >> Okay. Okay. One one more question before we end.
Destiny. >> Wait, no. I wait. >> We're getting to
the Hassan thing right now. I promise. Let me get to the thing.
I could get to the Hassan thing. You said that you would vote
for, and correct me if I'm wrong, Trump over Hassan. Can >> Can
you explain why? >> Are you asking me? Yeah, you said >> the
issue that I had with that Twitter thread is that like there
there's a meaningful difference and it was like like moving between
all of these at some point in time of are you talking about casting
the deciding vote? Are you talking about who you more ideologically
aligned with? Are you talking about voting for somebody assuming
they would have full control of the party or you talking about
voting for somebody assuming they would have full control of
the party and a full backing of the entire government? Like all
of these questions have different answers. >> Party wins.
Hassan wins with Hassan's party. No, no, no. But I'm saying like
are you saying like if Hassan were to win and was able to enact
a significant portion of his agenda?
>> Then I would vote for Trump easily. That's not even
a question. >> Okay. Why I would give it to Pisco. What
about you? Again, >> I need to I need to listen to this
again. Hold on. >> Some point in time of Are you talking
about casting the deciding vote? Are you talking about who you
more ideologically aligned with? Are you talking about voting
for somebody assuming they would have full control of the party
or you talking about voting for somebody assuming they would
have full control? >> This is never unclear. This is never
ever unclear. and oh it's so >> party and a full backing
of the entire government. Like all of these questions have different
answers. >> Which party wins? Hassan wins with >> Yeah.
No, but I'm saying like are you saying like if Hassan were to
win and was able to enact a significant portion of his agenda?
>> Then I would vote for Trump easily. That's not even
a question. >> Okay. Why? I would give it to Pisco. What
about you again? Trump. >> So I So first let me just clarify
the question as Stephen did. I never intended to ask that question
of Hassan without constraints. I you know I think it's delusional
to think that that's how you initially understood that question
given the fact that embedded in your response your initial response.
>> The other question doesn't make sense.
political power if Assan's irrelevant but he wins political power
then that vote doesn't matter. So how is that your point? So
the conclusion that Stephen was interpreting that question to
be Hassan without constraints is preposterous given the fact
that he was referencing as one of the reasons to vote for Trump
over Hassan in that scenario. Trump's constraints over the Trump
during his constrainted period in the four years he said look
at you know Trump wasn't able to accomplish what he did in those
four years. We haven't you know had a destroyed country. Clearly
he was referencing you know Trump with constraints to Hassan
with with constraints. That's obviously what the question asked.
That's what your people understood when they >> the constraints
on Hassan would be significantly greater though than the constraints
on Trump.
>> No but the whole point is no one was understanding that
question. You included when I initially asked it to mean without
constraint. >> Okay. Wait. So just to be clear then just
to be clear. So, so your question was, would I prefer to elect
Donald Trump into a system today where he has undying
cultlike support from the entire Republican establishment? Okay.
From all the media from the Supreme Court. Would I prefer Donald
Trump to be elected or would I prefer Hassan [__]
who probably like would barely even be able to be sat as president
of the United States? Because even the Democrat party sucks.
>> Wait, no, wait. I want to hear you. That's the question
that you were legitimately asking. >> So, the question
I was asking is the question I was asking is who you would vote
for president of the United States. car carrying all the assumptions
that you would normally take in any of those situations where
>> if there was an election held today, who would you vote
for if which is by the way exactly how you interpreted the >> like
when you're asking who you vote for president? I wasn't implying
obviously
complete dicta dictatorial control. Anyone who thinks that that's
how I >> uh and it's like made very very obvious from tweets
that he did not think this either. that I was >> Were you
implying a similar level of control of what Trump has now?
>> I was implying whatever I I wasn't I was agnostic as
to like Congress.
I was agnostic as to these other >> How can you be agnostic
to that? These are the most important.
>> No, no, no, no, no. But what I wasn't asking and what's
clear that you didn't >> No, no. Don't say what you weren't
asking. What? What was the actual
>> The question was the normal set of assumptions of of
>> There were no normal set of assumptions even a political
figure. He's not. If there's no normal set of assumptions, Destiny,
then why did you just answer? Why did you just answer? If there's
no no normal set of assumptions, then you should have asked clarifying
questions. You don't believe that and you answered the question
directly, which leads me to say, okay, what did you like what
what did you think? And is that going to be consistent with the
way you answered the question? Obviously, you think you understood
it directly, which is why you answered immediately.
But it's so hard. It's so hard in the moment to know you're a
politician. So if I were to ask you who would you vote for Connor
points or Trump, >> how would you answer? You would have
a set a set of assumptions, wouldn't you? >> No, I would
I would ask you for clarification. What do you mean? Like >> Yeah,
we're voting we're voting for a president of the United States
constrained in the normal ways that a president is and >> conrained
in the normal ways like
do no stop. Shut up. It's not being obtuse. Pisco is being obtuse.
I'm asking a very clear and obvious question, right? If you're
talking about what does it mean to vote for somebody and you
say with the normal constraints, the normal constraints earlier,
Hassan wouldn't be elected. So when you So are you talking about
a country that would have the political environment that would
elect here? You know what? Here's a better one. Given the same
constraints of the system, would you rather have Donald Trump
as a president or Stalin as the
>> Yeah, I think probably Trump. Yeah. >> Then you
agree with me? >> Wait, no. I I don't agree with you. >> What
is the grounding of your question? >> I have no evidence.
I have no evidence that Trump that Hassan is like Sullen. >> I
just don't know anything about Yeah. I mean like that's like
that's literally his political >> ideology. Do you want
me to read any evidence? I can read the evidence. >> No,
no, no. In the in the ways that matter in the ways that matter
like Stalin Yeah, I could answer that. >> So So you think
that you think that Stalin and Hassan So Hassan is a genocidal
freak? That's what you think? >> I don't know if I'd say
genocide but is aist like a Marxist Leninist. Yes. >> No,
no, but but he's not similar. Do you think that Hassan would
enact a genocide in this country?
>> Yes. Yes. What's your evidence that What's your evidence
that Hassan would enact genocide in this country?
Leninist because when other vanguard parties have come into power
like in China and the Soviet Union, they ended up having genocide.
Just to be clear, >> you think that you think that is pro
genocide in this country. >> You realize
>> and to be clear, it has to be more pro genocide than
somebody like Fentesto, I guess, for Destiny to argue not that
you can't platform them platform them. You shouldn't have them
on your platform. And definely went had ice cream with Fuentes,
right? So there has to be more genocidal than
we're pro- genocide. That's it's that's a stupid question. You're
trying to do this after no on complicated liberations. You don't
understand any of the politics.
Do you think that Stalin was pro genocide? Yes or no? Just >> yes.
Yes.
>> No. Wait. Wait. Conor. Connor. You agree with me that
was proide? Correct. >> That's great. He's a Republican.
I
Holy [__] I can actually answer questions unlike
yous. Yeah, Stalin wanted to the out of the Ukrainians. However,
Pisco, what I'll answer directly to you is that I think if Hassan
No, I'm pretty sure Hassan is literally Joseph Stalin. Dude,
this is actually where these people have gone to. Like, this
is where it's gone straight. Also, I don't know if you saw, uh,
you need to go watch this clip from like 17 minutes onwards,
and we need to all point out that this is just clearly clip chimp.
You literally you literally cut out specifically that you want
like so so slow social change towards Marxism and the allegation
they made was that you're advocating for the murder of the capital
class. Just so you know, I sent it to you in Discord like uh
it's it's just silly. It's just very silly. >> Was put
into power the same way that Stalin was. He 100% would create
thought crimes. He 100% would incarcerate people without trial.
He would 100% do mass executions of ideological enemies, namely
capitalists.
>> And I have Yeah. He said he wants to kill all the landlords.
>> He said he wants to kill the landlord. >> Not
just that. I literally have in preparation for this debate. I
wrote >> I'll ask you I'll ask you I'll ask you Connor
Connor. If Trump had total power and he had no checks, do you
think he would political rivals? >> Oh yeah, 100%. >> Yeah,
100%. So what's the what's the disparity there? >> Okay.
Okay. Okay. Hold on. I I want an >> What are the what are
the motivations behind fascism and communism? What draws somebody
towards fascism versus communism? Fascism is usually communism.
You can argue there is a push towards communism from an empathetic
point, right? That is how that is why communism is in fact insidious,
right? It takes advantage of people's empathy. People usually
are fairly good people who get pulled into like socialist or
communist things. I want things for everybody. I want everybody
to be happy.
Where is that element in fascism? Where is the element in fascism
where you're like, I want everybody to be happy. So, we need
badass arguments. We need bad Sorry, we need badass uniforms.
and we need to crack some skulls. Like it's the clear difference
between both, right? >> This question because I feel like
you guys are talking past. >> Unironically, unironically,
I think I truly believe that Adam friended would have been better
in this conversation than some of possibly like a at least for
this part of the conversation, right? Cuz he's read the uh the
Jonathan Heights stuff and he would explain why you would consider
like ideological communists or ideological socialists very different
from ideological fascists. There is no there's no empathy, right?
There's no empathy in Donald Trump. Selective empathy. Sure.
Selective empathy. Yes. So I guess racism, ethnoism, something
like that. >> I guess we're back. Sure. The selective empathy.
Yeah. Yeah. I agree with this. >> Trump right now we have
some he's a cult-like leader within the >> But I think
usually that selective empathy comes from what what could be
you could argue would have to come from a perceived like persecution,
right? And the tangibility of that persecution is probably relevant
to how empathetic you actually are. If you're like an old white
man in the United States and you feel persecuted to the point
that you think fascism is the answer, you are probably like a
delusional totally like self victimizing narcissist, right? >> The
Republican party, but he does have some institutional checks
on his power. >> For the sake of the hypothetical, for
the sake of the hypothetical, I presume, >> not to argue
that Hassan is not a totally delusional self- victimizing narcissist,
by the way. assumed in order for Hassan to be of similar power,
he would have a similar situation. He's not in total control.
We still have Republican checks on the limits of his power, but
he has a cult-like following within the left. Okay, that's what
I presume. And what I would say is that his sense of isolationism,
his sense of proterrorism, his sense of wanting to backstab the
Western world, him hating mixed economy capitalism, capitalism,
I think he would be just as large of a danger or more of a danger
than uh Donald Trump. And I can back that up
>> Okay. I mean, I disagree. >> Said like 50 times
he's a Marxist Lenist. Like it sounds like openly said >> Hang
on a second. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Destiny. Destiny,
you love Destiny. You acknowledge you acknowledge that I never
said he wasn't a Marxist Leninist. >> But that's basically
that's essentially like the blueprint for what Stalin did. Yes.
It's the over he's on the program like championing like Lenin's
literature like overthrowing states. >> Stephen, I never
said he wasn't a Marxist Leninist. And when I was talking, I
I so I want to address because you put a video of it where I
was like addressing uh some people who are following Hassan and
getting his clips um basically where they were talking about
this reeducation camps. And what was told to me is this is an
example of Hassan explicitly in favor of re-education camps.
I want to be clear about something. I have now seen the clips
of Hassan calling himself a Marxist Leninist. People have brought
that to my attention. I asked these people, "Do you have clips
of himself calling himself a Marxist Leninist? What's the evidence?
What's the strongest evidence?" At no point and there's even
something where explicitly I said this did I say Hassan wasn't
a Marxist Lunist and I just want to repeat for like the 10th
time I do not like Hassan he does and I think you think he's
the significant what would the significant difference between
his administration and Stalin's
>> because I I do think that Hassan if we want Lennon and
>> no Stalin no do Stalin
Stalin because I yeah so so I think the key distinctions are
I think that if you take a look at their different personalities
that Stalin seems like a worse overall has worse people on his
ear. I think that uh Hassan has some friends who I think are
generally like good people. People like Adam um Freriedland people
>> here's a question first of all. >> So Connor actually
sorry I'm like I'm actually on Twitter now. I'm in like Twitter
mode. So Connor says the closest I've heard from clips is you
allow Kiwi Farm schizophrenics into the into the Discord to hang
out and commentary community plays footsie with them. So it's
like hey I've literally asked for evidence of this repeatedly.
Nobody provides any evidence of this brother. What are we doing?
Nobody provides any evidence for their allegation. I can't moderate
it. I am totally hamstrung. I don't even have a clear allegation
of
>> Let me let me let me let me finish. Let me finish. >> I'm
pulling this back a little bit. I'm like I'm twittering more
than I am actually looking at this stuff. So, hold on. I'm I'm
going to pause for a second. Sorry. I'm uh I'm I'm But he has
a cult-like following within the left. Okay, that's what I presume.
And what I would say is that his sense of isolationism, his sense
of proterrorism, his sense of wanting to backstab the Western
world, him hating mixed economy capitalism and capitalism, I
think he would be just as large of a danger or more of a danger
than uh Donald Trump. And I can back that up factually.
>> Okay. I mean, I just >> said like 50 times he's
a Marcus Lennon. Like it sounds like openly said that. >> Hang
on a second. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Destiny. Destiny,
you acknowledge Destiny, you acknowledge You
>> but that's basically that's essentially like the blueprint
for what Stalin did. Yes. It's the over he's on the program like
championing like Lenin's literature like overthrowing states.
>> Stephen I never said he wasn't a Marxist Leninist and
when I was talking I so I want to address cuz you put a video
of it where I was like addressing uh some people who are following
Hassan and getting his clips. >> Um basically where they
were talking about this reeducation camps and what was told to
me is this is an example of Hassan explicitly in favor of reeducation
camps. I want to be clear about something. I have now seen the
clips of Hassan calling himself a Marxist Leninist. People have
brought that to my attention. I asked these people, "Do you have
clips of himself?" >> Yeah. Pisco is never ever arguing
over whether or not he was a Marxist Leninist. He was saying,
"Hey, in this specific instance, when you say when you cite this
clip, right, you're citing a clip that does not say what you're
saying it says." I don't and I said this as well. I don't doubt
there are clips of Assan actually doing communism. I don't doubt
that. I actually fully believe it. But I'm saying this clip right
now is totally disingenuous. It is totally bad faith. Right?
Obviously, it is obviously bad faith. The fact that Hassan in
another clip called himself a Marxist Leninist does not change
the fact that the clip was taken in out of context and was used
in a bad faith manner to maliciously slander him. That is what
it was used for, right? That was the obvious goal >> of
calling himself a Marxist Leninist. What's the evidence? What's
the strongest evidence? At no point, and there's even something
where explicitly I said this, >> I'm sorry. I'm sorry to
cut this off for you guys again. I know we have 700 viewers here
right now, but I just want to point out that once again on Twitter,
I am I'm just going to keep calling people out. Hey, if we have
totally baseless allegations, I need somebody to come and actually
say what they think has happened here. Okay, I responded to Connor
just now. Uh he says, so I'm saying, hey, you have to give me
a solid allegation so I can do something, right? So, I just responded
to him on my profile here, right? Repeatedly asked both publicly
and privately via you for any evidence of this. Doctors are banned.
Links to KF are banned in my community. Nobody is showing any
evidence that I can moderate for. How am I supposed to act with
a totally baseless allegation like this? Destiny's baseline for
the Catholic and manifesto was, "Show me the bad behavior and
I'll moderate anyone doing it." That is my standard here. If
anyone has a better approach, please let me know. Nobody will
show me any evidence of the allegations being made. These people
are just making things up. They're just totally making things
up. Just like they're making things up about Straight Raid, just
like they're making things up about Pisco. It is just malicious
lying. And I'm really I'm just sick of it. Okay, no, he can't
get away with it anymore. Okay, so I'm just going to keep calling
Destiny is a spineless loser. He can't post any evidence. He
won't post any evidence. He's just going to keep running away
like he ran from Pisco like a whiny this entire conversation.
Refused to take any moral positions. Okay, that is what it is.
All right, he's just a complete. Everyone who supports this guy,
Connor, you are a [__] Okay, you are a complete.
You support this guy trying to destroy a bunch of people around
me. You are a complete too. Aerodite is a complete. You people
have no spines. You have no principles. You are losers. Anyway,
we'll go back. >> Did I say Hassan wasn't a Marxist Linist?
And I just want to repeat for like the 10th time I do not like
Hassan. He does. And I think you think he's What would the significant
difference between his administration and Stalin's? >> Well,
because I I do think that Hassan if we want Lennon and No, Stalin.
No, >> do Stalin because I Yeah. So, so I think the key
distinctions are I think that if you take a look at the different
personalities that Stalin seems like a worse overall person,
has worse people on his ear. I think that uh Hassan has some
friends who I think are generally like good people. People like
Adam um
>> Okay, here's a question. First of all, let me let me
let me let me let me finish. Let me finish. And then in terms
of ideology
wait I think you agree
part of >> Wait, the who are the politicians Hassan's most
likely to put in his cabinet? Aren't they people you said would
you'd have in your coalition, Destiny? Aren't these people you
said you'd vote for? Bernie Sanders, Zora Mandani, AOC. Aren't
these the people that Hassan would most closely associate with
in terms of politicians?
I I think culturally he's much more likely to >> Wait,
hold on. Resnav this. Trust me, I'm getting a contest today for
the dumbest comments that could be made. Everyone is me hiding
behind PFP. Your comedy is unmatched. Wait, do you think I'm
saying they're a because they're like scared to fight IRL or
do you think I'm saying they're because they're making allegations
with no backing to them? Which one do you think is more likely?
Go ahead. >> To be more moderate um in terms of the genocidal
stuff that Stalin was able to get away with because >> apparently
you think I'm trying to like fight people IRL and I'm like look
this is me. This is what I look like. Fight me IRL. That's not
happening. >> This the American culture that he's a part
of. And >> Pisco is actually making the argument you made.
Jtock Hassan is fundamentally not enough of an evil person to
truly enact his policies. Well, truly enact I I just don't think
like I've seen evidence of who he is as a person, right? And
it's he is a consumerrist. He's he's doesn't believe sincerely
in these things. Absolutely not. >> So there and I think
also by the way >> probably he gets shot in the head and
over and usurped in some in some version of the world where Hassan
sees his power, right? He would be the naive idiot who gets shot
in the head and somebody else who's actually Makavelian would
take over, right? Ah I don't want Hassan shot. I'm obviously
not advocating for violence against Hassan. I'm saying that Hassan
is like the naive idiot who gets it socialism enacted, okay,
and then gets done away with.
>> You know, in the context, if we're actually putting
real constraints on it, I think the military and the police would
be less much less apt to do abuses under a Hassan administration
than they would under Trump. >> Here's a question. If Assan
was the president of the United States and he could push a button
and say Israel has become a one state right now, that will probably
lead to a genocide there until the majority of them leave. Do
you think that he would push that button? >> Wait, push
a button to do what? Sorry. to turn Israel Palestine into a single
state that would probably result in the next 5 years of some
genocide or genocidal campaign against there until all of them
basically leave. Do you think it's time to push that button?
>> Yes. Would you push the button of for Israel's conduct
right now? Do you support Israel conduct right now?
>> Okay. So you So, >> but also this isn't about
me.
Trump is Trump is willing Trump is willing to Trump is willing
to abide. Trump is >> Would you vote for Trump or destiny
as president
now? >> I would vote for Destiny. I'm I'm honest. I No,
wait. Hey, but but hold on. You just said that Stalin being genocidal
was a key differentiator between him and Hassan. So Hassan would
be genocidal in some cases, right? Depending on who the people
are. He probably to Polish people, right? He said much you're
asking >> No, he said he thought Polish people were Do
you think Hassan's going to kill all the Down syndrome people?
>> He's like joked about how low IQ Hungarians and polls
are. >> In a context in which the for Hassan the trade-off
is genocide, the current genocide, he views it as a current genocide.
What's what's going on in Gaza? And you know I guess the question
would just be like which you know genocide is entailed no matter
what. >> Sure. And for Stalin it was do we have enough
crops to feed the people in do we have enough people >> but
in terms of the intern I think there is a significant difference
in terms of the internal potentiality for a genocide. And I just
want to be clear about something. I don't support police. So
let's get to the prescription. I am not trying to build a bridge
with Assan. I don't ideology. I'm not protecting.
How how am I protecting? >> If you okay if you want to
run the last topic. So like at this point in time, do you admit
that there is absolutely zero evidence whatsoever that there
was any kind of discriminatory activity towards him in his whole
TSA adventure and then he lied? >> No. Wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait. So I agree he lied, but you and I both agree, didn't
you? Didn't you agree that the main reason the most probable
thing that happened on anything else you said this was that viewpoint
discrimination played a role in his rejection of you did say
that. You said it. We have it on record. >> No, no, we
were right here. Talk to me. What was the viewpoint discrimination?
Yeah, you No, I'm saying what you said. What you said was you
need to say what I said. You need to call me for two months ago.
If you want me Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait. You don't need to
call me for two months ago. I'm right here. Uh, wait. Should
we bring straight around? No, no, no. I I have to run. I have
to I'm not going to be here for straight raid. Wow.
So, so honest, so consistent. What a good person. What an awesome
guy. Oh my goodness.
>> You said something that you said something something
that Hassan said. It's so transparent. It's so transparent, dude.
It's so embarrassing. >> Was the most likely reason that
he was denied or had his entry. >> That's not viewoint
discrimination, though. That's not viewoint discrimination. That's
content discrimination. If you talk about politicians, if you
talk about
do you think that Do you think that if talked about Democrats
or whatever that he also wouldn't have been flagged maybe >> Hold
on. But the whole point here is that Pisco is favorable to Democrats.
All Piss has to say is I literally gave the same pass to Nick
Fentes. Like I don't think I don't think Nick Fentes for any
political speech should ever be struck from flying anywhere.
Like I don't believe any of this stuff should happen. That's
all he has to say. It doesn't matter. You disagree on that point.
That's not where the disagreement is. Or sorry, that's not where
like any of this is. The whole point of this debate is Pisco
is way too nice to lefties. Pisco does not just extend the same
charity to lefties. Yes, it's a free speech issue. Yes, he's
saying I grant this to everybody. If Nick Fentes was in the same
issue, I would rent this same charity to Nick Fuentes despite
how disgusting I find his beliefs. >> Global Entry if he
had a tweet blow up about having a a Democratic bill. >> I'm
not sure for the purpose of this.
You said you were 100% vindicated.
I am I am I am vindicated on that. I am vindicated. I'm saying
I'm not sure as between a Democratic candidate my my um what
I think would probably happen is that no, he wouldn't be. I don't
know is the answer to that. I I truly don't know. But then what's
the viewoint
>> Let me let me talk about this. Right. So contentbased
restrictions are also subject to strict scrutiny. Do you know
>> Yes, they can be. But viewoint
means even stricter is even stricter. Viewoint discrimination
is almost never going to pass because you're not just saying
you can't see my
>> So Desi is just yelling over Pisco. I've still not heard
Pisco's point. >> A certain type of
>> This guy got a lot of his [__] swallowed
today. Yeah, if
he wouldn't have had >> he's fueled up. He's ready to go.
>> That is my inclination. But regardless, it doesn't matter.
It's overdeetermined. When I say it's over determined, I mean
it doesn't matter. Like content based restrictions are subject
to strict scrutiny. And for law,
you
global entry. I'm not sure. Let's be clear. Let's just be clear
about something. You did agree into that something he said before
was the most likely reason that he had global entry revoked.
Correct. >> Yes. Do you agree that you can say things that
maybe would make it worth it to have your Google entry revoked?
>> Yes, there there are certain things you could say that
would have it. Okay. But >> do you think that one of those
might be talking about a politician? >> Well, it depends
if that is a tr if it is a truth or not. If it's a true threat.
No. So, for example, so for example, so if someone takes something
that you said, Stephen, if someone says something that you said
and like what you said, for example, uh about some of >> Let
me stupid. If I got an email and I found out that I got kicked
out of Global Entry. See? See? Uhhuh. This is This is unfortunate.
Pisco is letting him Pisco's letting him go. Pisco is correct
here, but he's not going to he's not going to hammer through
that he's >> because of what I said about >> he's
he's just he's like uh I think he's slowly coming to realize
that oh, like everything I ever thought about this person, right?
Everything I ever thought about this person is actually incorrect.
I have to totally reevaluate. It's a feeling, man. It sucks.
It sucks.
It's a >> firefighter to whatever. I'd probably be like,
"Eh, sure." Yeah. No. You think you think I'm going to go on
the internet? You think I'm You think I'm going to be like, "Oh,
I can't believe that I can't make death threats about people
and they're going to kick me out of the expedited security screening
>> What if they denied you what if they denied you a gun
on the base of that >> That would be much different. That's
a much stronger Wait, wait. You're talking about Hold on. You're
talking about Hold on. No. Pisco Pisco is going to walk him down
this dialogue tree. >> Constitutionally guaranteed right.
We're not even
>> too many on the internet think freedom of speech means
freedom from consequences. Uh, this is possibly God. You guys
are like in a full-on contest all day to say the most things
you can. The government has to obey the constitution. The government
cannot silence political speech. That is that is just factual.
This is a government privilege, idiot. Yes, the government cannot
inflict consequences on you for your speech. Sorry, there are
there are I think two or three car votes there. There are two
or three car votes for that. This is not one of them. >> So,
let's move up. So, let's move on. So, what about a driver's license
then?
>> Why not? >> This is not This is not >> No,
Kingler. It's not airlines. The airlines can't detain people.
Kingler 92. Do you think the airlines can detain people at the
airport? You think they gave that to private companies, the ability
to dain to detain random citizens? I am so lost. I am so I'm
so lost. I'm so lost. This is all part of the same government
organization. Was it the Customs and Border Patrol CBP? >> Not
relevant. What part of what evidence do we have that Hassan was
discriminated against for like a view for a political reason
for something that we wouldn't ordinarily expect somebody to
be kicked out of an expedited security screening program for?
Do we have any evidence to that whatsoever? Yes. >> So
I think Yeah. Yeah. Yes. The fact that the the most likely statement
that you've attributed and which I probably agree is like either
the Risk Rick Scott comment or the comments on the Houthies in
the in Palestine and and Israel. I take all of those to be content
based restriction viewpoint discrimination that would be insidious
and unwardly
supporting you think of somebody outwardly supporting a terrorist
group that's declined that's declared as a terrorist group that
they shouldn't be allowed to be removed from expedited airport
security screening. >> Yes. Yes. Yeah. Yes. Yes. So let
me ask you the question. Wait, let me ask you the question. So
with respect to a driver's license, do you think that >> I'm
not this is not >> you're not going to answer. Wait wait
wait. So, so, so I'm going to ask you to talk about Wait, wait.
So, you want to
I'm going to ask the question like
>> Yeah, sure. Jerry, give me the the time
>> Pivot. I dodged your pivot. I dodged the pivot. I do
pivot. I do. >> I dodged the pivot. >> Let's I can
already see. I've already seen this entire conversation. I'm
going to say, "Oh, good driver's license." Every time Pisco has
tried to clarify, every time Pisco has tried to hold Destiny
to like actually answer a question that's tangible to the the
debate, Wick gives him the ability to move on, right? Connor
jumps in. When when Pisco goes to talk, not a word from Wick
is a writer. What is that? Oh, it's a privilege. Wait, wait,
wait.
>> He's literally not even saying anything. He's not saying
anything tangible right
I already entire argument and I can already see how [__]
[__] is
already admitted that you don't think somebody should be kicked
off of an >> uh this is you. So now Piss goes behind on
the talking. He should have been talking this entire time, right?
When Destiny goes to try to frame out the yes or no question
thing when he goes, "Oh, it's totally sped of you to to do the
yes or no thing." Oh, I guess you're just gonna do the that Pisco
should have done. Oh, you're just gonna spur out. Keep spurging
out. Right. Unfortunately, you got to watch Andrew Wilson sometimes.
Okay, Andrew Wilson has this has this down to a tea. Go spur
out. Just totally spur out your right now, but it's fine. I'll
just I'll just let you finish. I'll let you punch yourself out
like a sped you are. You go ahead. Yeah. Yeah. Nobody respects
you. Nobody respects you when you do this. I'm willing to have
a real conversation. You're a loser, right? That's what you have
to do. Unfortunately, Andrew Wilson knows how to play this game.
Pisco will learn. Why? Because Pisco is motivated. Pisco is smart.
Pisco is devoted. He will he will get this down to a science.
Trust me. Are you done? Are you done? Spuring line. Andrew does
is perfect. Yeah. Andrew absolutely just like talks down to him.
And Andrew lost to a pickle jar. Irrelevant to the current conversation.
Irrelevant to the current conversation.
Well, true. Irrelevant. Okay. Expedited security list on on an
That's crazy.
That's all I got on it. I'm good. I'm good. So Destiny says he
didn't agree with Pisco at all. that that like it was probably
like speech persecution or that that the big >> Destiny
says he doesn't agree that the reason Hassan was pulled out of
the line was due to his political speech
Hassan has completely made up this entire story to try and rehabilitate
his if I had to guess I actually believe the Trump administration
that Hassan has made up this entire experience >> well
I don't think she probably didn't even ask she probably just
assumed they followed procedure I doubt she pulled any specific
details >> no I believe them I I think I think Hassan has
fabricated the entirety of this I don't think any of this is
justify true belief question of epistemic justification. Listen,
they could be correct, but it doesn't mean that they actually
possess knowledge that they're correct about the thing. >> I
possess one piece of knowledge. >> Hassan has lied and
been about one part of this so far. So the justific >> they
could be correct. Hold on. Hold on. Let me >> The entirety
of this I don't think any >> this is a justified true belief
question of epistemic justification. Listen, they could be correct,
but it doesn't mean that they actually possess knowledge that
they're correct about the thing. >> I possess one piece
of knowledge. What >> Hassan has lied and been about one
part of this so far. So the justification is that he has lied
about more parts. >> I understand. I'm just saying this
is a classic JTB. Okay. I don't know who that >> Stands
for justified true belief. Let's say that a ball rolls down the
hill and somebody says, "I know there's a ball at the bottom
of the hill because I saw the ball roll down the hill, but somebody
ran up and grabbed the ball and ran away, but there was another
ball down the hill. Just because they believe there's a ball
down a hill and there is a ball down the hill doesn't necessarily
mean that they were correct about >> Why do I keep doing
like why do I keep >> saying you saying that they were
right even if they were right doesn't mean they were right. Do
you understand? >> Hassan bad. >> Yes. Okay. Okay.
God, my brain is so >> I'm You don't have to answer it.
You don't have to answer it. I'm just going to put it out there.
So, this is the question. Should because of the support for a
terrorist organization, should someone be denied a driver's license?
Because a driver's license is not a right. It is a privilege.
It's purely at the discretion of the state if it wanted to can
kick you off a driver's license for something trivial, for, you
know, for a parking offense, for anything really. You know, there
are tons of different restrictions that don't have to be uh,
you know, totally tailored. Wait, let me So, >> totally
tailored. Wait, wait. What is strict scrutiny entail, Pisco?
Yeah. Yeah. You need a compelling person.
>> Wait. What would the compelling interest to deny somebody
a driver's license? What would be the compelling reason to deny
a driver's license? Because they put a terrorist group. >> I
don't have it because I think it's on all for I don't have it
because it's on force. Yeah. What is it? >> The fact that
it might make them somebody who's worth screening in the ordinary
manner they screen people to come back to the United States.
>> Wait, but I thought this I don't even think Pisco actually
Wait, is there any reason to believe that Pisco thinks the screening
is the incorrect procedure here? The screening. Oh, it's not
as bad. The screening isn't the incorrect procedure here, right?
The screening is totally fine because his global entry was revoked.
The actual downside, the actual negative enforcement on his political
speech is the revocation of the global fastpass, right? That's
actually what it is. >> Hang on a second. Hang on. So,
as a security threat, it is a compelling purpose for for global
entry, but as a security threat, it's not a compelling purpose
for a driver's license. Explain >> Because I think that
there are a lot of people that can have some kind of support
for terrorists or whatever that can drive in a car. I think that
the uh >> Oh, what's the most common form of terrorist
attack in the in the country of Germany? Destiny, what's what's
that exactly?
Are you Destiny? What happened in Waca? Wasa. Destiny. Hello.
Is there not a compelling reason? Hello. >> Other side
of the citizen for having a driver's license driving around just
because you have a support or whatever for some terrorist. >> He
just realized that there could be like a compelling reason. It
seems like it's a fairly obvious. Hey, same reason we might screen
them for a firearm,
>> Revoke your driver's license. I don't think that
>> dung devil what what you require to be a part of that
fastpass is basically irrelevant because there are protected
things that they cannot revoke any benefit from you for right
like if you are saying I I believe in like this dem in this uh
political movement right they cannot revoke a government thing
that is I believe protected right they can't invoke something
to do with the government here so it's it's literally any it's
one blade of grass not one thing can be revoked for this reason.
Right? So dung devil the entire the the hypothetical uses to
drive this home is basically if they revoked global fastpass
because from all black people because they have an increased
propensity to commit crime that would be a security reason. They
wouldn't be they would be like basically there would be some
reasoning whether they're justified or not to think they're a
less trustworthy person. Would it be justified or okay for us
to remove or revoke global fastpass from all black people? The
answer obviously is no.
terrorist cars. Islamic terrorists use cars that kill people
just like they used the other part of the strict scrutiny analysis
that you said narrowly tailored. Do you think that revoking a
driver's license for somebody is as narrowly tailored as not
allowing somebody on an expedited security list? >> Well,
can someone travel?
>> Oh, yeah. Exactly. No, correct. Make it more comparable.
If you were to talk about banning him from all airline travel,
I'd say, well, now hold on. Now we've got that is not narrowly
tail. Now we're talking about something completely different.
If you wanted to compare this to going in an expedited line at
a DMV to skip the ordinary background check, then sure, maybe
we could talk. If you support terrorists, you don't get the expedited
DMV line. But to talk about just having a driver's license, so
then then basically if there was a reason to remove these these
uh what do you call it? These privileges from black people, you'd
have to argue that yes, that's totally okay. If you had if you
had a reason and it was a strict like a narrowly tailored penalty
on these people, it would be okay even if it is a racist motivation,
which Destiny obviously wouldn't argue. And Pisco will probably
make him bite that bullet. Maybe, maybe not. expedited screening
list. That is not correct because you're right for strict scrutiny
has to be narrowly tailored on a compelling state interest and
I believe that it is narrowly tailored to >> so Destiny
has to agree here. He will have to agree with the black off with
a compelling state interest.
>> No, it's not. But their speech is >> Destiny is
going to spur so hard trying to run from the black people hypothetically.
They're not they're not making their speech illegal. They're
not crafting a law against the speech in any case, shape or form.
No, they're not. They're just not security list driver's license
and you know that so respect to Muslims if you had a ban and
just to finish this respect the Muslims who you know have a you
would agree a higher incidence of Islamic terrorism correct
>> they might yeah probably dude every single one of these
has to be clipped together for Pisco asking a direct obvious
yes question of Islamic terror well yeah there might be some
like
there might be some like connection between Muslims and Islamic
Ter maybe maybe they might maybe maybe dude he is such a oh my
god who who takes this person seriously
>> definitely
I don't know if that's true or not
>> see Bisco's got to work on his sewing out over this
right like this is a totally disingenuous
loser there's no reason for me even to share a stage with him
like this is this is actually such a fall it's such a catastrophic
fall from who everybody thought this person was so
Don't nationalist terrorism in the United States. I'm [__]
Muslim. >> Bruce Willis, I didn't see anything like this.
I've never seen anything like this from him before. And I I want
people to basically show me where he's done anything like this
in the past where it has been 15 times in the same debate he's
done the same move. Maybe one time in a debate that's like 3
hours long, right? But in this in this like like 15 times, 20
times, there's no way. Anybody link me a debate and I will listen.
and I'll uh I'll PayPal you 50 bucks if you can find me something
that's comparable to this 50 bucks.
>> Yeah. So so but specifically Okay. So let's say white
nationalist. Do you think it would be acceptable to say white
nationalists need not apply for global entry? >> The depend
if it was like something like let's say it was like the Proud
Boys. >> I'm not going to I'm not going to watch it. You
want me to pay you 50 bucks? You're going to go find every time
stamp. I need like I need 10 to 15 minimum of these things where
he goes oh I'm not sure about that. >> Yeah. That's probably
Yeah. For expedited security screening probably.
I've already said that. I've already said that my comments online
and I even joke about it that if my global Yeah, I get it. Yeah,
it's global. >> That's not the question. That's not the
question. That's not the question. >> Regardless of this,
we have a different opinion about the right here. I'm not being
un if I'm just like a hedge of a two week vindication
that you're totally right on this. >> We have a disagreement.
So, so, so, so Stephen, you and I have this disagreement about
how much the right should protect, what we're okay with in term
of view discrimination. None of this is saying that we have to
be unhinged with respect to giving Hassan a pass. I have a more
protective view of the First Amendment than you do in this specific
instance. Why isn't that not an honest disagreement? Why does
it have to become I'm being a, you know, poster boy for Hassan?
Why does it honest? Because because an honest disagreement would
say I think that maybe you should be able to support or give,
you know, verbal support over terrorist organizations and I don't
think this is a good reason to kick somebody off of an expedited
screening list. But that wasn't your position. Your position
was he was explicitly targeted by the government because of speech
that he's made in order to kick him off the list just to harass
him individually. >> You know, so so you you agree with
that, but you just think that you have a different sense of of
whether that's okay or not. You agree with that factual component
that it's the most likely outcome and you just >> But your
thing was you said you your your interpretation was he was explicitly
and specifically targeted because of stuff that you thought was
like clearly violent of
we don't even >> So the disagreement is whether or not
the first amendment protects that speech. That's the disagreement.
But he says he would give that that same thing. Okay. He would
give that exact same trust or or that exact same charity to Nick
Fuentes versus Hassan, right? >> Oh, so he but he did.
>> I would give I would have gone boy and counterpoints
a chance to leave if if this is what we're going to do. >> Well,
sure. Here, I just a question. Wait, wait, wait. Just one final
question. What evidence could there be? Like, could it have been
a random screening cuz it was 20 minutes long and nothing happened?
You agree that nothing bad happened besides him getting asked
a question for 20 minutes? >> When you say when you say
could, what do you mean? Do you mean like could it like logically
is it possible that yes
possible? I think it's way more likely that that his stop at
the global entry line had to do because his global entry was
revoked. Do you agree?
>> What? What? Isn't that like obviously? Wait, what? No,
I think that's basically everybody agrees on that, right? That
he was stopped because his global entry was revoked. That's why
they stopped him. Hey, you're in a line that you don't have a
pass for. No.
No. No. I think that being in global global entry, >> is
the moderator going to point out the clear and obvious like thing
that was just said and just say, "Hey, Dusty, I think you misspoke."
Is Whit following this or >> when you don't have global
entry that you're and you're being stopped? It's most likely
because you don't have global entry, right? >> You want
have you ever traveled internationally before?
>> Dude, what is he saying?
Hey, you tried to go through the fastpass line. You don't have
You've had your fastpass revoked. The most likely reason they
stopped you is because you tried to go through the line for which
the pass you used to have has been revoked. Um, have you even
flown Have you even flown internationally before? >> Yes.
Yes, I have. >> If you go to the wrong line, they don't
pull you aside for 20 minutes of questioning. They tell you to
go to the other line.
>> I don't know why you think going into the global entry
line, oh, we got to pull this guy aside for expedited questioning.
They would just say, hey, you don't go to the other line. >> Uh,
it seems like they might have checked in this line very effectively
and realized they might have let him through. Like there could
have been so many other concerns there. I'm guessing if they
So, how here's the question. Why if that if that was the case,
the the question isn't Hold on. Then why didn't they Hold on.
Then why didn't they if they were just going to say go to the
other line, then why didn't they? His global Nobody disputes
that his global entry was revoked. So where was the person scanning
it? Or was there like some kind of error that hey, you're in
the wrong line. Yeah, we're going to pull you aside. How did
you get here?
>> So uh give me a two sentence summary of the debate.
Uh, liberals and well actually progressives are being told dumb
asses for socialists. >> Gang gang. Um, this is >> Sorry.
Destiny just said, "Oh, well, they're not going to pull him aside."
Did they go Oh, well, even though he's in the Apparently there
was no scan before to go, "Oh, he's in the wrong line, right?
There's no there's no there's no investigation that would go
on there for why this guy got through with the wrong line. >> This
has been a this has been his point is that he never got the Global
Entry." No, that's not true. We have Hassan's emails showing
he had global entry. We have everything showing that you um right,
we have evidence showing that he had global entry granted to
him and that he had it revoked as well.
>> Sure. We're going to give the mic to each of these individuals.
>> He ended up in a place he wasn't supposed to be. That's
probably why he got pulled aside >> to give closing statements
and
uh where you can find them. >> Yeah, that's obviously gentle
will is exactly that's exactly what I feel like has to have happened,
right? Because obviously if it's revoked then he would be sent
to the other line. How is he let through? Like that is that is
immediately concerned. >> I have links to all their stuff
in my YouTube description. If you've enjoyed the show for whatever
reason, hit that like button. Hit that subscribe button. Um we
do stuff like this all the time. It's very fun. Um I'm going
to keep streaming after. They can stay if they want. They can
leave if they want. I don't care. I have some things to say,
but we're going to give it first to Counter Points. Then we're
going to let Pisco have the last word and we'll just go around.
Go ahead. Counter points. >> Yeah. Uh, I think I would
personally if I were Pisco, I'd never agree to a panel with like
this group of people again, right? You want to have a conversation,
we're going to do it one-on-one. So, you can't have somebody
off in the corner for you, right? We're have that. And I don't
know if I would want
I don't know if I Dude, when Pisco sees that clip of Aaron, he's
going to
lose it, right? He is going to I would lose it. I would lose
it. Oh, boy. So, I came into this conversation hoping to discuss
the fact that I feel like progressives are sometimes useful idiots
for socialists. Uh, I also had a pretty clear definition of socialism
that I asserted half a dozen times. Instead, I got accused of
being a conspiracy nut and uh that I didn't know history. I feel
like I've consistently demonstrated that I have a decent command
of history. I also think I have a decent command of the definitions.
And while uh I am a fan of Pisco and Econo Boy, despite, you
know, maybe any mean words that I said tonight, I do feel like
they're being usefully stupid for infinitely more nefarious characters.
And uh that that's the position I started with. >> Guys,
if you're over on the Twitch stream tonight, if you're over on
the Twitch stream, we're going to end the Twitch stream. Guys,
if you like the content, go ahead, throw a couple bucks my way.
You can get more hours on the stream. All right. Um you can donate
through Twitch. You can give subs on Twitch. You can sub with
your primers over on Twitch. You can give subs through kick.
You can sub on kick. Kick's a 955 split. Okay. Way better money
split for me. So, if you're going to sub and you just want to
add more time, sub on kick, okay? Uh, you can donate through
the TTS mechanisms. Exclamation point. Donate the chat. We'll
show you both. There's Kickbot, there's Streamlabs. All right.
$3 minimum on Streamlabs. $2 minimum on Kickbot. There's also
the Patreon. Patreon.com/jstk
guys. Go sign up. Go give me money. It's important. It's imperative
that you give me money. Okay? It's imperative. You got to you
got to fight the power. I don't know who the power is. fight
future perspective homelessness, which I am absolutely at risk
of. Okay, throw me some money. Add more time to the stream. Really
appreciate all of you. Thank you all for being here. All right,
we'll maybe watch some of the follow-ups with Pisco and everybody
else, see how they feel about it. All right. Um, but I'm going
to end on Twitch and we'll see you guys over on kick. So, have
a good one, guys. Good night. Uh, if you guys want to fight at
a later date or time, I'm happy to do so. And then if you want
to find me, Counterpoints 40k is my main channel. That's my Warhammer
channel. Uh, Counterpoints Politics is where I post the VODs
for my streams. Monday through Friday, I am live on a >> [__]
me. I didn't start my Twitter stream tonight, did I? My Twitter
stream's not running. Oh, whoops. I didn't run my Twitter stream
tonight. Oops.
Oh, well. Oh, well. What can you do? Wait, hold on. I've asked
repeatedly both. Uh, okay. Uh,
so I have asked publicly and he knows I've asked him privately.
I'll just post I'll just post the evidence of both at some point.
and I'll quote this and I'll post our DMs me telling him to go
and ask Destiny for his evidence of this because Destiny does
not have evidence, right? And then his total totally response.
I'll post those DMs and then I will also go ahead and post like
some clips of me basically saying publicly there is no evidence.
If you have evidence of this, give it to me. Also, I probably
can't even do the DM thing cuz um my account's still banned.
I've got no response from Discord yet. Anyway, bro, why don't
you debate him on stream? I already debated him. He on everything.
He completely lost the debate. He admitted he has no principles
and then he walked away. So, it's really up that it's just I
don't know what more to do. Everybody who will talk about this
is like going, "Yo, you're totally correct." And it makes no
difference. It feels crazy. I feel like I'm getting crazy made.
Feel like I'm getting gas lit. Anyway, anyway, continue. Media
Network. V A L O R. Media common spelling. Network common spelling.
Type that into your search bar. Subscribe to it. Watch me from
9:30 a.m. to 2:30 p.m. EST. And then on Tuesdays, I'm live on
my home channel, Counterpoints Politics. But I parasially love
you. I still love you guys even though I chatted mad and used
homophobic language. You literally have had a person with almost
100 posts in the Destiny thread on your stream like eight plus
times. I know, but I think Destiny technically is like he gets
like the pass on that for totally engaging with his Kiwi Farms
thread all the time. Like constantly engaging with them and riing
everybody up. I think he gets a total pass on that for some reason.
I'm not totally sure why. I'm sure somebody could explain to
me why, right? I'm sure that makes sense to somebody out there.
>> No. No. >> Uh, so looking forward to the next
one. >> Hey, thanks for being here, Counter Points. Really
appreciate you. Go check him out. He took time out of his day
to come on our show. Give him that give him that courtesy. Destiny,
please. >> I think it's a good question to ask who we want
to include in our Democratic Party apparatus. OB, I think that
the majority of this has to do with us as being media figures.
So, people in the media. I don't think there's anything wrong
with including people who have some fundamental >> Yeah.
So, in the in the political party apparatus, I'm only concerned
about media figures. Uhhuh.
Does the Democratic Party broadly want like a fest like somebody
who absolutely has multiple allegations of uh of consent violations?
Is that what they want? Is that the look the Democratic Party
wants? Guys, just say base values and agreement that generally
revolve around concepts related to liberalism and free market
enterprise. I think those are hugely important parts of the United
States. I think they're an important part of wealth generation.
Um, even when econom boy brings up, you know, Norway and he talks
about all the money that they get from their global wealth fund,
like the majority of this is invested in literally international
stocks from capitalist ran companies. Um, I think that like the
defense of capitalism and >> that's what economy wants.
Yes. Is to like start buying shares in these things. Yes. To
be invested in the companies of the country. >> Enterprise
is a central part of the United States. >> Maybe even companies
in other countries. Yes. But it's like socially controlled >> I
think that if you want to talk about reforms or redistribution
of wealth, I think all of that is great. All of that can happen
within the basket of a liberal capitalist country. I don't think
that we should seek to keep people inside of our movement who
would literally dispossess the majority of our movement if they
had the power to do so. When people are talking about things
like re-education camps and it's not just random people, but
it is literally some of the largest figures that represent that
label in the media sphere. I'm way more likely to look to that
person. Like Pisco said, I look at use definitions of words,
not just strict definitions of words, than I am to look to the
communist manifesto. And when you >> So Pisco didn't actually
get a chance to uh and I'm sure there's going to be like kind
of for him. He didn't get to point out that Estie's like clearly
been lying and twisting everything here. Oh man, do you peep
this the the counterpoint's response was the response to me?
He's going to say I don't know. Oh, I responded to this and I
said, "Can you confirm to me that like I've I've reached out
in private and said, "Hey, can you get whatever evidence you
have from Destiny?"
Uh actually, hold on. Let me uh let me respond to him because
I I actually did he did respond to me as well. Hold on. Hold
on, hold on, hold on. Let me go and grab my Connor response here.
I asked you to ask Destiny for this evidence and and and he essentially
he provided you
you nothing proving the allegation. Okay, people like that or
people like Aaron saying that they would ban all. >> Sorry
about I'm sorry, but concerning the comment like 3 minutes ago,
who from KF Thread has been on stream? They're not public individuals.
I did not think. Oh, Destiny. That's the joke. Destiny is the
person from the KF thread who has been on the stream. Destiny
has posted dozens of times, hundred a hundred times apparently
in his own thread. Destiny is the person who participates in
the Destiny Kiwi Farms thread who has been on the stream. He
is the only person that I've had any contact with. And I don't
know if that's like his justification here or what's going on.
We'll see. Forms of private enterprise or all forms of private
property. I don't think that these are people that you need to
ideologically align yourself with just the same way that I would
ideologically align myself with some third positionist because
he says he also wants social healthcare. he just only wants it
for white people. Uh so he's willing to have for everybody first
until we kick all the black people out. I think that when we
talk about who we should include in our movement, I think one
of the most important things we should look for is reciprocity.
I think that this conversation would be totally different if
there were all of these socialist shows where people like Crystal
and Kyle were arguing back and forth with each other about like,
hey, don't you think we go like a little bit too hard on the
liberals sometimes? Doesn't don't Crystal and Kyle promote a
lot of Democratic candidates? I don't I don't know if he like
realizes the per the people he's like putting this if they just
all turn and start going against the Democratic party that hurts
a lot. That would hurt a lot. >> Don't you think that maybe
we should be like a little bit nicer to some of these people
rather than who the can we primarate in the Democratic party?
Who are these uh like moderate liberals that we can excise or
like >> is that actually the is that the vast majority
of Crystal's engagement? Crystal Ball's engagement with Democratic
politics is who can we primary? How can we the Democratic party?
Is that true?
last show that I just watched before coming on here where Crystal
Ball is literally excoriating
a a Michigan senator because she doesn't have the most pure position
possible on Israel Palestine. So I don't think >> is that
is that even like an accurate thing or what is she excoriating
for? Like I I don't know the actual material fact there. What
is Slotkin's position on Israel Palestine? >> We should
align ourselves with a group of people who say caught a liberal
and a fascist bleeds and liberals always side with fascists.
And I think that if you were looking at people you wanted to
align with, look for people who are also building a bridge your
way. Not just people who are looking to funnel people off of
your movement. >> Crystal and Kyle literally offer for
Pisco and Josiah to come on all the time. They're literally building
a bridge with Pisco.
They just don't like
Okay, they don't like you. You are a weird degenerate. You are
a weird freak. That is that's just you. You are the only person
these people don't like. You are the one nobody wants to build
a bridge with because you are a disgusting freak. That's it.
What's confusing here?
Crystal and Kyle and the Vanguard people are trying to build
a a bridge back to Econo Boy and Pisco and Hutch even. All these
people like each other. It's just you. That's it. And nobody
has to like you. I don't like you. Okay. Thank you for being
here. Check out his channel. I don't really need to promote him.
He's the biggest guy here. Uh Econ boy, go >> Hey, what's
up guys? I'm Econboy. Boy.substack.com.
If you're interested in any of the writing that I do, if you
want to know what my actual positions are, I did literally write
them down in an article series that's now posted. So, if you're
interested in learning what my real positions are, go over there
And yeah, I'm guessing Cherry, I'm guessing it's the feeling
that whatever Pisco is feeling right now where he got zero zero
chance to actually explain how he's been like maliciously lied
about, how his friends have been maliciously lied about, how
they maliciously lied about straight raid on this podcast, right?
I'm guessing that's going to be frustrating. I'm guessing that
the reason Anna and a lot of other people don't want to engage
is this exact behavior.
What I >> So, not necessarily stuff, but you know, still
being a weird freak. >> I would say about the summary of
the debate is this. Number one, Connor clearly actually doesn't
know about history because he seemed completely unfamiliar with
the entire history of actually existing socialist governments
>> I know this is go yourself.
>> I I didn't I didn't interrupt you. You said I was stupid.
I mean, you know, we're just throwing it back. Connor, calm down.
So the point is K doesn't actually know about history
>> phrasing kind of boy why because he was completely unaware
about the kind of history actually existing socialist
>> in oceania in and also Europe um so that was just the
thing that I tried to add to the debate when it comes to Connor
when it comes to destiny I feel like destiny really did understand
my point about Norway and like Nordic institutions my only point
about that is that the US could build domestic sovereign wealth
funds easier than Norway because the US has a lot of financial
capital available to it, whereas Norway doesn't. Like Norway
literally like the capacity of like the Norwegian financial capital
market couldn't handle all their oil wealth um to the extent
that it could. I would argue that it probably should, but that's
a totally different discussion on the actual topic of the debate.
Here's the last thing that I'll say. I do appreciate that it
seems like Destiny clear. Real quick, I don't know. Can you at least
confirm I asked you to ask Destiny for this evidence and he provided
you nothing proving the allegation? I asked him and he said,
"Y'all are being cute and know what you're doing." And the evidence
he provided of this was,
oh wait, I'm not asking you if he was cute. I'm not asking you
literally anything except what evidence did he provide you? How
am I supposed to defend against a baseless accusation that has
nothing to it? There is nothing there. What am I supposed to
say? Connor, help. Connor, tell me what I'm supposed to do. Connor,
do you want to come on stream? Are you watching right now? Connor,
do you want to come on stream? Explain to me how this is like
you say you hate socialists. I'm literally getting thrown in
a goolog on Twitter. I'm getting blamed for things I didn't do
with no evidence. I'm getting a sham trial. I'm getting thrown
in the goolog. I'm going to Siberia. Help me out, Connor. The
socialists are have me under attack. I'm besieged. Okay, hold
on. I'm like under attack. We're hel held out on a planet. Okay.
And we need the Imperium to come and rescue us right now. Connor,
please. Where's the Imperium? Connor, I need the Imperium now.
I think if I do a 40k reference, he'll see this and he'll want
to come on stream. Connor, are you out there? Connor, hello.
clarified and narrowed his position to a substantial degree that
we shouldn't treat everyone who uses the socialist label as an
instead we should treat certain people in the socialist left
media space as quote unquote and to kind of exclude them from
the movement. I pointed out several times that that is actually
a statement that all four of us all five of us I guess >> I'm
so sorry that I'm the people who actually wanted to watch this
debate if you wanted to watch this debate.
Anything to back that off? I know Solo joined on Discord of Jtock
at one point and got instabbanned. Same with other known KFERS.
So where does this rumor come from? I don't have any evidence.
I don't swim in these waters. I So there is no evidence being
provided. I just want to point out what spineless pieces of these
people are. Okay, Connor. Total spineless piece of [__]
Should it should it not be incumbent on you as this person's
quote unquote friend to go, "Hey, you're like you're totally
trying to like slander this person with no evidence. You need
to show me something for me to feel comfortable associating with
you." Is it is it feeling better now that he's doing it to Pisco
or
like Connor, what do you think prevents him from doing it to
you? >> Actually agree with that to the extent that people
in the media are like like militantly anti-democratic party and
just like really bad faith with Democrats all the time and they're
trying to just occupy Democratic spaces for their own ends and
not to try and you know push forward an electoral movement. We
should exclude them from the inner party and from strategic discussions
and from platforms like the DNC. I've only said my position I'll
repeat is that we should take >> he will stand by the I
know he stands by the figuratively figuratively consent violator
not an actual not a literal physical penetration
got to be accurate guys advantage of their platforms in although
I will say by Destiny's own standard where we're going to hold
jokes to people or hold like half statements to people absolutely
by by Connor and Destiny's standard okay Connor thinks Destiny
cannot joke he's jokes way too much about with children right
that's Connor's Connor's own words. Destiny jokes way too much
about with kids, kids off kids, all of this stuff, right? And
then by Destiny's own assertion, oh well, we have to hold people
to these individual statements, even things that were possibly
made in humor. So, I guess by Destiny and Connor's joint powers,
Destiny is in fact a I would never argue that personally because
I think that's a really crazy line to cross, but by Destiny and
Connor's own standards, Destiny is provably a far as Democrats
actually want to like participate in their platforms, not them
participate in our platforms. Um, and I think that was just a
useful clarification to the extent that Destiny and Wick are
interested. I look forward to the to the to to the the socialism
versus capitalism debate in the future. Um cuz uh it seems like
the people want that as well. But I'd have fun doing it. Anyway,
it was really fun, guys. Uh and uh these were there was a lot
of useful clarification I feel like and yelling and yelling between
Desi and Pisco. And I love you too, Connor. Even though uh you're
um No, I'm just kidding. Uh but I do love you too. Okay. Thank
you for being here. You can check out a >> Okay, we got
the Pisco closing arguments coming up. I'm just grabbing
refill my water. I've been yelling a lot. Jesus Christ. Give
me a second. >> I've linked it in my YouTube description
and you can find them streaming on live and learn and other podcasts.
Thank you for being here. Really appreciate you. Peace. Go. >> Yeah,
as I predicted, I don't think there's a ton of substantive disagreement
here. I think at the heart of this is some kind of semantic confusion
or a debate about what the term socialism means, what the term
uh communist means, and these different subcategories of people.
And and there I just think that there's a bizarre interpretation
and special pleading really from Connor and Steven, you know,
that socialism doesn't include singlepayer. Well, if use is meaning,
that's, you know, people call that socialized medicine. You know,
socialism doesn't include places like, you know, China. People
use that term that way. You know, the the major socialist figures
in the Democratic party wouldn't be considered by most people
who use the term socialism to be socialists themselves. That's
not how people use the term. But that's kind of a semantic disparity
without much significance to it. But actually check out the the
substantive disagreement here. When it comes to Marxist Leninists
and the people when we use the term like tanky to refer to people
who like substantively don't believe in our constitutional order
or who substantively want to get rid of the rights that we hold
dear. There's a full agreement. We don't agree that those people
should be making decisions. We don't agree that they should be
in the halls of power. I think that we agree that like we should
interact with them in in terms of it where it's useful for Democrats
to do that. I think that that's fine. So, I don't think that
there's actually much disagreement on that um on that front at
all. But it seems like there's like a special pleading I'm going
to say for the kind of prescription. Okay, we should kick out
people with a socialist label, but just in the media space, not
people who are politicians. If they're politicians out of the
ticket, he shouldn't let the
um but certainly like we should kick out economy from Lib and
Learn um because he uses the socialist term label, but is that
more of a problem with the name of the show being live and learn?
Is that the problem? Or is it the problem that he uses the social
label at all? Um and so what actually is is the problem here?
is a problem that we were too tonally respectful to uh the Vanguard
when we were discussing I want to sort of stress again how to
best implement the Biden agenda. It wasn't a discussion about
socialism versus capitalism. We weren't saying like oh yeah maybe
we should have a Vanguard party. It was a discussion about like
tactics that Biden could use to implement his own agenda and
what tone policing that like we were we were around when there's
big >> crescendo means buildup. Oh, I probably did mean
climax then. Thank you. substantive disagreement and we gave
our back into Hutch on discreet points like on the mansion point
on the Joe Biden legislation accomplishment points on the point
about the student loan stuff. Uh if that's the case why doesn't
it apply equally to Steven and Connor who sometimes yeah they
disagree I agree they disagree when they when they bring on some
of these conservative figures but they play nice with them. Uh
Gourd 36 we mostly just laugh when Destiny is a totally to loser
and refuses to take any position on anything.
Hey, Destiny. Would you say that like being Arab, okay, being
Muslim, uh, you know, might be tangibly linked to Islamic terror?
Um, no. I don't know if I would say that. I don't necessarily
know if they'd be linked. That's your guy. That's your guy.
Oh my god. Fundamentally, it's a respectful conversation. You
talk to Ben Shapiro, respectful. Talk to Myron Gaines, respectful.
Even, you know, talk to Nick Fendes at a certain time, respectful
conversation. Um, so is it really just the tone about it? Um,
we didn't get too much into the specific examples of us. >> I
actually really want to read this message, but I'm just gonna
pull this guy's message up. I never said Hassan, whatever you
want to call him, wasn't a
on the specific semantic disagreement about like uh trader and
communism versus Marxist Linism. I think that's an interesting
semantic discussion. I think that Steven and Conor points are
probably wrong about that, but I don't think that that's anything
about what's going on here. This is not about those distinctions.
It's not about our distinctions on the First Amendment and should
viewpoint discrimination matter for support of terrorist groups
or anything like that. >> Getting denied a driver's license
is the same as getting denied global entry. That's literally
not what Pisco said. But you're probably enough to believe that,
aren't you? Go ahead, join the Discord. Hop in the waiting room.
It's not the same. It is a tangible benefit that the government
grants that can't be taken away for protected speech. That is
the point. That is the point. That will always be the point.
What's going on here is frankly this is my opinion realistically
these guys hate Hassan for probably good reasons some good reasons
and so we're all just trying to get at that and calibrate >> it
is hold on Gord Gord 36 hop in the discord if you're not a complete
and I'll unban you hop in the discord come on and argue it and
you can explain your point go ahead >> our ideology and
our rules and our prescriptive rules on that specific >> doesn't
matter if global entry is a discretionary program. >> Um,
and I don't think any of it has to do with like major substantive
disagreements on the merits. And I think that that was shown
today. >> Okay. Well, thanks for being here, King. You
can leave if >> Damn. Did we just lose Steven? >> I
think he got bored. >> It's probably true. >> That
was rude. It >> is what it is. >> I'm a professional.
I stayed till the >> Well, thank you. But, um, if you need
to leave, you may. Uh, I have some people who want to come in
and and talk and things like that. You could stay if you'd like.
Um, but yeah. >> Any of them. Aaron, >> it has to
be a narrow thing. Okay, so Pisco is literally just saying that
any any tangible benefit
taken away for your political speech is bad. A government provided
tangible benefit taken away for your political speech is bad.
Being taken away because you're a security threat is fine, right?
If they believe you're a security threat, but your political
speech shouldn't be a part of that analysis. Does anybody misunderstand
that? Your political speech should not be a part of that analysis
at all.
That's the point. Okay,
if it is a part of that analysis, then that is wrong. It should
be protected. Just like the fact that you are black should not
be a part of that analysis of whether or not you're a security
threat. If you think it should be, you are aing idiot. Unless
Fentes, no. Pisco argued that Fuentes should not have been stopped
from flying because of his political speech. That is literally
a part of Pisco's argument.
>> Why not? >> Why not? Okay, let's bring on some
>> I got two callers. >> Yeah. Uh, it does go into
it could go into security threat analysis. It can't be your specified
reasoning, right? Like basically if you went and they had intelligence
that you were like coordinating with and you're an actual tangible
threat, that's not your political speech, right? It might be
the reasoning to go and look at you, but it can't be the reason
to stop you or to retract a benefit. That is the whole point.
It can't be a reason to retract the benefit. If they wanted to
investigate whether or not you were a security risk, I believe
that is fine. >> Oh, it's Dev. I guess I got to stay in
>> history speaks. Couple of famous caller >> Famous
caller iners. Okay. Hi guys. You're live >> and you're
muted both of you. >> Yeah. Well, that's on your ends,
gang. I'm not sure. Oh, we're going to get the super chats at
the end of the stream gang. I will read super chats. It will
be at the end of the stream. Don't worry. Do >> not miss.
Yeah. Hello, Dev. >> That was a show. >> Political
speech involves political threats. It should.
Why? Uh, so it depends on it depends on if it's a threat. If
it's a threat, then it's exempted from free from free speech,
right? If it is if it meets the uh the Brandenburgg standard,
right? If it's incitement to violence, then it is actually not
a part of free speech and it's fine. But it has to be actual
incitement means approximate, right? It means you are actually
telling somebody who can actually do some effect. You have to
be inciting violence in some way. But then that has nothing to
do with political speech either. This has not protected any speech.
It wouldn't matter if it was if it was political or not. Right?
So, I would argue that the tweet, the Shinszo Abby tweet with
the gun, that's like to me that's right on the line. That's like
right there, right? But the Rick Scott thing is not. The Rick
Scott thing is not even close. It's not even close. And if anybody
thinks so, go ahead and join the Discord. I'll just point it
out, okay? If I'm banning you, you are welcome to join the Discord
and actually come and argue and not be a whiny
[__] Okay. Like your daddy.
Go ahead, join up. Come argue the points if you want to do that.
Yeah, it was pretty it was pretty great.
>> I thought it was absolutely hilarious. >> And
Destiny, thank you for the raid on YouTube. I really appreciate
you. Okay,
>> watchers are watching. Okay, >> Dev, I am hungry.
Do Do you have anything that I need to address? >> Uh,
I don't think so. If you want to go
>> okay, I parasially love you guys. Looking forward to
the next fight. Sorry for using homophobic language and abbleist
language. >> I'll catch you next time. >> See you
later. Okay, so what what you guys are here? You have some questions
for Boy or Pisco? They're the ones that >> Yes, boy. >> I've
read your substack. I know what's going on. I have >> I
believe when when dev says he read a thing, I believe him. He
probably really did read that entire >> Is there any content
here at all? Is there like content left here or >> So when
you say that this is socialism, I don't I I don't buy it. It's
it's sovereign wealth funds and it's from what I understand it's
like
stock portfolios. I don't see the >> 1.5 maybe. >> It's
collective ownership of the means of production. >> Okay.
Like I could I could a lot of different things. >> What
do you think socialism is, Dev? >> I agree. >> Dev
knows. >> It's a broad term. Why are you guys like immune
to like people use the term you >> the content now is to
get Pisco that clip? Yeah, I would say I would probably switch
over to Pisco's stream and just see his like postgame cuz I think
it would be very funny. >> Use the term to refer to like
socialized medicine and that is how it's used single health socialized
socialist >> Yeah, he's still going to be here. >> I
don't think so. I wouldn't put it >> People use that term
to refer to those kind of things, right? >> Oh, but that
that really though. Well, that for instance, okay, I don't think
it's to say that singleare healthcare is like a socialist institution
for instance, right? Many countries do have privately owned for-profit
insurance companies. However, in like your country, Canada, that's
that's a publicly owned service, right? Like it's a socially
owned means of production. The thing that they're producing is
the service providing insurance. >> Well, no. Um Yeah.
Yeah. The insurance is funded by by taxes, but the actual hospitals
and the clinics are all privately owned. >> Oh, right.
No, I No, I'm not I'm not >> making any broader claim.
The insurance industry, and I understand you guys have some private
options. I'm just saying that, you know, there's some private
schools, but it's mostly public schools. You could have totally
private insurance. You don't. you have mostly publicly owned
and democratically accountable insurance. That's just like and
that's just and I'm not saying that that makes Canada a socialist
country, but it makes Canada a country with one more socialist
institution than other countries that have private insurance.
>> See, whenever I've debated other socialists who weren't
you on this topic, I've pointed out that you could then go over
to Germany and they had a lot of a lot of similar things where
the state was involved in production. They go, "No, no, no, no,
no." And they really don't want to give that policies.
>> My my answer to that would be that um there I think
there is probably a meaningful semantic disagreement about what
it means to own something, right? Right. So, I think that where
most socialists are coming from is they would typically say this
these are like the same type that would say like the USSR isn't
like really socialism because it wasn't democratic in nature.
It wasn't true horizontal ownership and like democratic ownership,
public ownership because the public didn't really like own and
hold accountable the institutions of Germany even though they
were government owned. And so, I think there's probably there
probably is a meaningful difference in the type of ownership
that the government provided to its citizens and the type of
ownership that like the Canadian government provides to it to
its citizens, sorry. Um, but to the extent that we just want
to say like, hey, like anything that's owned like by the government,
I guess, is like a form of collective ownership that >> I
don't like that. Oh, globe hard. It's just so you actually need
to watch uh critically I think to see like basically in my opinion
I penalize somebody for not actually arguing in good faith right
like so so when somebody basically gets asked something like
would you say Muslim terror or sorry would you say being Muslim
is linked to Islamic terror and the guy goes I'm not sure I don't
know if those things are connected I would say that I penalize
that sort of total disconnect from reality I penalize super hard
okay I I think that's insane. That's not what Pisco asked. Stop
lying. What do you mean that's not what Pisco asked? That is
exactly what he said, is it not? His whole point is we should
be able to revoke a driver's license on the basis of somebody's
racial identity because that racial identity is tied tangibly
to some kind of terrorism. Stoping Islamic ter He did say Islamic
terror. What? Why am I being gaslit?
>> Monday through Friday, I am live on >> What are
you guys talking about? He absolutely said >> I for I'm
not similar. Do you think that Hassan would enact a genocide
in no is the answer that I truly don't know. But then watch this
discrimination my inclination but regardless it is if that is
a truth if it is a truth or not. If the truth so what about a
driver's license? >> No discriminated against for like
Yeah. Yeah. Yes. The fact that the most likely statement that
you've attributed and what I probably agree is in base restriction
you put in discrimination that would be insidious and yes yes.
So let me ask you let me ask you a question. So with respect
to a driver's license do you think that this is
So Pisco can't even answer ask you a question. Destiny's just
going to spur and be a total sped, total loser. Some DJers probably
actually like think this is like good debate or something. Um,
this is embarrassing. This should embarrass you, right? It's
a total lack of ability to engage with the other person who you
know is smarter than you and so you just muddy the waters by
being a total fat.
No,
I'm going to dodged more. That's right. I do pivot. I dodged
the pivot. I dodged your pivot. I mean, I can already see this
entire conversation. I'm gonna say, "Oh, driver's license is
is a right." Oh, it's a privilege. Wait, wait, wait.
>> Yeah, this is like total lack of ability to engage with
the points because he knows he's totally wrong.
>> People like this apparently arguing like a 10-year-old.
This is apparently inspirational to people. It's shocking to
me that the Democratic party wants nothing to do with this person.
It's totally baffling, isn't it? Wow. Isn't that crazy that they
don't want They don't want this guy this this like 40-year-old
this 40-year-old defender. That's who they want. That's who they
don't want. Why wouldn't they want what's not to like, guys?
What's not to
>> Sorry. Metaphorical spiritual defender. Not actually.
Not actually uh what do you call it? Found guilty. >> Already
admitted that you don't think kicked off of an expedited security
list on on
should someone be denied a driver's license? Because driver's
license is not a right. It is a privilege. It's purely at the
discretion that the state if they wanted to can kick you off
a driver's license for something trivial for you know for a parking
offense for anything really. You know there are tons of different
restrictions that don't have to be uh you know totally tailored.
Let >> tailored Wait. What does strict scrutiny entail?
Pisco. >> Yeah. Yeah. You need a compelling
purpose for for global entry but as a security threat it's not
a compelling purpose for a driver's license. Explain >> Because
I think that there are a lot of people that can have some kind
of support for terrorists or whatever that can drive them in
a car. I think that the uh interest on the side of the citizen
for having a driver's license or driving around just because
you have a support revoke your driver's license
people terrorist use cars to kill people is terrorist use cars
just like they kill people terrorists use cars to kill people.
Islamic terrorists use cars to kill people just like they
>> Oh analysis that you said
>> dude this is just dying. Oh I need a time stamp. Hold
on. I need a time stamp for where this is. Minus 3238.
Minus 3238.
I need a different tab cuz this is going to blow up. Sometimes
if the if the chat runs too long, it's Oh. Oh, god damn it. For
whatever reason, hit that like >> nice with them. >> Or
title campaign against there until all of the there was any kind
of something. You did agree into that something he said.
>> Oh, wait.
[__] Totally.
Wait a minute. >> Totally tailored. Wait, wait. What is
>> Yeah. What is it? >> The fact that it might make
them somebody who's worth screening in the >> Hold on.
>> For having a driver who's driving around just because
you have a support or whatever for some terrorist they can revoke
your driver.
Terrorists use car people. Islamic terrorist car people. >> The
other part of the strict scrutiny engage with Desty's strict
scrutiny argument. um that the reason you even if you are doing
strict scrutiny like that still I believe even if it's like the
the strictest level of scrutiny there are some some reasons you
shouldn't do it for there there are some protected versions of
speech you shouldn't do it for right >> the analysis that
you said narrowly tailored do you think that revoking a driver's
license from somebody is narrowly tailored
travel
>> like even if it's so it's global expedited entry can
you revoke global expedited entry because somebody is black.
Is that legitimate? Is that okay? Killer Mech, answer the question.
Can you revoke somebody's global entry because they are black?
You have to argue yes. If you agree with Destiny, you have to
argue yes. It wasn't revoked. It was revoked. It was How do you
actually How are you arguing this? You don't know it was revoked.
What the if you were talking about banning him from all air travel
lights. Well now, hold on. Now we've got that is not something
clear. If you wanted to an
right for a speech nearly tailor and I believe it is narly
speech it's not their speech they're not they're not making their
speech illegal they're not crafting the law against the speech
in any way shape or form no they're not they're just not having
them security list which is not even remotely comparable to having
a driver's license and you [__] know that. Okay.
So, respect the Muslims if if you had a ban and just to finish
this with respect to Muslims who you know have a you would agree
a higher incidence of Islamic terrorism, correct? >> Okay,
there's the point. Now, who are the people who argued that he
didn't ask for Islamic terrorism specifically? What is Nessie's
answer here going to be?
>> Was this Killer Mac? >> They might. Yeah, probably.
>> They might. Muslims. They They might.
>> I don't know if that's true or not. >> I don't
know if that's true or not. I don't know if that's true. They
might, but like I don't know if that's true or not. Was it Killer
Mech? Was it Killer Mac who made this argument that that Oh,
that's a totally legitimate question. Killer Mac, go ahead. Explain
why you aren't
Explain why you aren't a totally cognitively
right now. Go ahead. Where'd you go? Killer Mech. Killer Mac.
Mech completely cognitively. I totally penalize this kind of
this kind of argumentation where you can't engage in any sort
of good faith with anybody. Yeah, this is embarrassing.
You should feel embarrassed for participating in this, for liking
this, for for thinking this is like ownage, for being like, "Oh
my god, he's totally got him." When he just won't engage with
any of the other guys points. That's so base. That's so cool.
That's so cool. Actually, Killer Mac, you admit now that you
are totally wrong, right? You're totally wrong. You were totally
cognitively
when you said that. Oh, no. Destiny didn't say, "No, being Muslim
is not linked to Islamic terror." He didn't say that at all.
He didn't say He didn't say, "Oh, I don't know. I could be. Maybe,
maybe. I don't know." You admit that you're totally Totally cognitively.
No, I was not. Wrong answer. >> Let's have more. Don't
wait. >> Oh, also gentle whale, thank you for the 10 gifted
earlier. I have not actually reset the meters here. So, hold
on. We got 10 gifted three
uh 75. So, 30 bucks 38 bucks onto the next hour of the stream.
We got another hour. Got to add that hour. 1 hour 30 29
29. Let's go. There we go. 1 hour 30 29
based. Awesome. You love to see it. All right. All right. Did
the mech guy actually make his point or is he still just totally
What's embarrassing is you dating what Destiny threw away. You're
You love her. I Hold on,
brother. I do love her. Yes. Yes. Apparently, that is embarrassing
for you. I don't know why you would find it embarrassing particularly.
Is it possibly that you will never know the touch of a woman?
Is that possibly what we have going on here? Is uh is that what
we actually have going on? I Oh no, the the the message went
away. Hold on. I need to pull it back up. I need to pull it back
up. Lau,
are you good? Are you good? Kmart Wings of Redemption is not
happy about my relationship, guys.
How will I ever >> Nationalist do more terrorism in the
United States of Muslims.
>> Yes. So, but specifically, okay, so let's take white
nationalists. Do you think it would be acceptable to say white
nationalists need not apply for global entry? the depend if it
was like something like let's say it was like >> these
people have been blown out on the arguments and now they're just
going after my relationship thinking that that does anything.
Uh, we see you. We see >> The Proud Boys. I would say probably.
Yeah. Let's probably Yeah. For security screen, probably. Yeah.
>> What a great night.
I've already said that. I've already said that. My comments online
and I even joke about it that if my global Yeah, I get it. Yeah.
It's global entry here. Regardless of this, we have a difference
opinion about the right here. I'm not being un if I'm just like
a hedge of a two week total vindication. Totally right on this.
>> We have a disagreement. We got Steve and I have this
disagreement about how much the right should protect. >> Is
Kev hopping on? You guys can hop on the Discord to get unbanned.
By the way, >> this is saying that we have to with respect
to giving Hassan a pass. I have a more protection of the first
amendment than you do in this particular messages. Why isn't
that not an honest disagreement? Why does it have to become I'm
being a